[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous au coiffe et bienvenue
pour ce
jour 3 du de la aique avec évidemment
Maxime va chez Lagrave et aussi
Magnus Carlsen Ali resa qu'on va suivre
tout de suite et il faut rappeler qu'il
y a 5 jours même si c'est la grande
finale aujourd'hui alors c'est pas la
très grande finale c'est la grande
finale simplement mais en tout cas on a
Magnus Carson face à Maxime va chez
Lagrave en deuxième partie
de soirée journée comme vous voulez à
20h vers 20h à peu près quand à l'IRESA
aura fini son match donc comment ça
marche cette histoire je vais vous
montrer ça tout de suite
on a Magnus Carlsen face à Maxime
Achille Lagrave dans la winners final
mais c'est double élimination ici et
donc
quand c'est double élimination
et on peut perdre deux fois c'est à dire
qu'il va falloir battre deux fois
probablement manuscrite pour l'emporter
dans ce tournoi et donc
ça sera pas une masse à faire déjà
aujourd'hui on a quatre parties on a
quatre parties pour
pour les deux joueurs donc voilà tandis
que dans le loser bracket comme on dit
on a ma meilleure guéri et Ali resa face
à Yann les pomyachi
en deux parties
salut à tous j'espère que tout va bien
au niveau du son j'ai baissé un petit
peu mon micro on a aussi j'ai un petit
délai honnêtement vous voyez ces images
avec une minute
soit très exactement 60 secondes de
retard pourquoi et bien tout simplement
pour des raisons
évidentes de j'ai les parties en live et
donc en fait ça change rien vous les
vous les verrez au même rythme que moi
mais j'ai un petit délai sur le sur le
chat de 60 secondes pour pas que les
gens voient les parties en direct et
éventuellement donne des coups même si
c'est ça serait de toute façon
quasi impossible à réaliser mais en tout
cas mieux vaut trop de précautions pour
le système anti triche que pas assez
et donc c'est une précaution de plus
qu'on m'a demandé de prendre
alors ce qu'on va faire c'est le format
vous le connaissez maintenant on a on a
ça on aura la grande finale évidemment
la grande finale à Toronto du 9 au 16
décembre ce sera ça sera vraiment pour
le coup
ça sera du vrai
[Musique]
du vrai du vrai eSport et donc les
joueurs seront dans la même salle mais
joueront
dans des
joueront dans des endroits différents
non au même endroit mais je rentre
devant un ordinateur pardon et on va
regarder tout de suite Ali resa ça a
commencé
ça a commencé dans le moment les joueurs
devraient arriver sur vos écrans je fais
ça parce que je dois avouer je veux pas
balancer mes dépôts il est pas
franchement arrivé à l'heure notre ami
ouh là allez Reza
ça c'est pas les raisins ça c'est une
époque ah mince j'avais une chance sur
deux
j'avais une chance sur deux donc on va
changer tout ça regardez-moi ça on va
faire de la magie
de la magie
non il faut que je fasse comme ça à la
main tant pis tant pis vous allez voir
les prouesses techniques de Take fraise
voilà encadre bien des pots après on
l'aura vraiment pour tout le match et on
va évidemment regarder la partie qui va
bientôt arriver
sous vos yeux ébahis
voilà on voit là il y a des pots yashi
et allez resa qui va certainement
qui va être là que je vais prendre en
direct aussi mais il faut que je le
bouge évidemment
et Yann il est là et oui c'est les
joueurs qui arrivent un peu en retard
bon ben voilà c'est comme ça on va tout
de suite aller attraper la partie
pour vous voyez le début de cette partie
on va faire masquer les parties
terminées et comme ça on a Ali resa face
à Yann les pomashi oh là là c'est très
chaud d'entrer entre les deux joueurs on
va aussi rattraper la petite la partie
en live que vous puissiez bien voir tout
ce qui se passe
et voilà désolé pour ces réglages un peu
de dernière minute mais c'est un petit
peu
sans vouloir balancer
c'est un petit peu à cause des joueurs
à cause de Yann et Achille là pour le
coup voilà allez on va avoir on a les
deux joueurs et on va voir tout de suite
le début de partie donc toujours en bas
vous avez le direct et à ma droite vous
avez le chéquier où je fais des flèches
je fais des choses et j'essaie de vous
expliquer un peu tout ce qui se passe
alors on a une italienne ok G5 donc ça
c'est très très agressif de la part
d'Ali resa en menace d'attaquer un F7
donc l'antidote très connu c'est de
jouer simplement des 5 puis on prend
cavalier à 5 fou B5 C6 puis on prend ces
6 puis on prend ces 6
et foudet 3 qui est la variance moderne
on peut jouer faux de fou de thé le coup
connu à l'époque mais fous des trois est
simplement l'idée de revenir ici
évidemment ça facilite pas le
développement de ce de ce fousser un
et H4 qui est très connu on joue à 6
damage 5 c'est très très complexe ce
genre de choses je suppose qu'après
Jessy sur aidé des choses comme
fulprange ici et il joue dans F6 si un
épaules F7 il doit avoir une histoire
comme ça par exemple cavalier F4
attention pas de dames ou G6
et sur quel est le cas d’âme 6 on fait
B3 avec les Blancs ok ok
et bien allez résa qui nous joue une
prépa alors ça a l'air très très risqué
ce qui fait les raisins la jauge n'aime
pas du tout alors avoir
à voir
avoir ce qui va se passer
dans cette partie
et
[Musique]
peut-être que ib4 alors le premier coup
qu'on regarde qui est B4 pour attaquer
le fou des trois
intéressant intéressant je sais pas du
tout j'ai pas du tout la réfe la
cavalier F4 aussi évidemment est un coup
vous voyez qu'avait les F4 ça a quand
même ça met une grosse pression être
obligé de faire de la F3 et bon pourquoi
pas on essaie de s'accrocher à ce pur en
plus
c'est risqué évidemment mais c'est comme
ça qu'on peut essayer d'obtenir
l'avantage j'ai 6 dames 2 jouer très
rapidement sur dam F3 je suppose que F5
était assez méchant celui de 4 donc il
décide de jouer dame 2 c'est évidemment
une préparation du côté de Ali Reza
firuja notre jeune ami qui on le
rappelle assez simplement deux parties
alors ça sera en 4 pour le grand match
le grand format
entre Maxime va chez Lagrave et Magnus
Carl scène qu'on verra tout de suite
après
dès que c'est terminé en gros 10 minutes
après vous savez il y a les petites
pauses alors c'est quel maillot n'est
pas porte je sais pas n'est pas les
blancs
mais non
nettoie les blancs oh la boulette
la boulette je tournais chez qui je suis
vraiment désolé les poils et blanc et
c'est une époque qui joue tout ça ça
m'étonnait de mon petit Ali resa je suis
vraiment confus
nettoie les blancs incroyable
ça commence mal ça commence mal ce
stream j'6 d'un E2 F5 et EC3 mais
heureusement il y a des gens très
alertes dans le dans le chat je suis
vraiment désolé je suis vraiment désolé
ça m'étonnait aussi de voir jouer nepo
comme ça de devoir jouer à les raisins
comme ça avec de prendre un pion comme
ça et après d'essayer de le garder
surtout que mes potes joue des pétroches
en fait il y avait plein de choses
bizarres
donc là c'est clair que des pots connaît
et à lireza connaît pas mais ça a l'air
tellement bizarre pour les blancs et
tellement dur à jouer mais bon après
tout dépôt il sait il a l'air de savoir
ce qui fait
un petit peu ça parce que j'avais pas
fait
voilà
la pendule
on a
alors et il joue au 4 maintenant et ça
sera la première réflexion de Yann les
pomyachi d'am2 F5 les conclusions on
change pas évidemment les couleurs
changent mais pas les conclusions c'est
à dire qu'on a beaucoup de jeux
et dans mes fins E4 fou et deux et je
sais pas pourquoi j'avais je m'étais dit
que ally resa avait les avait les blancs
bon c'est comme ça est-ce que les deux
donc non les deux sont pas préparés mais
Ali resa bon ben ça fait pas du tout
peur ça avec les noirs on se dit qu'on
va toujours avoir du jeu ce qui est vrai
mais alors est-ce qu'on va avoir assez
ouais faut le G7 sur la grande diagonale
c'est hyper logique fou B2 ou X3 il est
il est quand même assez coutumier il y a
des pommiers de ce genre de semi bluff
c'est à dire c'est variantes qui vont
certainement surprendre sur l'adversaire
qui sont pas objectivement pas terrible
mais il joue la surprise il joue des
positions compliquées après tout c'est
du rapide fou B2 je suppose qu'il veut
faire cavaler à 3 et grand rock bon bref
c'est pas très joli tout ça mais
un pion qu'est-ce que je vous dise les
échecs modernes
impardonnable cette erreur je suis tout
à fait d'accord je vais me décaler tiens
comme ça serait bien au milieu au moins
j'ai fait tout plein de trucs pour
essayer d'améliorer le show et voilà que
je me trompe dans les couleurs le la
base mais bon pas si longtemps que ça
soyez indulgent je compte
je compte sur vous
ouais on comprend rien cette position
moi non plus je comprends rien il y a du
jeu c'est évident on va essayer de faire
rock peut-être c'est 5 qui est 6 moi je
prends les Noirs tous les jours
honnêtement j'ai jamais aimé jouer comme
ça il va faire cavaler à trois grands
rock peut-être F3 un moment pour essayer
de valoriser son pion en plus tout
simplement
c'est ça le c'est ça le concept
et dans l'autre demi-finale on aura
Guilhem à média Rohff donc à noter que
dès demain je vais vous montrer comment
ça marche bah dès demain loser semi
final donc c'est deux joueurs se
rencontrent tandis que le perdant de la
finale sera reversé directement dans
cette looser final donc il attendra son
adversaire donc vous voyez l'avantage
qu'on Magnus et Maxime qui sont qui
peuvent revenir dans la grande finale
finalement ils ont comme match à gagner
pour revenir dans la grande finale donc
c'est quand même assez intéressant ils
sont déjà garantis d'être dans les trois
premiers parce que ils peuvent oui c'est
ça ils sont garantis Magnus Carsen et
Maxime bachelagrave d'être dans les
trois premiers donc c'est quand même
déjà sympa car les Détroit échec et oui
ça c'est une idée qui existe et
effectivement si on prend du fou on va
reprendre avec échec donc ça ça n'irait
pas du tout donc à mon avis il faut
prendre du pion c'est obligatoire
et c'est pas obligatoire du tout si on
prend
et ensuite j'ai l'impression qu'on a pas
trop le choix on peut pas toucher
mais quel va être l'idée des blancs ici
sur cavalier A3 on va se prendre fou à 6
et ça va pas être tout rose parce que
sur grand rock il va y avoir puis on
prend le 2 tout simplement donc là il
est 3 jolies coup de la part de Yann et
pomyachi
pourquoi prendre autant de temps à ce
stade parce que la position est complexe
et chaque coup va très cher c'est pas
c'est pas une italienne fermée qu'on a
habituellement c'est une italienne
complètement ouverte avec beaucoup de
jeux donc la valeur des coûts est très
haute
et donc je peux comprendre à l'IRESA qui
prend énormément de temps c'est vrai
dans ce début de partie
mais la position est tellement complexe
qu'un seul coup et on a plus de
compensation on a l'impression de moins
et contre un joueur pareil ça va être
compliqué
Magnus mvl quand c'est deux joueurs
finissent 10 minutes plus tard en gros
voilà quand ces deux joueurs plus
guérisent un média off donc on verra à
priori en compte vers 19h45 19h50 un
début mais après il peut on peut avoir
des matchs très longs des parties très
longues Armageddon interminable c'est
toujours pareil on sait jamais à
l'avance
et roi D1 jouer assez rapidement Parian
éponyachi donc maintenant il menace tout
prend des trois donc si on prend le 2 va
être joué puis on prend dam prend mais
après dame prend on apprend x 6 ah c'est
décompensations quand même à faire grand
rock on va mettre une tour en 8 c'est
qu'on passe sur quand même assez
évidente alors ouais l'ordi la jauge
montre un léger avantage blanc mais
franchement
franchement ça donne pas du tout envie
cette position quoi que sans les dames
c'est déjà mieux après on n'est pas
obligé de prendre on peut faire on peut
faire petit rock directement ça va être
le choix d'aller esa ici non il prend et
il va jouer petit rock ou alors voici
ses chèques quoi que le roi des 1
ensuite c'est deux peut être pas mal
mais non il fait fois 6 ok roi des on va
être joué très certainement c'est jouer
à tempo il y a une époque il y a une
tendance à jouer très vite
allez-renza allez noir ah oui pardon je
vais retourner chez qui live hors
décidément décidément
je sais que vous êtes indulgent
heureusement heureusement vous avez bon
coeur moi je vous le dis
heureusement que vous avez bon coeur
avec moi et oui je retourne à chiquer
live c'est à lire Isa qui a joué cahier
des trois Ali resa les Noirs dans cette
partie dans cette première partie il
aura les blancs dans la deuxième ça sera
beaucoup plus simple 3D un grand rock
vous qu'est-ce que je vous dis c'est la
force de l'habitude d'avoir les blancs
de son côté et j'ai oublié de changer et
c'est vrai qu'on aime bien voir et on
aime bien voir
[Musique]
de notre côté oui on rappelle Maxime qui
tabasse ma médié
à l'un contre les resa et ma média Rohff
ces deux derniers jours très très bon
même on va dire ces dernières semaines
parce que c'était c'est la continuité de
ce résultat au tata style rapide il a
aussi a réussi à se qualifier c'est pas
une masse affaire au playing c'est très
très fort ce playlist il a de jouer de
manière très convaincante ce planning et
donc c'est qualifié pour cette division
1 déjà ce qualifier c'est quand même
c'est pas évident mainus avait eu avait
même Magnus avait eu du mal donc voilà
tout est tous les espoirs sont permis
pour aujourd'hui évidemment évidemment
Magnus Carlson reste le boss
surtout en ce moment bon un peu toujours
ces 10 dernières années mais là il a
gagné la Coupe du Monde il gagne un peu
tout sur internet ils viennent gagner le
speechess mais
clairement il restera favori ça c'est
une évidence mais Maxime est peut-être
le seul joueur du moment qui peut lui
poser de vrais soucis
et donc on a hâte de voir ce match et on
va voir un très beau match en Suisse
certains vu l'application aussi que mes
collègues Maxime ces derniers jours dans
ce dans ces tournois online il aimait
métamorphosé
il avait une petite tendance à jouer un
peu moins un peu moins concentré c'est
tournant online mais maintenant il est
très très concentré on voyait les
pommiers qui est probablement dans sa
chambre d'hôtel Amsterdam où il a gagné
le la lévitov chez swick donc voilà les
joueurs jouent de tournoi de tournoi en
même temps c'est la magie
des internets
c'est assez incroyable cette époque on
vit une époque assez formidable pour ça
on peut jouer depuis chez soi entre
quelqu'un qui est à l'autre bout du
monde tandis que aller à est à Paris
visiblement roi c'est de tour HDV 8 ok
on a mis les deux tours ça c'est très
logique on veut empêcher attention parce
que c'est vrai que s'il arrive à faire
qui est C3 tours à D1 les compensations
vont être dur à voir mais tourner 4
j'aime beaucoup parce que ça attaque ici
ça laisse la pression sur le plan des
deux
et maintenant ça peut être évident pour
Yann des pomyachi de de se sortir
donc il faut faire attention
merci mais merci beaucoup kabilca alors
là tu peux pas me faire plus plaisir
ouais alors ouais effectivement
dingueren question très pertinente dans
le chat
digne ouais disparu des radars je sais
pas ce machin champion du monde la
visiblement
émotionnellement au minimum la
complètement épuisée et donc il joue pas
il joue pas il joue plus
alors est-ce qu'il va défendre son titre
très probablement ça veut pas dire il a
pas annoncé de retraite ni rien mais
c'est vrai qu'il joue nulle part même
les tournois online qui nous met bien
jouer les jouent plus
ils se reposent c'était quand ce
machinalement c'est en avril ça fait
quand même ça fait
ça fait pas si longtemps que ça vous me
direz
ça fait 5 mois c'est qu'on est habitué à
avoir les joueurs jouent tout le temps
mais finalement on a le droit de se
reposer aussi de profiter de ce titre et
cette c'est un coût thématique pour
revenir dans la course par là ou par là
des choses comme ça on pouvait aussi
envisager le coup ces 6 C5 suite et C6
peut-être qu'il a eu peur sur ces 5 de
tour E5 attaque un peu tout ou peut-être
tout aussi même attaque le fou et
attaque le pion c'était intéressant et
donc il décide de faire quai B7 Ali resa
on voit qu'il accéléré un petit peu le
mouvement ils veulent lancer 5 alors il
faut voir ce qui se passe surtout aussi
maintenant je sais pas trop ce qu'on
fait surtout aussi peut-être tour des 6
tout simplement pour empêcher quand même
ton processus régional ou tu reprends le
6 aussi
mais c'est vrai que ça enlève un peu de
pression tout ça ok c'est 3 on peut
envisager tourage 4 maintenant que le
pion est en H5 on va récupérer notre
pion surtout on va faire roi des 7 ou
quasi automatique pour pas laisser la
tour s'infiltrer intéressant intéressant
ce cette position et il fait pas du tout
ça il fait tout au 5 à toute blindes il
y a des pots très très vite dans c'est
rapide il fait ça même en live lui c'est
pas du tout pas du tout Internet
pas du tout il joue pareil sur internet
ou en vrai il joue très très vite il met
une pression dingue au temps toi F4
attaque le pion F2 et maintenant comment
on fait après on va faire F3 ouais il
traîne pas traînent pas il y a une
éponyashi G4 vient tout de suite à
l'idée comme ça sur pion prend on fait
tour reprend ah il faut être fin pas mal
coup caché mes coups coups pas mal parce
que comment on fait pour protéger ce
purger de on ne peut pas et si on le
pousse on va prendre le pion et ça va
être complexe pour le champion
russe
comment il fait là n'est pour peut-être
aller un coup de développement
maintenant écoute développement ça perd
la ça perd les deux pions donc faut
rester en perdre qu'un sur les deux
ouais non une date de retour prévu je
crois pas je crois pas pour Ding pas
pour l'instant après il peut jouer où il
veut
c'est quand même le privilège d'un
champion du monde c'est-à-dire qu'il a
envie d'aller jouer avec un zig il a
joué avec un
alors comment on fait sur fouet F1 pour
Yann les pommiers qui réfléchit beaucoup
là
il a bien raison
il a bien raison parce que c'est
maintenant ou jamais parce que si il
perd ses deux pions il peut même perdre
celui-là H5 et ça serait évidemment
complètement dévastateur
donc comment on fait là
et bien j'en sais rien
comment pourquoi la jauge ne mets pas un
bel avantage noir je vais mettre la
petite variante qui peut être utile
quand je vois vraiment pas ce qu'il faut
faire c'est tout aussi c'est le coup ici
je pensais qu'il est tour des 6 ici
allez à tour
G64 et surtout on prend aussi ce que
c'est élégant puis on prend le 6 c'est
le pion fit la dame
ok ok alors ça faut le voir quand même
tout aussi et Kate ici c'est le meilleur
coup il est noir un petit avantage déjà
d'après la jauge
c'est pas étonnant parce qu'on encaisse
tous les pions par exemple sur deux on
va prendre ici et c'est très chaud on a
ces deux pions passés liés on a récupéré
notre pion c'est archi chaud mais alors
tout aussi quand on vient de jouer tout
au 5 c'est pas évident à faire donc
j'aime bien j'aime bien Ali resa la
position dans les resa qui prendrait une
vraie option SI s'il l'emporte
alors il fait oui
ou là on dirait qu'il y a quelqu'un qui
rentre dans sa chambre
peut-être la femme de ménage
je sais pas trop ce qui se passe enfin
la tête il a pas l'air ravi et c'est
toujours l'inconvénient quand on joue
dans un hôtel ça peut se passer comme ça
il a pas battu Magnus alors champion du
monde par intérim pas champion de ouais
mais les absents toujours tort
moi je suis plutôt team les absents en
tort et joue G4
allez zafiruja
je sais que je peux être fan de Magnus
mais effectivement il veut pas des
formes son titre alors peut-être qu'il a
raison peut-être qu'il a tort mais en
tout cas
bien Ding et le champion du monde ça
c'est une évidence
alors j'ai 80 à deux options maintenant
soit on prend en G4 soit on prend F3 il
décide de prendre G4 assez rapidement
les raisins puis on prend il va prendre
de la tour je suppose et récupérer son
du
à moins qu'il puisse faire ça aussi
peut-être
ouais
5 le petit train
ça peut être sympa parce que c'est vrai
que sur ton plan G4 on va certainement
faire que ces trois et on va en faire
sortir avec les Blancs
on va voir
on va voir ce que fait
notre jeune ami à
ouais c'est vrai qu'il s'est désisté
alors qu'il est encore le meilleur et
qu'il continue à jouer et surtout
c'est ça aussi la différence c'est que
au moins faire la différence la grosse
différence avec Fisher qui était encore
le meilleur quand il s'est existait
c'est qu'il a
c'est qu'il a et qu'il a arrêté de jouer
derrière
il a repris 20 ans plus tard
et fois je crois quand même jouer fou
prends j'ai 4 attention il faut F5 qui
menacent faire bouger la tour là quelque
chose comme ça et donc pour laisser la
case B2 oui bien sûr c'est très bien vu
ça de la part de Yann les pomyachi mais
d'après la jauge les Noirs ont
l'avantage certainement à cause d'un
coup comme vous pouvez le 5 aussi
simple cela puisse paraître mais il y
aura tout aussi c'est quand même qui
attaque des pions
ce qui va je crois que les blancs et
c'est déjà s'en sortir ok c'est 4 fois
F5 échec ok roi B2 va certainement
arriver oui pour laisser sortir la tour
ça a beaucoup de sens et fou des trois
menaces vous prend ces quatre et tu
reprends des deux
c'est pas mal tout ça
c'est pas mal de la part de
d'aller résa j'aime beaucoup ce qu'il
fait sur cavalier 3 il va faire tout F2
certainement
et non fait toi aussi maintenant il
essaye clairement il est en mode
j'essaie de tirer ma nul sur fou prend
ces quatre il va faire tourner 6-3b8 on
va le voir ton C6 va arriver c'est sûr
roi B8 et là il comprend la tour du pion
plutôt du pion quand même quoi que pas
sûr parce que cavalier à 5 peut faire
très mal s'il fait ça mais là il est
clairement en mode défense pour prendre
des deux échecs va être joué très très
certainement
et les noirs sont mieux c'est une
évidence est-ce que les blancs peuvent
sauver très certainement aussi
peut-être tourage d'eux aussi menace tu
reprends H5
au tour prendre d'abord
on va voir
ce qui va vouloir faire
notre ami à
ouais alors il y a des statistiques qui
ont été faites qui a le plus dominé mais
les époques sont tellement différentes
moi j'aime pas du tout comparé
celui qui a le plus dominé
en termes de niveau
ces Fischer qu'il était très au-dessus
des autres celui qui a le plus dominé en
termes de longévité qui est pour moi mon
goût personnel
termes de longévité c'est le plus
important parce que je pense que c'est
le plus dur de dire
c'est casse pas off
voilà
et Magnus est un peu un peu entre tout
ça
parce que quand même il a eu des matchs
champion du monde assez serré Magnus il
faut dire ce qui est alors il fait
cavaler à 5 on va faire on va B4 qui est
C6 va arriver il va faire c'est 5 je
suppose il a pas réussi à la gagner à
lire les raisins
pourquoi il a fait il a fait il a pas
voulu faire tourrage 2 certainement à
cause de toi 8 et avec des contre jeux
c'est vrai
roi B4 va être joué ou à C2 mais roi C2
j'aime pas trop tourage 3 ouais on
attaque ce pion tomber on va faire roi
c'est 8 je suppose
oui tout à fait il y a un décalage je
l'ai dit au début on m'a demandé
gentiment de mettre en décalage parce
que comme je l'ai parti en direct
et bien pour une
[Musique]
encore une garantie antitriche et les
parties en direct moi et donc c'est
sympa de voir les parties en direct avec
les réactions des joueurs mais ils m'ont
demandé de mettre 60 secondes de délai
entre le stream
entre le moment où je parle et le moment
où c'est diffusé
sur les internets voilà
donc
ça c'est un petit 60 petites secondes
des cartes
voilà mais bon on peut se parler quand
même c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
dramatique je trouve j'espère
parce que c'est vrai que voir c'est
parti en différé alors je pouvais voir
avec une mine de retard mais du coup
comme j'ai les caméras en live parce que
je suis dans le call zoom je raconte pas
si je dois faire un décalage dans le
zoom là je m'en sors pas là c'est l'ordi
explose
pour le faire je sais même pas c'est
possible certainement
ça serait peut-être le mieux mais bon
c'est bien comme ça je pense
alors on a quand même pris un pion ok
tourage 3 tours H5 et c'est 5 il se fait
contre jeu assez rapide j'ai 4 et quand
même petite pression là pour les blancs
alors pour les Noirs pardon puis en plus
donc c'est sûr qu'on risque rien comment
il va faire
les pots là
alors le matériel très réduit faut voir
il y a très peu de pions garantie
garantie sur un jeu précis la nul au
blanc mais attention là oui attention
faut être précis parce que c'est quand
même deux pions passer lié
potentiellement ça peut faire très mal
est-ce qu'on fait tout ça ici tours 5 à
l'aide il coûte automatique
ouais c'est ça son ordi les trois plus
les trois joueurs les plus précis de
l'histoire sont Magnus casse pas
réfléchir mais on parle des époques
différentes où on s'entraîne pas avec
les mêmes avec les mêmes avec le même
matériel voilà
c'est Magnus à disposition stockfish il
a appris de Kasparov des parties de
Kasparov donc voilà chaque génération
est de plus en plus forte c'est normal
parce qu'on apprend des précédentes et
en plus maintenant il y a les
ordinateurs qui sont venus se mêler à
cette à ce petit jeu donc effectivement
alors on voit ces 6 et surtout F6 est-ce
qu'on va oser monter c'est pas sûr parce
que six qui peut arriver assez vite j'ai
l'impression que tout F6 doit être le
coup pour assurer la nul tout F6 roi des
5 c'est chaud très bon
pourquoi C6 j'ai roi prend non puis on
prend et tomber 5
et ça ça pourrait gagner ok donc Tour
Eiffel 3 c'est 6 ton F6 roi des 5 et
assez mauvais pour les blancs donc faut
pas jouer ton F6 pardon autant pour moi
et ton G7 jouets en attaque le pion et
il est là hein il joue quand même bien
c'est parti rapide qui est français 5 ça
va pas être assez hein ça va pas suffire
on pourrait certainement faire mieux
avec la technique de Vancouver
la défense devant courage qui sont très
mauvais pour gagner
pour les pour les Noirs en finale de
tour donc ça devrait pas suffire c'est
pour ça ici il va se il s'attaque au bon
pion il connaît tout ça il y a des
pomyashi même si c'est vrai qu'hier il a
fait il a montré
[Musique]
une technique un petit peu défaillante
dans ce roi d'âme contre roi tour ça
c'est sûr contre Magnus Carlsen
c'est très dur
mais avec Magnus qui qui défend comme ça
OK prend ces cinq tours J6 d'abord
attention pas de gaffe bonjour les amis
Ali resa 3D 5 cavaliers F6 mais bon
n'importe quel autre coup droit paroi
des 7 évidemment
et ensuite on va on va courir par là bon
il fait des échecs ok une emportera pas
au Paradis ah mais attention sur quel
prend ses seins qui échec non il faut
faire ton projet 4 c'est ça
OK
ouais les blancs peuvent se tromper mais
bon ça devrait aller quand même on peut
faire ton projet 4 et c'est nul
ça y est c'est jouer en mettant le roi à
5 alors est-ce que c'est vraiment bien
ok ça c'est complètement nul c'est 100%
sûr
parce que le roi aura le temps c'est à
dire que si on s'organise à mettre la
tour là le pur en H3 et faire le grand
tour avec le roi pendant ce temps le roi
va venir manger ce pion et en général ça
se termine on est obligé de sacrifier la
Tour Blanche sur le purge c'est ça le
scénario et ensuite on a le pion a et on
va essayer de damer le pion
oui j'ai vu l'interview de Hans
on en parlait hier
je sais pas ce que quand on pensait
soit avocat est aussi ridicule
c'est bizarre de venir avec son avocat
dans une émission de télé
enfin bon j'ai pas très bien compris
c'est quand même bien pourrir et c'est
gagnant d'après la jauge mais non
mais non non
c'est nul
peut-être c'était tour c'est 5 et H5 le
coup et après on venait avec le roi
est-ce que c'était ça le coup attendez
je vais regarder là parce que là c'était
gagnant
est-ce que ton C5 gagner
non peut-être
c'est ça que je voulais faire et faire
le grand tour avec le roi ou par là
ça c'est vrai que ça peut gagner
mais là c'est redeveux de redevenu nul
alors attention vous voyez comme quoi
Jean du chat qui disait qu'il avait des
chances avaient raison
après
le moins pire c'est peut-être un
pire
moi sur le coup il a triché à 12 ans ok
c'est un gamin il a triché à 16 ans
est-ce qu'on peut lui faire confiance à
20 ans
globalement je trouve que c'est un bon
argument
après évidemment il y a pas de preuve
donc on peut pas non plus condamner à
vitam æternam les gens mais
effectivement
ça arrivait en dire à 12 ans j'étais un
enfant oui mais à 16
on est on est moins un enfant quand même
toujours un enfant mais bon on est un
adolescent donc voilà
je trouve que son argument tombe un peu
à l'eau ça argument j'avais 12 ans
j'étais un enfant je me rendais pas
compte ce que je faisais tout ça à 16
ans il se rendrait très bien compte
alors 6 et maintenant et il a passé la
tour comme ça est-ce que ça serait pas
compliqué là déjà pour les blancs le roi
maintenant on va passer
il vient avec le roi par là maintenant
les pots ça de manière très aléatoire je
trouve
la jauge qui change d'avis
c'est pas du tout la main et pas du tout
ferme pour défendre cette finale de tour
et maintenant il fait tout rage 5 est-ce
qu'on fait tourger de H2 non il fait
wave si il veut venir avec son roi par
là
et deux pour faire au F2
peut-être
non
ok
donc on peut pas faire on va prendre
parce que le pion finir à la dame et en
fait on G3 maintenant
2 et il vient avec le roi
encore une fois et il a gagné une petite
colonne
ouais c'est très dur à gagner avec 3
secondes à la pendule si on connaît pas
si on sait pas entraîné vraiment
de manière systématique sur l'ordinateur
je pense que c'est compliqué
alors pour ces trois
oui on parle de Nice sur YouTube
tout à fait
ouais non c'est vrai qu'on peut être
bête à
16 ans aussi évidemment mais à 16 ans on
se rend compte de ce qu'on fait ça pas
d'histoire à 12 ans d'accord moi je veux
bien
merci
donc voilà je trouve que c'était un
pointé du doigt
sur ce coup là
sur ce coup là je trouve qu'il pointait
du doigt quand même une
[Musique]
contradiction de la part de neiman
ok donc maintenant il fait le tour par
là ça ça va perdre a priori on va être à
temps le roi il va être trop loin
clairement on va montrer
et on est pas si loin que le roi mais
c'est un peu juste il manque un tempo
voilà c'est au blanc de jouer ça serait
nul mais deux et à deux
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a fait il a joué
tout F4 tours c'est deux reprend H 3
tours prend à deux et roi G3 qu'est-ce
que c'est que ce coup de roi G3 fallait
faire tour à 4 évidemment
quoi que c'est peut-être gagnant
maintenant je sais pas qu'est-ce qu'il
fallait jouer
surtout un roi G2
et si on roi C4 oui on fait échec comme
dans la technique de Vancouver on fait
des échecs comme ça
il a raté la défense
ouais il est pas technique hein
le roi arrive
et ouais la technique il a raté la
technique de Vancouver
que je vais vous remontrer en fait que
les noirs et un pion à choupass ça ne
changerait mais là c'est fini tour à 8 3
C4 n'empêcher le roi de passer la
technique du coup d'épaule et on va
aller par là les pots qui va bientôt
abandonner 4 minutes à la pendule oh là
là il a joué beaucoup trop vite c'est
complètement foutu maintenant
oh là là quelle mauvaise partie quand
même quel mot est technique on va
regarder ça tu reprends à deux et là
évidemment il fallait faire tout F3
voilà un coucou mvl ouais je vois tempo
c'est 4 on peut même on peut même
attendre un coup moi j'ai trois et
l'idée ça sera des rois avec 4 en acier
de bouger à tour hop là échec hop là
échec
en plein échec en plein échec on peut
déjà on peut pas se soustraire des
échecs à moins de revenir par là mais à
ce moment-là on revient avec la tour en
F3 et c'est complètement nul dès que
le
tour vient ici on vient très vite avec
l'oranger de pour empêcher à deux et ça
va être la même histoire et sur à deux
on va simplement faire tour à trois
maintenant et sur roi B4 tour à 8 et on
va les échecs comme ça quoi qu'on
pouvait continuer les échecs comme ça on
pourrait faire ton F2 sur sur à deux
tours F2 était aussi très bon
non toi j'ai un pardon
n'importe quoi bon on va voir maintenant
et à lire et zafiruja là emporter
évidemment je vous l'avais annoncé
c'était gagnant quel manque de technique
de la part de Yann des premiershi pour
un candidat titrementaire c'est quand
même dur à regarder
surtout que les deux minutes à la
pendule donc il aurait pu prendre un peu
de temps
1-0 pour aller Raisa et bien écoutez
on est content tout simplement on va pas
on va pas bouder notre plaisir
notre ami notre ami est beau les cas
jouer un peu moins évident c'est pas
pour toi non
non
et un point pour notre ami à les raisins
voilà un zéro
et oui non ça c'est sûr ouais ouais non
mais franchement
je remonte à la Cité nul et c'est vrai
qu'on est le pion ou pas ça ne change
absolument rien cliquez ce pion h ou pas
ça ne change rien sur la défense
maintenant tout F3 évidemment était le
coup
tout F3
et roi 4 elle a eu peur de ça il tombait
trois maintenant et toi un roi G2
roi des 4 et ton F3 et voilà ou alors
tour G3 ou on met le rouage 2 en fait
tour G3 et on fait l'essuie-glace comme
ça je vais le montrer pour un rouage de
et ça ça ne change rien ça sera la même
histoire sur roi C4 hop là faut les
échecs on suit le roi et la tour ne peut
pas
protéger son roi et donc ne veut pas
s'interposer donc c'est
nul tandis que là c'est perdant une fois
que la tour peut venir latéralement
c'est à dire ce roi G3 tourbé 2 et à
deux tout simplement parce que on va
faire passer le roi par derrière et on
pourra interposer la tour une fois qu'on
sera à trois par exemple
vraiment bon mais GG à l'ireza bien sûr
il a su il assume elle la pression
être très bon est-ce que guéri et ma
média off on en terminé oui
a gagné avec les Noirs contre chacun ok
ça nous prenait peut-être des matchs
très rapides et les deux joueurs qui
gagnent avec les Noirs c'est quand même
intéressant évidemment à lire Isa qui
aura les blancs dans la prochaine donc
c'est quand même plutôt plutôt très
encourageant cette histoire
et il y a une pause entre looser le
winner bracket ça enchaîne ça enchaîne
elle somniaque blood je vais vous passer
ma pub obligatoire
je vais regarder d'abord je vais vous
montrer le bracket vous voyez 1 0 1 0 et
la looser demi-finale la demi-finale des
perdants sera joué dès demain donc 18h
on se retrouve pour très probablement
ce qui est favori au moment où je vous
parle c'est une demi-finale entre alias
firoga et Annie qui rit et le vainqueur
de ce match là jouera le perdant du
match de la grande finale
entre Magnus Carlsen et mvl et le
gagnant de cette finale des perdants
aura une deuxième chance contre le
gagnant de la grande finale j'espère que
je suis clair et si il gagne il rejoue
encore une fois mais cette fois en deux
parties donc ça peut être un vendredi
très long
si jamais ça se passe mal pour le
vainqueur d'aujourd'hui entre Maxime va
chez Lagrave et Magnus Carlsen on va
évidemment suivre ça avec beaucoup
d'intérêt je reviens dans quelques
petites minutes en compagnie de notre
notre jeune ami
jeune ami Ali Reza Mbappe qui n'en finit
plus de nous étonner qui a perdu
simplement que contre son compatriote
Maxime chez Lagrave qui a fait un gros
match mais qui est en train de très très
bien revenir dans ce tournoi à tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je suis donc de retour pour cette
artificial intelligence Cup
voilà on est au dans le loser bracket
évidemment aujourd'hui la grande affiche
ça sera Maxime bachelagrave Magnus
Carson juste après cette première partie
et qui est quand même très très sympa à
regarder
clairement avec Ali resa qui a gagné
cette première partie avec les Noirs
donc
c'est quand même pas mal du tout
alors j'essaie de me reconnecter
j'espère que vous me voyez
oui je pense que tout marche mais j'ai
un petit souci avec mon petit ordi en
face de moi bon bah rien de rien de très
grave on va se mettre sur les deux
joueurs et on voit Ali résa firoga qui a
donc les blancs face à Yann epomashi je
vais vous le mettre partout cette fois
on est sûr qu'il allait blanc c'est
quand même c'est comme ça la bonne
nouvelle et évidemment qu'est-ce qu'on a
on a un petit fou mais cinq échecs des
familles ça mange pas de pain il a bien
raison notre ami à lire Elsa
et on va essayer de remettre sinon je
peux pas trop voir le chat en fait c'est
plus compliqué
on va essayer de remettre l'Internet
mais vous inquiétez pas pour vous ça
marche
et foub5 et 17 jouer c'est le coup pour
essayer de gagner à 4 ok c'est pas
forcément bon c'est solide clairement de
toute façon les positions qui découlent
de fou et 5 échecs sont des parties
d'un des parties en général assez solide
G6 ouais clairement montrant c'est
l'intention de jouer un de mettre un
fonds
petit côté ce qui est très très logique
et c'est souvent qu'on joue comme ça
alors il fait petit rock à 6 le fou
est-ce que le fou va s'échanger ou pas
ça c'est une question maintenant parce
qu'on veut prendre et jouer des quatre
c'est une option ou alors on peut on
peut tout simplement reculer soit en E2
soit en D3 même C4 est devenu une option
maintenant
donc je sais pas il va en E2 ok il veut
certainement faire ces trois suites des
à moins que ça soit son idée ça soit de
faire A5 D3 qui est C3 des choses comme
ça qui existe aussi
bref beaucoup beaucoup d'options
salut à toi relax en lac de la night
salut à tous merci de me rejoindre pour
ce
loser bracket mais alors attention
attention après on a Maxime achillagrave
et puis losers bracket c'est quand même
un match fille rouge à
firogène et pot donc c'est pas rien non
plus
alors B6 et maintenant on va
certainement devoir jouer des quatre si
on remonter un peu d'ambition alors
après faut pas non plus on est on est
d'accord avec la nul évidemment mais
faut pas non plus tout jouer pour la nul
clairement
donc va falloir jouer des cartes ouais
c'est jouer d'ailleurs et puis on prend
on va arriver cavalier prend évidemment
cavalier
5 qui va pas tout à fait aller pour
les
blancs donc plutôt F4 F3 des choses
comme ça
pardon
F4 F3 ou alors
des deux quelque chose comme ça
quelque chose d'intéressant
en tout cas nepo
réussit un petit peu
son pari
de créer quelque chose de
une partie vraiment à double tranchant
on va voir comment on va faire le jeune
prince aliasaps
il y a un petit piège sympa
mais qui est dessin qu'on peut juste
ignorer je vais fou B7
kb4 fou B7 ok il veut mettre un cavalier
en dessin que vous voyez
on a eu la même idée
la même idée avec notre jeune ami à
l'IRESA
j'ai plus de wifi mais bon j'ai toujours
l'Internet ça c'est bien ça c'est la
bonne nouvelle
et il fait cahier des 5 on attaque la
dame on a mis un bel avant poste ici
c'était assez malin ce qu'il a fait
peut-être faut trois fous des 4 quelque
chose comme ça
pas sûr
mais intéressant pourquoi pas
salut Aubert
je me rappelle ouais
tout à fait oui effectivement les
loosers
c'est très beau loser
attention
c'est appelé comme ça on aimerait on
aimerait faire partie de ces loosers
clairement il fait tout droit on va tout
rentrer logique
de coach aussi l'avant-poste si on veut
le chasser il va falloir faire E6 et
ainsi
ça fait bien le pion des 6 voilà donc
c'est un bel avant-poste pour les blancs
et donc normalement ça leur confère
légère avantage on peut faire faux trois
fous des quatre ou quelque chose comme
ça quelque chose d'intéressant
ouais c'est vrai qu'il y a un épaule il
a vécu une sale soirée c'était quand
même ballot de perdre comme ça en ayant
toujours les plus les plus moches c'est
à dire que il met une super pression il
fait une superbe dernière partie même si
Magnus avait mate en 5 à un moment mais
un peu
un peu contre le cours du jeu assez
clairement
et
nepo a dominé et donc avait cette finale
roi dame contre retour qu'il a pas
réussi à gagner la règle des 50 coups on
rappelle la règle des 50 coups c'est non
si on joue 50 coups de part et d'autre
sans prise
ni pousser de pions bon là il y avait
plus de pions et bien la partie est
déclarée nulle c'est quand même une
bonne règle pour éviter
que les parties s'éternisent
de manière très logique et de manière
très rapide mais pour
il met la pression au temps quitte à
délaissé parfois la qualité bon là
c'était quand même la première partie il
y a encore en finale de Tours il avait
trois minutes à la pendule il a gaffé il
a perdu dans une position théorique
nulle
franchement il connaît ça il y a même
pas de c'est pas un problème de
connaissance là c'est juste un problème
de un moment de s'arrêter
de prendre 30 secondes une minute et
voilà de jouer
[Musique]
de jouer un coup
un coup tranquille qui était en
l'occurrence tout F3 qui était pas très
compliqué qui était largement dans les
coordonnées pour et qui était dans ses
connaissances n'importe quel
enfant russe c'est bon me semble très
logique faut j'ai 5 aussi un coup
pour mettre la pression un petit peu
j'ai cinq peut-être Dame des deux
faut 3 aussi bon allez ça qui prend son
temps là qui prend beaucoup de temps
faire tour à trois aussi comme il a fait
hier en italien pour faire coulisser la
tour
c'est un coup qui joue comme ça surtout
à 3 par exemple qui prend des 5 on
reprend et vous voyez on a cette tour
qui peut venir jouer voilà j'aime pas du
tout c'est juste pour montrer les
possibilités des blancs
comment on rappelle aussi que dans
l'autre match il y a une autre
du coup c'est un quart de finale sans
être un une demi-finale du du bracket
des viseur plus vu que le perdant de mvl
Magnus va être reversé dans le tableau
mais en tout cas il joue le vainqueur
[Musique]
le vainqueur de ce match rencontrera
Guiri ou ma média Rohff a priori guéri
qui doit revenir
dans ce match
pour
qui mène qui mène contre ma média Rohff
dans ce match pardon
1-0 qui a les blancs dans la deuxième
donc ça a priori à les résa contre eux
guéri
pour un le droit de challenger les deux
champions Magnus et Maxime
Magnus et Maxime c'est juste après vers
quelle heure vers entre 19h30 et 19h50
je dirais au pif
même si c'est pas une science exacte il
a fait F3 qui a pas faiblissant mais bon
ça surprotège le Pione mais ça affaiblit
à grande diagonale on sait-on jamais un
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
conséquences immédiate évidemment mais
ça pourrait jouer des tours donc après
on joue contre le
oula qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
moi là ça y est c'est les vieux
je vais fermer tout ça non qu'est-ce qui
se passe
voilà j'ai un gros problème là comme
quoi il faut utiliser l'Opéra
[Musique]
il y a un message qui s'est affiché je
vous raconte pas
non mais je veux pas ça je veux fermer
moi
je vais essayer de
ça y est
quel enfer
j'ai un message qui s'est affiché
je vous raconte pas
ce que je vais faire
et non ça va pas
alors je vais vous laisser comme ça
ouais
ah c'est quand même c'est ballot hein
non mais je sais comment résoudre le
problème
et ça va être ouais ça va être réglé
dans 30 secondes
bon vraiment bien
mais décidément on n'a jamais tranquille
alors je vais vous le remettre bien
voilà
ouais c'est bon ok donc
F3 qui prend des cinq six carénées F4
qui est c'est 5 ça va faire ricaner dans
le chat mais j'ai eu un coup de poing ça
je vous raconte pas C3 je sais pas ce
qui s'est passé la mc7 x 3 fd8 et la MC2
ok ça joue solide des deux côtés mais
reste pas mal de pièces ça m'éloïde
d'avance pour des pots
ça pourrait ça pourrait jouer des tours
ça alliésa faut qu'il accélère un petit
peu le mouvement mais bon il a très bien
fait dans la première
et vous avez plus le temps tout à fait
exact
vous avez tout à fait raison vous avez
pu étendre
la vie de streamer et pas de Tours
quand on veut j'essaie de bien faire les
choses
et parfois
quand on va faire un peu trop
bien ça peut ça peut jouer des tours
alors
un petit peu de pression joue vite
surtout pas vraiment de c'est une
position équilibrée il n'y a pas
vraiment de plan pour les blancs pas
vraiment pour les Noirs non plus on va
essayer peut-être de faire la même
recette de provoquer une une réaction du
côté de la dame qui ait des trois vas-y
que j'ai envie de t'échanger un peu
toutes les pièces
on est d'accord pour échanger les pièces
on va de prendre et prendre donc
attention
à lui
oui oui c'est revenu c'est revenu le
temps avec une mine de retard mais c'est
revenu
il faut B7 il revient à les raisins pour
y revenir aussi mais bon il y a pas de
raison particulière
le cavalier F4 était pas nécessairement
très très bien placé et il faut avouer
que les pots ne va pas répéter la
position c'est une évidence ça c'est il
va pas il va pas répéter un épaule il
préfère perdre que de faire nul
je vous le garantis
mais six minutes d'avance comme quoi le
chrono ah une importance
oui mais ça arrive après ça arrive après
c'est pas moi qui fait le titre
des histoires c'est après le match MB 24
voilà c'est exactement ça
et oui le mieux est l'ennemi du bien
c'est ça fais attention
donc tour a D1
OK
c'est un bon coup de centralisation
c'est une évidence ça me set il cherche
toujours à garder à garder l'attention
créer un vis-à-vis ici bon même si on
voit pas on voit pas trop comment on va
on va s'en occuper de ce vis-à-vis
mais surtout il joue il joue le la crise
de temps déjà chez elle qui a quasiment
il y a quasiment 6 minutes 30 de moins
c'est quand même énorme
c'est un peu trop
alors A5 ouais ça c'est pour liquider du
matériel
et surpuis on prend on va faire que les
Français 5
certainement le problème de cahier prend
ses 5 direct c'était B prend ses 5 et on
prenait vers le centre et c'est vrai que
ça peut donner un centre très fort pour
les Noirs donc il voulait pas créer ce
genre de scénario à lire donc il joue à
5 et très logique
mais pour essayer de jouer des cinq mais
bon pas tout de suite on peut pas trop
là voilà j'ai l'impression qu'elle prend
ses cinq va arriver suite tout reprend
des 8 et tourner c'est ce que j'aurais
dans cette situation
après faire attention de pas trop jouer
pour la nuit mais là ça a l'air quand
même pas mal
va-t-il le jouer cette liquidation
ça a l'air quand même très solide alors
après faut faire attention à ce purement
à 5 mais quand même ça a l'air
extrêmement solide pour les blancs du
rapport d'imaginer de perdre cette
partie
sinon qu'est-ce qu'on joue remarqué il y
a pas tellement de menaces pour les
Noirs non plus d'un meuf de ok il décide
vraiment
[Musique]
qui fait ça de manière très pro qui
décide de pas être moins bien vraiment
de de pas jouer la nuit à tout prix
et qui met la pression donc sur le
cavalier ok cavalier A4 pourquoi pas on
peut jamais faire B3 à cause de cahier
prend ses trois ça crée une petite
pression sur cette structure B de C3
mais rien de grave évidemment pour aller
raisin est-ce qu'on peut essayer changer
les fous je sais pas fout des cas tu
aurais 5 et peut-être suite des 5 il
faut des 4 jouets
je pense qu'il va être vraiment obligé
de faire le 5 à un moment ou un autre et
ensuite je vais descendre
là ce serait les bonnes conditions pour
jouer des cinq à mon avis
parce que faut prendre des quatre un
mauvais dire on pourrait simplement
reprendre du pion et on serait quand
même très très bien avec les Blancs
surtout que ce four rayonne pas vraiment
il tape sur cette structure
c'est quand même compliqué donc 5 me
semble être
compliqué et enfin le seul le seul coup
pour les pour les noirs
et non
alors laissez mais bon laisser j'aimais
pas trop
simple manger le pion
manger le pion
intéressant
je savais cette question allait venir
je le savais
alors est-ce que ton corps je vais à
Maxime ou vers Magnus les deux mon
capitaine mais bon j'ai été je suis pour
un beau match là honnêtement
quand on a été à tous les matchs
champion du monde avec manuscrit
pour Magnus je peux pas être contre
Magnus c'est pas possible ça n'arrive
pas ça n'arrivera jamais ce que j'ai dit
ça c'est quelque chose qui ne peut pas
arriver mais effectivement ça tourne sur
Internet
maxime est en forme c'est important pour
lui de gagner le plein de confiance avec
l'île de Man
donc j'ai vraiment envie de voir un beau
match voilà avant tout ça sera ça la des
beaux échecs
c'est ça le
c'est ça le but c'est ça mon
mon cœur penche pour un beau match
bien joué les deux côtés
ouais donc allez-y il prend les
répétitions effectivement il prendrait
une répétition dans cette position mais
il joue pas nul à fond moi je présentais
ça qui était
ok certes un petit tableau de faiblesse
mais quand même ça ça a changé pas mal
donc vous défend indirectement ce pion
si Dame prend à 5 on fait B3 tout
simplement et on ramasse le cavalier
donc c'est ça l'idée mais c'est pas un
coup qui fait plaisir à jouer
assez clairement
et comment il va faire ici une peau il
va essayer de d'augmenter la pression
clairement
des 5 il va falloir y passer c'était
demander dans le chat
on a tous envie d'un beau combat ah mais
nepo là c'est trop dur là on a envie de
voir des surtout à les raisins là
vraiment là j'ai aucun aucun scrupule
je veux bien voir les a gagné de zéro
voilà savoir des des belles défenses en
finale de tour par exemple on a été
servi
il jouait 5 d'abord pour sur des 5
empêcher E5 c'est assez bien vu c'était
ce que je proposais avant
je vais dire c'est assez bien vu je joue
mes coups mais non c'est pas ça mais
c'est surtout sur des seins qui a pas de
il y a pas de 5 des blancs c'est ça
l'idée
donc j'ai un tour des 7
évidemment qui espoir
il y a un espoir pour un vélo candidat
il y a deux places à l'île de Man mais
ça sera c'est le grand Suisse c'est fin
octobre c'est à l'île de Man ou jamais
aussi simple que ça enfin ou jamais ou
la prochaine fois en tout cas pas pour
ceci donc voilà il va falloir il va
falloir être fort dans ce tournoi c'est
pas évident c'est un open faut bien
commencer
faut pas avoir des gens qui sert trop la
vie c'est avec les Blancs non plus parce
que si on gagne pas avec les Noirs il y
aura besoin certainement de gagner au
moins une partie avec les Noirs donc il
faut qu'il joue des joueurs qui a envie
de gagner avec les Blancs enfin c'est
toujours pareil c'est très compliqué les
joueurs qui sont pas contents de faire
un bon prix mais qui veulent se
qualifier pour les candidats donc des
joueurs qui prennent des risques
il y a cette magie de l'Open où il faut
avoir un peu de chance au
appareillements aussi alors sur C4 ça
c'est joli sur pion prend C4 il veut
faire tourner à 4 je suppose et sur dame
prend ces quatre badaboum qui prend le 5
terminado il y a le fou ici ça c'est pas
bon et ces quatre menaces quand même de
prendre ou peut-être des B3 c'est pas
mal qu'elle vise Vista tactique de les
raisins c'est toujours très
impressionnant
il a un talent dingue ce jeune homme on
le sait mais on est toujours
impressionné
je suis à 1100 hello j'ai débuté les
échecs il y a six mois je stagne un peu
est-ce que tu arrives à me conseiller à
1100 je sais pas trop mais des exercices
tactiques n'importe quel livre de
tactique assez simple
me semble pas mal déjà
mon système de ninovic
ce genre de choses mais je suis pas très
honnêtement
il a fait bien pensé 4 ok prends le 5 il
avait le choix entre ça et tu reprends à
4 mais c'est pas mal puis on prend tu
reprends un franchement je suis pas très
qualifié pour
pour
et bien conseiller des livres à 1100
hello c'est un peu plus tard mais
regardez des lives comme ça et se poser
des questions et essayer de calculer ça
peut être aussi très utile
sans la jauge sans l'ordinateur faut
regarder ça avec ses yeux c'est de
réfléchir
c'est pas facile les échecs on stagne
tous à un moment même à plusieurs
moments normalement on fait après on
comprend des choses on passe des paliers
petit à petit mais c'est pas évident
c'est pas évident de faire évidemment et
la question est complètement légitime on
peut prendre un coach aussi
il y a plein de manières de faire ça
pour gagner candidate
alors tu reprends il attaque le pion
et qu'est-ce qu'on va être obligé de
faire C3
certainement
tour des quatre et tours c'est ça
et on réattaque ce pion mais quand on
pense pion on perce pion mais en fait ça
va donner des échanges massifs
il y a deux minutes pour que j'essaie de
position et les raisins mais elle est
quand même assez simple son prochain
cours on le connaît il veut prendre ici
ces trois c'est pas bon je pense qu'il y
a tous ces quatre
là j'ai un désaccord
il voulait faire simplement
et je vais tourner 4 qu'est-ce qu'il
voulait faire sur ces trois peut-être
juste puis on prend et en fait c'est dur
d'imaginer que les blancs sont moins
bien avec un fou qui quand même qui tape
sur ce rock F3 E4 tour des 4 tours c'est
un
attaque le pion c'est
et maintenant comment on fait
avec les Noirs est-ce qu'on peut jouer
C3 il y a tout reprend maintenant oh pas
sûr et à tout reprendre
et surpuis on prend on peut faire de me
prendre les quatre échecs
donc en gros ce qui va se passer c'est
qu'on va tout échanger en C4 il va
prendre à 5 on va prendre en C8 en gros
mettons ça ça ça
et ça et ne tient
mais il tente un autre truc
pour CD8 mais à tout repenser 4 là quand
même
attends ok il prend de l'autre tour
voilà pour forcer les échanges si on
veut pas perdre de pion pour prendre si
fou prends et être tourner un qui peut
être pénible
ce qui va chercher à garder le pion
ça fait pas nos affaires est-ce que ça
va être joué tout ça
pour prendre un Massac et la dame C5 mon
petit allez le petit coup sur
allez le petit coup sur les raisins on
l'aime on l'aime le coup sûr
on sait que c'est pas toi ça mais bon
c'est ça qui veut faire quoi demain
madame
c'est 5 et bonne chance
bonne chance les pots
le grand Suisse oui tout à fait
et allez Reza qui a
l'emporter il l'a emporter aussi assez
facilement hier contre la zavik donc ça
fait deux petits matchs là
qui remportent en dominant clairement
donc ça fait plaisir de le voir revenir
aussi bien
et ça montre aussi l'exploit de mvl au
au premier tour d'avoir battu à lire
Elsa c'était pas une mince affaire
comment il va faire les pots et réfléchi
mais en fait si échanger d'amis il peut
pas être mieux
vraiment pas être mieux
on va faire on va faire ce qu'on veut on
sait sept en plus hein qui est vraiment
gênante on sait sept hein en vrai
et comment on fait même pour sauver en
fait c'est pas si évident peut-être
demain
si tourner mais bon on va me prendre 5
G8
on a ce dernier mais on sent que ça va
pas aller loin même tour des 4 tourner 4
est pas mal
pour essayer de changer les tours et
surtout C8 on va faire un coup de tour
des 7 on peut pas faire tourner parce
qu'il y a toujours des 8 et maths
donc ça c'est c'est assez mauvais pour
les Noirs
j'ai 8 et maintenant va-t-il jouer tour
des 4
assez probablement moi j'aime bien tour
des quatre C8 est-ce que dame 7
6 j'aime bien
comme ça sur dame prend V2 on a toujours
des 8 en fait on protège directement le
pion B2
ça sent bon ça sent bon pour aller
raisin ça sent très très bon
attention quand même 38 secondes faut
accélérer un petit peu le mouvement s'il
te plaît pour ces 7 jouer
il fait une grimace parce que surtout D1
il y a dames 8 ok mat
OK
bah oui c'est pas mal ça
c'est même très largement suffisant on
attaque ici on a de F6 ou 7
alors fousser 8 est-ce qu'on fait DAF 6
ou dame 7 c'est ça la question
d'un meuf 6 jouer toi et fidèle jouer
même ton problème c'était pas sûr qu'il
est pas perpette mais on n'a pas du tout
besoin de faire des choses comme ça
peut-être au F2 pour venir en C4 mais il
faut 6 fois aussi c'est le prochain coup
clairement
bref de jouer il faut 6 va être joué
tout recettes peut-être mais aussi
et après les perpettes mais attention
plus de temps quand même ça se seconde
c'est pas beaucoup
c'est la seule chose à dire pour
l'instant la seule chose à critiquer
pour les raisins c'est sa gestion du
temps qui était aléatoire aussi contre
approximative contre mvl bon là faut
jouer à les raisins quand même 4
secondes il va être gentil
non mais il peut pas faire les choses
comme ça
pourquoi il fait chose comme ça de Me
décatres on centralise certes c'est un
bon coup
extraordinaire non plus mais c'est pas
mal coup de centralisation mais bon elle
a 4 secondes il a joué qu'une six vous
rendez compte c'est une coupure internet
alors après on est dans
il est à Paris
on est plus à Chartres non je plaisante
je plaisante
[Musique]
coucou à nos amis Chartres que j'aime
bien charrier un petit peu
non mais à Paris on a le meilleur
intérêt du monde certes mais
quand même c'est un peu risqué cette
histoire de se laisser aussi peu de
temps
faire tomber dessus mais ça c'est mon
c'est mon côté joueur
alors
il joue toujours pour le club de
Chartres d'ailleurs à les hasard même si
il habite plus à Chartres donc
voilà toujours et c'est là où il a
commencé sa vie sa vie française
donc il doit évidemment énormément au
club de Chartres
merde Chartres
qui a beaucoup aidé notamment
au moment où il est arrivé
en France
alors faut deux on stabilise tout ça
mais attention la machin attaquage
et c'est du ouh là là
mais que j'aime pas ça et pourquoi il y
a besoin de se mettre avec ses deux
secondes c'est 5 secondes tomber ça de
Me Mastour des 7 oh là il jouait le feu
bien joué avec 0,7 secondes
et c'est une gaffe tour des 7 mais oui
mais bon j'ai dit
[Musique]
c'est pas raisonnable c'est aussi peu de
temps là
bon on a droit à l'armée qu'est-ce que
je vous dise alors après il sait pas
gagner pour 3 tours donc on se méfie
on se méfie
dame B3 ouais protège et menace à trois
à deux c'est bien joué ça
oh là là
c'est rageant mais voilà il tombe il
tombe c'est vraiment c'est un total
et ouais ouais ouais mais bon
ouais mais c'est qu'est-ce que ouais
qu'est-ce que je vous dise moi
c'est c'est voilà c'est la punition
c'est la punition pour cette gestion de
temps
moi je suis le premier à manger à mon
temps mais bon je suis pas candidat au
titre mondial
ça ne pardonne pas contre ce genre de
joueur ils se sont déconnectés nos amis
pourquoi
allez savoir est-ce que ça joue dans
l'autre partie
on aura un Armageddon mes chers amis
c'est ça la seule bonne nouvelle tandis
que Annie Gery l'a emporté deux à zéro
face à chaque
et donc on a à Nice guéri on va regarder
ça tout de suite
dans le bracket on a guéri qui est la
première des demi-finales les pots à
l'IRESA ça joue à la mer
dommage dommage cette partie derrière ça
parce que franchement
il était en contrôle complet oui oui mvl
Carson est décalé à la fin d'Armageddon
on a un vélo carcène qui arrive c'est
pour ça que c'était aléatoire lors de
l'armée donc c'est un vrai spectacle
tous en chaîne
non mais là ce truc du temps il le sait
très bien en plus
il le sait
mais voilà c'est ce truc de
n'y arrive pas
je sais pas il a pas réussi à se
se mettre dans le truc bon qu'est-ce que
vous voulez ça arrive
c'est comme ça je vais d'abord regarder
je vais regarder
c'est dommage évidemment c'est une
évidence que c'est dommage mais un
partout en trois livres et Yann les
premiers
est-ce qu'ils sont revenus pas du tout
bon alors attendez
je comprends pas là
autant pour moi ils sont pas partis
parce que Maxime je pense est installé
Maxime attends
Maxime je le vois dans le call zoom donc
maxime est là Maxime
alors là il va y avoir un
[Musique]
ils vont donner leur temps
great games
les parties la partie sera à 32
pour les parties disons
moi j'aurais mauvaise
enfin
l'Armageddon sera à 32
donc dans très exactement moi il est 24
chez moi
donc dans 8 minutes
Maxime joue en suite donc ce qui va se
passer
ce qui va se passer ça va être très
simple c'est que je vais faire un petit
bord avec de la pub
et
je reviens à sur les coups de 30 pour
moi donc
après un truc comme ça et j'aurai les
temps j'en saurai beaucoup beaucoup plus
je vous remercie infiniment de me suivre
je rappelle
que on a un Armageddon entre aller à
zafiroja et Anna et pomachi donc comment
ça marche à ma guidon les Blancs ont 15
minutes les Noirs mettent leurs coups
sous enveloppes leur temps sous
enveloppes celui qui a le plus battant
choisi et donc par exemple si nepo met
10 minutes à les raisins mais 9h30 c'est
Ali Elsa qu'elle est noir avec 9 30 mais
il a le droit de faire nul il a les
Noirs il a moins de temps mais il a le
droit de faire nul s'il fait nul il
gagne
et donc après ça on aura la finale le
match de gala entre Maxime va chez
Lagrave et Magnus Carlsen qui sera
évidemment passionnant te
passionnant le match passionnant mais
n'affiche passionnante et donc
[Musique]
on aura quatre parties cette fois en 15
+ 3 ça sera un match évidemment très
très sympa à regarder
on se retrouve ici quelques petites
minutes 4 minutes à mon horloge pour
le l'Armageddon entre Ali resa et
Yann n'est pomyachi à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je suis de retour donc pour cette
Armageddon ou Ali resa on a les
propositions de temps
d'aller resa et de Yann et bien
figurez-vous que Yann a mis 11 30 donc
c'est quand même assez haut
ça ressemble à une proposition de texte
moi je sais ce que je fais 11 30 à peu
près bon je varie je veux avoir l'air
intelligent donc je vais en 37 voilà et
[Musique]
Ali resa a mis 8 58 donc rendez-vous
compte plus de deux minutes d'écart et
donc à lire et ça allait noir
dans cette partie dans cet Armageddon
c'est étonnant quand même les deux
joueurs qui sont pas du tout d'accord
pour on va voir
du temps mais ouais bon c'est un peu
étonnant cette différence de temps mais
à les raisins qui est très content
d'avoir les noirs et les draw hots comme
on dit
avec la possibilité donc de faire nul
mais il aura quand même 6 minutes de
moins c'est quand même quelque chose
ça va reprendre bientôt si elle est
réserveuse bien remettre sa caméra
après je rentre parfois un peu de retard
et ensuite bien évidemment en suivra le
match entre Messi machin grave et Magnus
Carsen
il mettront à mon avis si magnussie
devait en venir là
je pense que
il mettrait des temps beaucoup beaucoup
plus bas
en tout cas un pot c'est étonnant on se
trompe
c'est vraiment
un peu il veut pas avoir les Noirs quoi
il va voir les blancs et mettre la
pression au temps
on va voir
vu ce qui s'est passé dans la dernière
pourquoi pas ouh là qu'est-ce qui se
passe là dans mon call zoom
qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce qui se passe comme un affiché
masquer les participants dans ces pin
pourquoi je vois ça
permet la vidéo et l'écran partagé voilà
et là on voit les raisins contre Yann et
pomyachi on voit les deux joueurs
et ça y est c'est bien parti ça va
partir dans normalement très peu de
temps c'est assez étonnant ce qui s'est
passé ce qui vient de se passer dans ce
jeu du chat et de la souris
mais on va voir on va voir tout ça et on
va voir les parties qui vont bientôt
démarrer là normalement ils ont déjà
deux minutes de retard
bon les deux joueurs qui attendent on va
rien rater bien évidemment de cette
Armageddon
les deux joueurs pas pressés il peut y
avoir parfois des petits
des petits problèmes
pour régler les pendules
ou un type est pas prêt ou la caméra
marche pas ou je sais pas
on sait jamais
enfin en tout cas ah la partie va
reprendre
et avec Ali resa que je vais tout de
suite tourner avant de faire une bêtise
retourner chez qui et voilà on a les et
je vais le mettre sur le petit échec qui
est là aussi
et on va tourner chéquier et ça va jouer
très vite forcément de la part d'aller
résa vous voyez qu'il y a 8,50 déjà
contre 14,50 et D4 jouer donc une une
Nimzo une Nimzo avec trois c'est
vraiment la variante à la mode en ce
moment F3 lire les raisins qui prend un
petit moment de réflexion
et salut à tous dans le chat
et ouais bon ça c'est avant le principal
si on prend B6 on est vraiment en plein
dedans on est en plein dedans c'est
vraiment la variante à battre quand on
regarde ce système
ici on peut même jouer à si je crois
cramique jouer H6 ouais c'est ça c'est
pas étonnant de voir
aller-retza jouer répéter ce qu'a fait
Vladimir cramique qui était son coach
pendant quelques temps
alors tour des trois bons mais tourner 3
au moins c'est c'est pas c'est pas de la
finesse c'est cavalier 5 tours j'ai
trois fautes
c'est clairement un coup d'attaque
autour des trois une petite idée que la
jauge n'aime pas qu'elle ne connaît pas
visiblement
l'Armageddon donc je le rappelle une
dernière fois qu'est-ce que l'armée est
donc
c'est quelque chose comme des tirs au
but pour départager les deux joueurs
les Noirs ont le droit de faire nul mais
ils ont du temps en moins il y a aucun
incrément de A à zé 0 incrément parfois
dans des parties live il y a des
agréments pour éviter qu'on fasse tomber
toutes les pièces et ce genre de choses
mais ici 0 incrément
et donc l'avantage des Noirs évidemment
après non seulement les blancs
l'avantage du trait mais plus de temps
la pendule mais les Noirs ont le droit
de faire partie nul s'ils font partie
nul on considère qu'ils ont gagné
et donc ils jouent son plan cavalier sur
cavalier 5 et il va vouloir faire
tourger trois alors là c'est vrai qu'on
peut essayer d'éliminer du matériel
peut-être vous prendre ces trois
peut-être qu'elle prend 5 suite quai des
5 mais c'est dangereux c'est surtout si
on connaît pas comment le temps est
choisi les deux joueurs mettent sous
enchères ils envoient à l'arbitre
une proposition pour avoir les noirs on
peut même mettre 15 minutes
si on a envie de 0 à 15 minutes on peut
mettre on met ce qu'on veut à lire les
amis
on se trompe ça veut dire que en fait si
elle est résa avait mis 11-20 il aurait
deux minutes de plus à sa pendule mais
ça il peut pas savoir
c'est toujours pareil il a pensé que Ali
resa allait que Yann allait mettre un
temps beaucoup plus
en dessous des 10 minutes quoi en gros
ton C8 tour H3 et attention ça ça va ça
va partir si c'est possible
je vous le dis moi
bon bah c'est pas jouer tout en finesse
tout ça mais c'est dangereux quand même
ça fait peur
ça fait peur c'est pas un truc
positionnel où on prépare pendant 18
coups l'attaque blanche c'est tour des
trois tours des trois tours H3 et vas-y
que cette meuf vous prend H6
ok intéressant
et donc cavalier F5 jouer
ok ça protège H6 ça développe le
cavalier G4 serait un peu tout much à
mon avis mais il doit le regarder j'ai 4
ans
j'ai quatre alerte too much
peut-être simplement ça on attaque le
fou on va menacer de se replier ici ça a
pas l'air il a joué très très vite hein
et plus que 6 minutes pour aller résa
fout des deux cavaliers 4 mais ça il
accélère un petit peu
il a une position tout à fait acceptable
on va pouvoir même faire peut-être des
quais j'ai 5 sur Full par exemple pour
faire kg 5 et chasser la tour de H3
ça peut être
ça peut être ça peut être pas mal pour
les Noirs donc
tout il laisse prendre le fou en général
on se gêne pas
avec les noirs on est plutôt content
d'arriver à échanger de fou
on peut mais ça peut donner des cahiers
qui prend des dames prends des deux fais
attention à quelqu'un qui doit être une
menace peut-être fou des cinq ici ok il
est 6 c'est que maintenant on est on est
beaucoup plus détendu avec les Noirs
parce qu'il y aura pas lu a priori il y
a plus de il y a plus de souffrances
c'est sûr mais plus de sacrifice à h6
peut-être pour un H6 à un moment mais
bon ça paraît assez improbable là il
doit être en train de calculer ça mais
je crois que ça marche pas
et prend puis on prend et hop on protège
on menaçait maintenant G2 évidemment
par contre la jauge elle a montré ça ah
oui
ça même idée si on reprend j'ai deux
dames prends C4 et c'est jouer
paralléreza quel
du prodige
allez résa fu prends G2 et sacrifie la
peur aucune peur et c'est vrai que la
position va être facile à jouer Dame des
cinq et dame prend C4 et ça a l'air
complètement ok pour les noirs
il réfléchit Yann mais il va être obligé
de prendre ouais c'est pris Dame des 5
et d'un me prend ces quatre
ok tout est complètement normal
une qualité de moi mais de belles
compensations avec ce cavalier
complètement idéologable en F5 ce roi
qui va être affaibli on va certainement
essayer de d'attaquer aussi ses pions
faibles très intéressant
ouais c'est un peu du ouais mais ça
apporte bah c'est la touche télé je
dirais ce truc de des enchères pour
l'Armageddon c'est un peu la touche télé
du
de ce champion de chaise tour où on veut
petit spectacle je trouve ça assez sympa
honnêtement
je trouve ça pas mal
donc pour des 8 on veut
bon je joue la tour tout simplement
il va toujours beaucoup de perpétuelle
autour du roi du roi blanc donc ça c'est
pas mal quand même pour nous faut garder
les dames évidemment
pour avoir ses perpettes alors je sais
pas peut-être un jour Damien dame
d'abord à changer les tours
éventuellement
mais je trouve la position plus facile à
jouer après il a 7 minutes de moins
je pense qu'il faut garder les dames ici
à moins qu'on fasse tour C8
[Musique]
OK
il veut faire tourner 5 tours à 5 je
suppose
mais la jauge j'aime pas du tout elle
est comme moi la jauge elle préfère
garder les dames pour une fois une fois
n'est pas coutume cavalier 7 ouais il va
essayer de faire ça
ton C8 une tour en C4
et
c'est quand même c'est vrai que ça
permet de
probablement
si on arrive à faire tout ça un tour C8
on C4D on va sauver la partie
donc il faut faire quelque chose de très
rapide
avec les Blancs
c'est pas évident
c'est pas évident de voir quoi
exactement peut-être à 4 à 5 pour
essayer de
au moins de poser des petits soucis à 4
pour C8 à 5 choses comme ça
qui est des 5 plus c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment affreusement solide F4
que je viendrater 4 aussi menaces
et oui quand on fait ça non seulement le
pion mais en plus
on menace la fourchette alors pour ces
deux a été joué et là à la surprise
générale surtout C8 il voulait faire C4
ok ça c'est malin sur cahier des 5 C4
aussi donc c'est pour ça qu'il a joué
qui est ici pour empêcher ces quatre
on prend en D4
protège ce pion clairement l'enjeu c'est
prochain coup c'est est-ce que les
blancs vont réussir à faire ces quatre
ou pas
tourner 5 là clairement il veut
commencer son harcèlement il veut faire
du Tour à 5 poser des questions forcer
la tour à pacifier en a à deux
c'est ça l'idée c'est certain
est-ce que je peux tenter un truc comme
ça
apparemment non je voulais faire ça
je trouvais ça
et c'est 4 jouets et oui on veut ouvrir
les colonnes quitte à perdre un pion on
va ouvrir les colonnes quand on a une
qualité de plus comme ça
et ça a été raté c'est 5 et là le
problème de C5 si on prend tour prend et
on va perdre ce pion à ça va être fini
c'est fini
oh là ça lui aura joué un tour
incroyable
regardez les peaux qui est très en
confiance
ça lui a joué un tour incroyable cette
deuxième partie
quel dommage quel dommage
et ouais c'est ça gratte par la
patrouille non c'était pas très
compliqué non plus
mais là il est foutu hein il est foutu à
cause de ce pion à il est content mais
pour ça c'est sûr
en plus
ton français 5 évidemment et maintenant
3 5 c'est très simple on va prendre le
pion à on va pousser
et c'est très probable que le câble et
doivent se sacrifier
c'est sûr c'est fini
stock fresh et ouais la petite turbine
tu as vu ça
il faut que je me qualifie la prochaine
fois
le problème c'est pas d'être là à donner
des coups c'est de se qualifier
ça c'est pas facile déjà des visions
déjà dans une division c'est pas facile
division 3 ou division 2
c'est pas évident alors parlons pas Jul
a réussi notre ami Jules
mais c'est clairement c'est plénes sont
compliquées ça peut mal tourner et le
problème c'est quand vous commencez mal
vous les adversaires à peu près de la
même force
et donc ça permet pas de revenir
facilement
bon 2 minutes ouais non c'est terminé
pour aller à aucun espoir il fait dans
la tête il peut E5 qu'est-ce que c'est
que ce
ouais mais là pour prendre évidemment on
va arriver et on va pousser ça peut être
très compliqué ça va être comme tout
autour des trois tour H3
ça va être il va pas aller chercher midi
à 14h je vous le dis il me reste plus
que deux minutes à lire et ça en plus
moins de 2 minutes
il peut il peut abandonner tout
simplement
que le F37 pas du tout ok ça
ce pion à être décidément trop fort je
m'attends un abandon de la part derrière
les eyeline 30 ce que c'est triste cette
deuxième partie qui était quand même
en Contrôle
alors son seul plan ça aide de faire F5
F4 mais bon même ça ça a pas marché
peut-être 3 G3 même
coco Orange
il faut faire attention
parce que ça allait Adam je vais montrer
la petite combinaison de
pomyachi je vais la remontrer au ralenti
mais
je peux leur montrer de façon ça pas
beaucoup d'intérêts ce pion tout reprend
tout reprend qu'elle prend pour qu'on
pouvait pas prendre la tour je lui ai
montré tout à l'heure parce que le pion
pousse
inarrêtable il va Adam et a les raisins
abandonné après moi j'ai deux kh4
évidemment
et terminer victoire de Yann et pomyachi
c'est moche pour aller réserver c'est
comme ça et sur ce je vais essayer
de récupérer nos amis
et
Maxime va chier la grave
on va épingler un maximum
hop là on va enlever
ok donc là pour l'instant j'ai la caméra
de deux Maxime
alors galerie on va faire ça à la
galerie
pourquoi j'ai la caméra devant j'ai fait
n'importe quoi
j'ai absolument fait elle ou à cam1 de
Maxime elle est là
supprimer l'épingle ouais et je vais
mettre alors je m'organise pour voir
pour vous proposer de voir Maxime
voilà
et si Magnus avait la bonté
de venir un moment ou un autre ça serait
quand même ça serait chouette
allez
tiens regardez ce que je vais vous
montrer
j'ai ajouté l'épingle et je vais vous
montrer comment le setup de Maxime
vachere pour montrer quand même le
dispositif anti triche qui a sur ce
tournoi ça peut vous intéresser et on
voit Maxim ici
et de l'autre côté le zoom 2 hop là
Maxime là c'est derrière et on voit bien
ses mains on voit bien tout de la salle
et on demande d'inspecter la salle donc
c'est quand même assez bien fait
on va mettre son petit nom
on va mettre
un petit zéro
pour l'instant en tout cas on va mettre
0,2 parce qu'il y a pas de raison que
Magnus commence avec plus de points
on va lui changer son petit nom
regardez il fait inspecter sa salle là
vous visitez vous êtes dans la dans le
salon de Maxime va chez Lagrave alors
moi la salle la salle où il joue
voilà vous êtes dans son bureau dans le
bureau de Maxime il a montré voilà si on
lui demande de pas éteindre le son et de
montrer un peu son environnement
vous l'avez vu en direct voilà c'est
exactement ce qu'on demande de faire
voilà Maxime
le fait comme tout le monde
c'est ce que je fais moi chaque fois que
je joue les play-in ou à division 2 la
Division 3
et c'est ce que tout le monde fait
y compris à moins Magnus joue depuis les
studios de de non mais Manu si je jouais
à domicile
donc Magnus y compris
j'ai l'impression ça c'est pas une
nouveauté qui sont un peu en retard
il est pas là notre ami notre ami manus
Carlsen
voilà vous voyez
il nous fait visiter alors il nous fait
visiter le truc bah effectivement aller
me les mauvaises langues diront il y a
pas quelqu'un à la fenêtre il y a pas
quelqu'un derrière la porte il y a pas
quelqu'un je sais pas où
ça peut arriver moi je fais en vrai moi
je ferme la porte quand je ferme la
porte de ma de l'endroit où joue parfois
il y a mes enfants qui sont là
donc c'est vrai que voilà
qu'est-ce que vous voulez vous vivez
aussi dans une appartement ou une maison
ou il y a d'autres personnes parfois pas
toujours ça dépend des gens mais voilà
donc
je fais toujours bien attention de
fermer la porte et de de
faire en sorte de dire à tout le monde
de pas ouvrir pendant les parties
c'est vrai que ça met un peu
l'impression en fait on se dit ouais
faut quand même que je fasse un peu le
ménage moi je me mets sur une sur ma
télé en fait
dans une pièce j'ai une petite télé j'ai
pas ouais j'ai une petite télé et donc
en fait je mets un câble HDMI et je vois
comme ça mon écran d'ordi
sur la télé je trouve ça mieux je vois
mieux c'est l'âge
voilà
la fenêtre ouverte semble le suspecte là
voilà c'est ça en fait on s'en sort plus
on peut voir la fenêtre là derrière vous
voyez ça sur la caméra numéro 2 voilà la
fenêtre bon ben
ça peut arriver
ah là là genre cette question toute la
soirée j'en ai marre
je supporte le beau jeu moi le beau
match
est-ce que je peux mettre mon volume un
peu plus fort
allez
ça c'est compliqué
je pense pas
non est-ce que je peux est-ce que
vraiment il faut mettre le volume un peu
plus fort ou pas parce que j'ai mis le
micro un peu plus loin c'est vrai que
sans
paramètres de son
micro
non mais en vrai
c'est plus ou c'est est-ce que là c'est
un peu plus fort
tellement poliment
que j'essaye est-ce que c'est un peu
mieux là
est-ce que ça a commencé non pas du tout
vous voyez Maxime qui n'est pas là
alors
à quelle heure ça commence c'est ça la
question
j'ai pas de nouvelles
alors c'est gain du match
je vais mettre en mode studio
pour
aller voir final gain du match
à demi évidemment sans cas de parties
cette finale est-ce que le son va le
volume est parfait
ok on va tant mieux alors
donc premier à deux et demi
c'est la différence ce sont les très
bien pas besoin de toucher
il me semble on peut régler vous me
chiez non mais c'est vrai que parfois
moi quand je regarde après en replay
parfois je trouve ça
[Musique]
pas assez fort
ça m'arrive
le son est bon on touche pas
je sois le son un peu léger ouais ça
m'arrive aussi
de voir
ce que je peux essayer de
mettre un peu plus fort
[Musique]
je pense que je peux
pas toucher
c'est vrai qu'après les gens qui ont des
écouteurs en moins de mal et je sais
plus où en règle sur l'ordi
ça c'est un truc que je devrais régler
sur
de volume ah oui
haut-parleur non
non son système
c'est ça qu'il faut j'attends j'attends
la réponse des pros
est-ce que c'est le son système que je
dois augmenter ou pas
pour que mon micro augmente
salut
alors il est où il est où
apprendre à le droit de supporter qui on
veut tout le monde est libre
pour la pièce de Magnus ben si il était
là
le problème c'est que je vous montre la
pièce de Maxime ça m'amuse je fais un
petit tour de passe-passe mais là je
gagne du temps
j'attends les experts est-ce qu'il faut
que j'augmente son système ou pas
chez toi oui je vais essayer de
je vais essayer d'augmenter un petit peu
mon son système
non je peux pas faire mieux parce
qu'après si j'augmente d'en Obs ça
risque de me foirer notre truc
toujours ça désolé
et je sais que je sais pas pourquoi
je peux le
toucher à ses boutons
c'est en très son
entre son
je vois pas entrer son où est-ce que ça
se trouve
paramètres audio entrée ça c'est pas mal
ça
on va le faire on a le temps
vous voyez à quel point je suis parfois
pas bon
à son système c'est pour moi ouais
c'est trop fort non arrêtez
faites pas de blague par contre
volume principal
après les gens ils peuvent baisser c'est
ça le truc donc attendez paramètres sont
ça c'est sorti
donc entrer paramètres
qu'est-ce qui nous a dit là-bas en
Tresson
je me ridiculise
gérer j'ai propriété du périphérique
d'entrée audio périphérique d'entrée
ouais microphone ah non pas désactiver
certainement pas allez on va me faire
faire des boulettes moi je vous le dis
et bien on sait pas où il est notre ami
[Musique]
je trouve pas
je sais pas j'ai windows
toujours une petite saloperie à dire mon
petit Robinho je te reconnais bien là
donc faites attention moi je vais
raconter tes exploits dans les soirées
tu vas pas emmener l'argent
je te le dis
alors
je regarderai
je dois
entrer son mais je vois pas oui
choisir votre périphérique d'entrée
propriété du périphérique audio
est-ce que c'est bon ça
volume propriété du périphérique alors
je mets un peu plus fort là moi je pense
que c'est pas c'est pas ça
obtenir de l'aide
bon je vois pas
alors est-ce que
ça commence ou pas
vous voyez on voit derrière son écran
qu'est-ce que ça dit là dans le chat
maxime m'a demandé
ouais
comme Windows
je sais pas en vous embrouiller là
et Cup artificial intelligence Cup salut
des gardes salut moi Eva 974 vous
arrivez au bon moment ou pas
foncez pas on sait pas si il vient quel
suspense en tout cas Magnus pas là
il est pas là maintenant
il est arrivé
donc on va désépingler
[Musique]
et on va épingler manuscrit en retard
en vrai on devrait on devrait lancer sa
pendule c'est sûr je suis d'accord
ah c'est plus fort donc ça marchait mon
truc
d'accord
ah ben voilà je vais mettre à fond alors
du coup
tout moi ça
où est-ce que j'ai trouvé le truc
moi je vous dis informatique pas mon
truc ça me passionne pas du tout c'est
ça le problème ça se voit je crois
ah j'ai augmenté
d'accord je vais augmenter un petit peu
alors du coup je suis pas sûr
son du coup maintenant je suis content
[Musique]
et on va aller chercher la partie tout
de suite un magnifique il est pas là
Maxime concentré à bloc
son système 93
un petit peu aussi
est-ce que là j'ai encore augmenté ou
pas
et là
je vois pas
je retrouve même plus le truc que j'ai
pas
c'est incroyable ce que je fais bon bref
on va dire ça marche bien
d'accord mais c'est bon
on laisse comme ça
on laisse comme ça on laisse comme ça
faut être à jour Windows c'est ce que je
fais régulièrement
alors quel est blanc dans cette première
partie on va regarder le bracket pour
comprendre qu'elle est blanc
c'est Magnus Carlsen qui a les blancs
dans la première donc on va tourner mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe là
bon
[Musique]
je vais vous dire ça tout de suite
je crois personne ne sait
vous les streamer des échecs comme vous
j'ai lancé une pub là
c'est tout moi
bon
et bien
on est pas bien là
on n'a pas répondu à Maxime
on ne sait pas ouais ils peuvent se voir
ouais bien sûr moi je vois les deux donc
s'ils veulent se voir ils peuvent se
voir
pourquoi il est parti peut-être qu'il
allait mettre sa deuxième caméra je sais
pas mais franchement ouais c'est bizarre
quand il y a pas trop d'horaires quand
les autres ont terminé mais on attend
quand même que tout le monde ait fini
donc c'est toujours compliqué à gérer
ces trucs où on voit Maxime qui attend
par exemple ils mettent pas de pause
moi quand je joue la division 2 ça va
embêter un peu parce qu'il y a pas en
fait c'est les joueurs qui se mettent
d'accord sur la pose entre deux parties
c'est à dire que eux ils encouragent à
jouer tout de suite alors moi il y a pas
de cas où je veux tout de suite parce
que j'ai envie d'avoir une petite pause
5 minutes
et en vrai c'est un peu parfois en
rematch parce que Henri match
et paramètres sont entrées soit je vais
tu as l'air d'être au point là sur ma
tôle Pepper là je vais faire copier
coller dans mon dans mon truc et je vais
faire les tests de main
je vais faire les tests ce soir demain
de m'avoir le chaud je ferai des tests
merci merci pour l'aide toujours sympa
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe là
je peux avoir ça moi
bon quand tu veux hein
quand ils veulent les champions quand il
veut Magnus là
il est chiant pour ça honnêtement j'ai
le nombre de fois
en stage on va bouffer mais où est-ce
que je veux dire il est là il dit moins
le quart on attend on attend on attend
ça c'est infernal
c'est un truc où il est toujours en
retard
il y a rien à faire ouais mais ça c'est
vrai que c'est un problème et il faut
lui il faut lui déclencher sa pendule
vous allez voir
ça va
ça va le changer forcément ça va changer
et oui c'est ça le truc
c'est que il va arriver alors
allez c'est parti
Magnus car scène avec les Blancs on va
tourner tout de suite cet échiquier
et il proposition de Shrek off
[Musique]
on va aussi mettre sur notre échiquier
hop là
hop là et une rose solimo on a éteint
répertoire
on sait pas quand il va sortir
le type qu'il écrit et d'une paresse
infinie c'est incroyable
pas facile hein c'est toi que c'est
le truc le plus dur que j'ai fait de ma
vie
alors on voit une Rosso Immo où on prend
pas en C6 normalement c'est le coup mais
pardon c'est le coup mais il décide de
jouer le petit rock évidemment Magnus
can a vu qui a vu beaucoup des
ressourdiments notamment avec les Noirs
face à Fabiano carurana beaucoup de
roselymo H3 E5 ok ça c'est une des
ventes principales est-ce que je
recommande ça dans mon cours je me
rappelle plus je crois que oui en fait
ah non je compte pas ça
ouais ouais non mais c'est vrai que
c'est c'était un peu insupportable ce
retard là mais il faut lui démarrer sa
pendule et c'est le premier à trouver ça
normal
franchement
après moi en gros quand je fais un stage
comme ça je suis payé pour la pour
l'attendre donc
j'attends du coup
donc là il s'est passé une petite
escarmouchtactic c'est vrai que si on
prend des 4 il y a 5 souvent donc on
fait le dessin qui c'est très thématique
puis on prend qu'elle prend le 4 on a un
jeu dynamique en échange de ce pion
isolé ce pion qui est un peu en prise
est-ce qu'on fait qui est des deux ici
je sais plus ce qu'on fait est-ce qu'on
prend en C6 c'est pas possible non plus
parce que quand il prend le 5 a une
vraie menace à mon avis donc on va voir
ce que décide de faire Magnus mais
Maxime qui est venu très très bien
préparé
quatre parties c'est marqué en haut gain
du match à deux points et demi donc
ça va faire
ça va faire quatre parties au meilleur
des quatre parties après ça peut être
que 3 si quelqu'un il va devenir merci
Robinho 988 pour ton aide Robinho qui
est la seule personne que je connaisse
qui est encore plus paresseuse que moi
et oui il en faut
qui a promis des sous-titres qui les a
jamais fait bon bref chaque fois il a au
moins il inventait pas trop d'excuses
c'était pas mal c'était la elle mérite
de la franchise quoi c'est à dire qu'en
gros tu l'as fait non pourquoi
pas envie voilà
alors quel est ces trois ouais c'est ça
me rappelle quand même un truc théorique
ici en général je crois qu'on prend un
parce que qu'elle prend des 5 et aussi
une menace
donc les Français 3 me semble être le
coup sauf si qui est prend le 5 marche
mais qui prend 5 a pas l'air de marcher
à cause de ça et là on a beaucoup de
pièces sur la colonne
ok donc
Maxime qui va devoir être obligé de
prendre je pense mais après puis on
prend il y a rien de désastreux tout va
bien tout va bien pour les Noirs ça
c'est une évidence c'est une position
juste intéressante à jouer je sais pas
qui est mieux est-ce qu'il réfléchissait
est-ce qu'il ouvre est-ce qu'il
réfléchirait pas Adam B6
attaque F2 menace cahier français 3 et
dame prend V5 ça peut être un coup
intéressant
là je pense qu'on va être obligé de
faire bon
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on prend ici on
joue dans le pré F2 ça c'est complexe
certainement d'un problème de
et roi bouge c'est vrai qu'on a gagné un
pion tout simplement ça perdr terrible
quand même avons le donc d'imber si
c'est un vrai coup Adam B6 x 3 il faut
regarder mais il prend ses trois sur
faute et on gagne une pièce donc
attention attention de MB6 un vrai coup
qu'elle prend des cinq peut-être dame
prend V5 et c'est 7 à calculer mais qui
a été d'un B6 attaquait F2 attaque le
cavalier peut-être tu reprends le 4
mais avoir un truc sur le Cloud
certainement
que cette 3f8 et j'aime bien Maxime
comme d'habitude comme tous les jours
depuis le début de cette
artificielle intelligence Cup et même au
tata style rapide il prend son temps dès
qu'il y a une question à laquelle il
faut réfléchir et c'est bien
il a bien raison de prendre son temps il
hésite entre dames et qu'elle prend ses
trois ça je vous le garantie
peut-être vous aussi c'est aussi un coup
parfois
ok il va pour le coup le plus concret
alors que fait Magnus maintenant
peut-être dame aussi protège en F2 et en
C3 et en V5
est définitivement un coup menace et 5
donc elle prend le 5 marche pas du tout
qu'elle prend
au pas
perdant donc
prend C3 et maintenant comment on fait
avec les noirs
après on peut aussi intercaler peut-être
aussi
toujours intéressant de jouer comme ça
parce qu'on peut pas prendre le pion
tout de suite on peut faire comme ça ça
me prend il y a le fou faut faire
attention et sur par exemple
vous prend ces 6 on va faire dame prend
C6
a toujours du jeu là
ou pardon ou même ouais ou alors on
pouvait échanger d'abord et ensuite je
vais foudre
donc très intéressant et voyez de comme
si de rien n'était au 11e coup
ça a quand même ça swing
Ueux
OK
c'était le coup le premier coup auquel
on pense
en tout cas pour tout protéger pour
protéger un petit peu la maison
et attention à pas se retrouver dans des
scénarios comme ça en fait c'est ça
l'enjeu par exemple scénario comme ça
serait vraiment pas terrible genre un
truc sur case noire là qui peut
s'organiser voyez où j'ai 5 fois 6 ça
peut être très dangereux sur case noire
autour du roi et ce fou qui joue pas
trop qui bute quand même sur ce pion de
donc
faut faire attention à ça et j'ai trois
jolies
joli que j'ai trois mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est plus joli que
efficace
ou pas
Dame des trois
bon ouais ça attaque la dame mais après
le prochain coup c'est de revenir donc
il a joué pour D8 mvl ok ça c'est un
autre coup qui fait qui aussi protège le
pion des protège pas le Pione ça va être
la même idée sur ça ça ça
on a on a tout plein de contre jeu là on
peut jouer tourner un par exemple si tu
en prends cavalier prend récupère le
pion et si on fait roi H2 bah on est
cloué donc ça a pas du tout F5 on va
menacer ton C8 les Noirs se battent pour
leur les blancs se battent pour leur vie
pardon
donc pour des 8 bien joué la part de
Maxime j'aime beaucoup le jeu des des
deux camps là c'est très très concret
très complexe
intéressant
ah non quand on joue sur chaise comme
nous on a pas la jauge non on la met
on n'a pas la jauge quand on joue en
tout cas ça c'est interdit
c'est quand même le con
#niman
# je suis
voilà
Hans a joué un peu trop de fois avec la
jauge sur chaise comme
à 12 ans et 16 ans comédie
donc
à 12 ans parce qu'il était
il était jeune il se rendait pas quand
de ce qu'il faisait et à 16 ans
tu es un peu moins jeune mais il se
rendait toujours pas compte de ce qu'il
faisait
alors comment on fait ici avec les
Blancs
alors Maxime qui réfléchit et non c'est
d'accord
on va voir en rappel c'est double
élimination donc au pire du pire
pourquoi il y a un truc là qu'est-ce qui
se passe avec Magnus
je sais pas ce qu'il y a avec manus je
vais le décaler un petit peu notre ami
notre ami de champion du monde enfin
l'ancien champion du monde ancien triple
on va le on va le mettre comme ça parce
que là
et en plein
qui prend toujours son temps qui sent il
a une grosse il a une grosse force c'est
qui sent très très bien le moment le
moment critique ou les moments critiques
donc en fait quand on regarde sa gestion
du temps elle est quand même assez
incroyable
pourquoi
parce qu'il réfléchit toujours à des
moments importants il est il est assez
[Musique]
il y a très fort pour ça
alors vous pensez si je jouais
c'est la devinette du jour combien de
parties vous voyez du en haut de ma
muscarsen à ma droite vous voyez gain du
match à 2 et demi donc devinez quand il
y a de partout il y a trois minimum
on ne sait pas faut prendre ici c'est
logique dans ces structures on donne le
footclasse blanche pour mieux contrôler
cases noires avec nos cavaliers le
cavalier qui fait quand même un très bon
job en C6 de contrôler les cases noires
importantes donc faut prendre ces 6 et
très logique
ah oui c'est vrai
je vais me faire contacter par la vocale
effectivement
on se moque on se moque j'y peux rien
moi
j'y peux rien c'est lui qui avoue
il a dit
ça c'est factuel
à moi qui monte il monte sur ça aussi
bon
c'est pas trois sauts avantages de
mentir sur ça donc a priori il y a pas
de raison objectif de penser qu'il a
menti
sur ça en tout cas
on sait pas on sait pas si Magnus a payé
ou pas
puis on prend ses 6 quand il y a une
résolution comme ça a priori
d'ailleurs il demandait pas un million
il devait 100 millions
en tout cas un Sliman peut rejouer sur
il jouait en division de là je sais pas
ce qu'il a fait mais il peut rejouer sur
JETCOM
noir comme je vous le disais voilà c'est
exactement le genre de scénario qu'il
fallait éviter avec les Noirs à mon avis
et c'est le genre de scénario qu'on a
obtenu parce que là c'est compliqué en
vrai ça peut aller très vite par exemple
un coup de fouet 6 suite cahier des 4
celui de F4 suite tourbé 1 celui de F5
je sais pas ça peut être une attaque de
maths assez rapide
il a reconnu avoir triché en ligne c'est
tout et il dément avoir triché
over the board après il y a des gens qui
pensent que prendra peut-être parler de
ça pour certains c'est il y a une grosse
différence entre tricher en ligne ou
tricher over the board comment on dit en
direct
moi je à titre personnel vraiment je la
vois pas
je pense que c'est pareil quoi
en gros
qui est plus grande online parce qu'il y
a pas de caméra tout ça quand on joue un
bits online attention est plus grande
parce que après tout pas vu pas pris
c'est sûr de pas se faire voir à moins
que le logiciel le détecte attention ne
trichez pas ne faites pas ça c'est
stupide ça sert à rien
c'est absolument rien franchement quelle
fierté on peut avoir de gagner une
partie où on a
utilisé l'ordinateur ça n'a aucun
intérêt et attention vous allez vous
faire attraper aussi
et après voilà vous allez faire ban donc
faut pas le faire pour mille et une
raison
alors c'est 5 pour empêcher fof 6 est-ce
qu'on viendrait pas que la dame là la F4
pour s'organiser autour du roi ou alors
faut H6 je pense qu'il veut faire 5 x 4
c'est ça son plan
et sur dame prend des cinq à vous B7
c'est ça l'idée et on va échanger ici on
va certainement récupérer le pur de 5 et
donc c'est pas terrible
non mais après chacun son
alors ces cinq jouets et c'est pas mal
peut-être qu'on veut faire foudre et des
4 j'aime bien comment il joue Maxime
dans cette partie fois 6 me semble assez
critique pour essayer d'échanger ses
fous de case noire
c'est le coup le Cooking
[Musique]
F6 c'est complètement interdit
ça ça m'a l'air assez dangereux en vrai
là on a tout 8 si on fait dame 6 cette
histoire peut-être dame prend des cinq
d'abord
tomber 8 échec voyez cette chambre
d'histoire de me prendre ces cinq par
exemple ma fuite ça va pas du tout donc
si c'est aussi un coup
il faut jouer absolument sur castor la
F4
j'aimais pas fou F5
et il a joué fou F6 Magnus Carlson
ok il continue dans son idée
il veut échanger les fouilles il a pris
son temps
il a pesé le poil contre
consciencieux qui dit j'adore tricher en
ligne c'est pas pour afficher c'est pour
briser la fierté de l'autre oui bon ben
alors là faut consulter en fait ça se
passe plus sur les sites
ça passe plus ça se passe plus sur les
sites de
[Musique]
chez qui c'est plus grave que ça
alors
on veut faire de la F4 prochain coup et
changer de foot casse noir
alors comment on peut faire avec les
Noirs je sais pas là j'ai pas la rêve du
coup parce que ça me semble beaucoup
trop dangereux on peut pas se permettre
de laisser un pion par là
peut-être fou B7 comme ça mais voyez je
joue un coup la jauge j'aime pas
pourquoi je j'aime pas je vois pas je
vais tricher
mais je vous le dis
ça c'est finement vu ça c'est très
finement vu
ok donc attention donc quel est le coût
après
on prend c'est la partie
la jauge mais fou F5 pour faire faux 4
ok
0,20 ça veut dire c'est rien mais moi ça
me semble il est là Maxime ça y est
Maxime de gala aujourd'hui et bien pour
l'instant il joue parfaitement le coup
clairement
il joue une fait une très belle partie
là une partie de haut niveau de la part
des deux joueurs
tu es évident
on va voir ce que veut ce que peut faire
le l'ancien champion du monde champion
du monde de partir rapidement
récemment sur dame prend des cinq mains
toute la différence c'est je pense on
prend un F6 et on va récupérer ici par
exemple sur dame français 5 on fait on
fait tour C8 quelque chose comme ça et
on a assez de jeu peut-être non on va
faire ça plus intelligent peut-être
s'il est tactique marche puis on prend
la dame prend sur Dame des 5 à tour des
8 tout marche tout terrain de marché
c'est un peu bancal mais bon après tout
les échecs sont un jeu concret
c'est comme ça
Magnus agafé pas vraiment non
est-ce qu'on peut pas faire de la F4
avec l'idée sur dame prime F6 on fait G4
un jeu donc en fait on protège
indirectement le pion F6 parce qu'en
fait il est très dur à protéger ce pion
si on réfléchit MG5 je peux même jouer 6
et sur dame prend H6 donc ça ça va pour
les noirs
il fait une
alors pourquoi il nous fait une
je sais pas
on a déclenché un débat qui reste
éternel évidemment
alors dame F4 je vois dans le chat ça se
ça parle ça parle mais bon
il y aura toujours des avis différents
ça reste un délit comme un autre
finalement après les gens ont des
sensibilités différentes
deuxième chance pas de deuxième chance
quel genre de punition
toujours compliqué
là j'ai 4 j'ai l'impression quand même
avec les blancs en tout cas là on est
complètement sûr que c'est
et bien ouais quand on a des joueurs qui
gagnent et online et sur le chéquier bah
ça
ça enlève tous les soupçons quand même
et évidemment on a deux on a le champion
du monde de BIS 2021 mvl et on a
quelqu'un en face de lui qui a gagné au
moins je crois 5 titres de parties
classiques cet emblite 3 rapide enfin un
truc phénoménal donc on a vraiment
des cadors ici
et des cadeaux en forme
non il n'y a pas de décalage d'une
minute entre les cames et chéquiers
juste un décalage d'une minute dans la
retransmission de ce stream on m'a
obligé à faire ça pour voilà quand je
parle en fait ça vient à vous ça vient
sur les Internet une minute plus tard
tout recap jouer et puis on prend que
j'ai 5 peut-être mais j'ai 4
peut-être que j'ai 5 je sais pas
peut-être cavalier 5 aussi
parce que cavalier 5 d'un prime
ça marche pas
bonjour Hello
eh pas mal pas mal son truc donc surpris
on prend il faut faire quoi maintenant
est-ce que ça serait pas les blancs qui
sont
un petit peu dans le dur ici remarqué ce
qu'elle prend le 4 c'est toujours un peu
pénible comment on fait la dame 7 à mon
avis ça me semblerait pas mal protège
ici attaque le cavalier
ça devrait aller pour les Noirs ici
n'en perds pas le fou justement
et Magnus là qui doit mettre comme il
dit coup de frein à Merlin
comment on fait pour Magnus pas si
évident
il faut ouais tenter de je pense que
j'ai 5 ans
très tôt j'ai quatre marches là ah j'ai
quatre peu marcher maintenant parce que
dame prend ces trois il y a torcer un
qui a une pièce OK
c'est complexe et il y a pas de dame
prend H3 ouais parce que
j'ai 5 dons semble être le coup sur que
j'ai 5 ça qui m'échappe
là j'ai 4 une nouvelle fois
peut-être tout est-ce que toi 8 est
envisageable pour protéger ici sur G4
c'est chaud sur G4 quand même
c'est ça qui doit être en train de
calculer ce genre de choses
et tout ça là mais hyper acrobatique
mais ça a l'air d'être bien pour les
Noirs quand même
alors
plus que trois minutes pour un
va falloir qu'il accélère Magnus
j'ai vu ces deux joueurs même joueur en
blitz amical c'était très impressionnant
je notais les coups
je faisais le scribe à côté je notais
les coudes je rentrais les parties dans
l'ordi pour qu'on les aie ensuite
il aime bien faire ça Magnus de jouer
partie entraînement mais qu'elle reste
et les avoir ensuite
comme quoi elle a pas l'air mais c'est
quand même un sacré pro
il a joué 5 et donc voilà faut alors
bien comme moi par exemple qui note les
parties
mais bon
je me plains pas
si vous regardez un petit Blitz mvl
Magnus il y a des gens qui aimeraient
bien être à ma place
on regarde
le petit Blitz Maxime en plus avec la
jauge donc à la fin il demande qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont raté
voilà on leur explique un petit peu ce
qu'ils ont raté le pourquoi du comment
alors que j'ai 4
attaque la dame c'était l'autre option
ouais et sur dame prend ces trois je
suppose qu'il veut faire cavalier H6
intermédiaire suite pour C1
quelque chose comme ça je crois est-ce
qu'il va falloir prendre ou pas c'est
pas si clair j'en sais rien essayons
échec
on va où maintenant
on va où
ici
ça
ouais mais qu'est-ce qu'on risque en
fait avec les noirs on va jamais la
perte cette partie dame français 3 a été
joué tours c'est un d'abord Dame des 4
et cavalier H6 jouer
me semble pas être terrible parce que
moi je suis va sûrement y avoir qu'elle
prend F7 on a un peu le jeu quoi que
c'est pas sûr
tout à l'heure ok en fait pour les Noirs
mais bon
G4 serait beaucoup trop ambitieux on
fait faux aussi donc on est obligé de
reprendre en fait
on prend on prend on attaquage 7 on
attaque c'est 5 moi je veux un coup
droit certainement et ça va être assez
facilement annulable par exemple E3 ici
pour jouer et puis on prend F2 si pion
mais c'est objectivement c'est les
blancs qui doivent faire attention un
petit peu
ça a l'air et leur Didier vous n'avez
rien raté c'est ça
en 3 + 2 il y a des choses quand même
non je sais pas pourquoi il a pris
Maxime
je suis venu comme ça il s'entendait
bien il lui a proposé
alors
5 c'est un peu la ligne que je vous
proposais en version améliorée pour
pour personne en vrai
pour personne ça a très certainement
faire nul on est assez de jeu quand même
avec les Blancs on attaque de pions
donc ça va faire nul c'est à peu près
certain alors attention Magnus c'est
toujours Magnus
faut faire attention ah ce qu'on dit
peut-être dame prend
ça me prend à se faire nul tout de suite
et puis on prend bref on prend micro
avantage peut-être pour les blancs ici
alors attention pour Maxime a pas tombé
dans ce genre de finale qui peuvent être
légèrement inférieur E3 a été joué par
mvl qui nous fait une grosse partie pour
l'instant
non mais sur dame prend vous savez ce
qu'il va faire il va prendre il va jouer
F1 il va juste tourner 8 voilà c'est le
mieux
c'est le plus simple dame prend pour
prendre vous l'aurez vu ici en premier
c'est comme ça que ça se terminait
quoi que là
donc il faut faire attention peut-être
des blancs peuvent être un peu moins
bien
Magnus qui a suivi son temps qu'est-ce
qu'il a joué Magnus il a pas joué son
temps tourne une 37 quand même
il faut jouer un coup alors rien de
grave parce que la position reste quand
même assez simple on a un choix entre
une fille de Tours peut-être légèrement
inférieur quand même
et je vois pas l'autre choix en fait
j'ai dit entre en fait pour avoir le
choix il faut vraiment une autre option
mais je la vois pas pour l'instant
et tourner 8 ouais qui gagne du temps
par rapport à Dame prend évidemment dame
prend qui active la tour on laisse on
laisse les blancs prendre et on s'active
oui effectivement quand ça sent la nul
ça c'est certain mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe sur E2 E2
certainement tout RER
et Dame des deux maintenant on a
toujours pas fait là mais on perd même
pardon
et on va encaisser le pion ok dame prend
F7 et ouais hyper concret mais hyper bon
aussi alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
ici avec des Noirs ça ça
attention de prendre
mais bon même ça
vous avez compris
vous avez compris ou pas
est-ce que vous avez compris est-ce que
ce compte 2 est assez peu engageant
oui mais est-ce que Maxime aurait gagné
d'un tour contre dame contre tour hier
oui oui oui je vous le dis oui Maxime
très peu de temps
ça c'est une évidence c'est Maxime il a
une superbe technique en finale
attention on rigole pas sur la finale
théorique avec Maxime machin grave
c'est du sérieux c'est du solide donc il
l'aurait gagné
c'est absolument certain
alors ça dépend des
alors là que ça dépend parce que là on
est sur cheescom donc on est on est
quand même on est sur Youtube aussi il
faut avouer que sur chaise 24 on était à
l'époque alors je parle de pour les
anciens c'est diffusé aussi sur chaise
24 donc n'hésitez pas à voir et
n'hésitez pas surtout à vous abonner aux
chaînes come fr évidemment twitch
YouTube on était surtout orienté on est
très très orienté sur sur Youtube donc
twitch pas du tout là Chase comme FR et
plus orienté sur twitch que sur Youtube
donc c'est pas tout à fait des choses
comparables mais effectivement
[Musique]
le combiné chascom fress 24 fr
maintenant que c'est réunifié il y a
plus de monde que avant oui ça c'est
c'est sûr
c'est indéniable
donc ton G8 jouets par mvl et oui on
n'est pas obligé de prendre aux échecs
c'est ça qui est magique est-ce qu'on
comment on fait là avec les Blancs
est-ce qu'on va jouer de la F3 ou un
truc comme ça pour empêcher tout arnaque
40 secondes attention
s'ils sont tous à deux je vais vous dire
je vais vous dire s'il y a de partout
qu'est-ce qui se passe ça va être
l'Armageddon mais attention on en est
loin il peut faire ça aussi est-ce que
ça et ça ça perdrait parce que sur
rouage de il y a dame G3 donc ça n'irait
pas pour G8 il a joué tout
Magnus Carson qui est un bon coup et qui
force sa décision ici et surpuis on
prend ses dames prends c'est la même
idée que d'un F3 mais en mieux jouer
c'est tout lui ça
et là on peut forcer à finale de tour
qui serait bien entendu pour des joueurs
de ce niveau archi nul hein quand ils
sont la technique de Maxime normalement
on passe pas même si on est un peu mieux
en finale de tour on ne gagne pas
non j'aurais pas gagné contre Magnus au
roi dame contre 3 tours le terrier 59
non non vu comment il a défend moi je
connaissais pas cette défense là oui il
a défend bien j'ai pas eu la défends
bizarrement il a défendu une façon que
tu as pas ton truc habituel le truc que
tout le monde a vu mais il est malin
pour ça
ça y a pas de problème vous en faites
pas pour lui surtout alors j'ai arrêté
de m'en faire moi
F2 et maintenant final de tour une
minute contre 25 secondes ça peut
paraître critique mais c'est quand même
très très annulant cette histoire cette
fille de Tourtour est fuite qui force
ses changes ces prix et ça va être
attaqué je pense qu'il va essayer
attention il peut être un peu moins bien
attention il faut faire un petit peu
attention avec les Noirs ici
il va faire tourner 5 je pense pour
faire tour à 5 étant pas
je pense que c'est la façon de jouer
autour des 6 touristes allez qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait un Maxime il réfléchit il a
bien raison il prend son temps
maintenant pour C8 pour faire tourner et
on va avoir ce 2 contre 2 dont je vous
parlais avant pour prendre des quatre va
être jouée peut-être une proposition de
nulle qui va arriver d'un côté ou dans
l'autre je crois qu'il y a une règle de
30 cours 2 regardez hein il cherche il
cherche toujours à petite bête Magnus
Carlson il est comme ça et pour ces
quatre jouets pour jouer tour à 4 et ça
ne sera pas suffisant
pour Magnus qui cherche toujours la
petite chance autour des trois
OK
est-ce qu'on fait tour à Cap peut-être
il cherche vraiment à lui poser les
petits problèmes c'est tout lui ça
comment on fait nul je serais déjà
inquiets avec les Noirs parce que tu
auras quatre à trois c'est vrai que le
Roi peut venir 4 en imagine tous les
scénarios les pions pousse on sait
jamais voilà on n'aime pas ça
à trois G7 et maintenant on met le roi
E4 mais il va faire 6 ok on peut pas
faire roi des 6 c'est interdit là on va
faire H6 et 6 3G 6 on va attendre comme
ça on n'a pas le choix hk3f6 va être
joué attention la Tour Eiffel 3 rois G6
non mais ça fait rien tour F3
il faut faire wave 6 à un moment ou un
autre mais je vois pas Maxime du tout en
train de perdre cette position
clairement
mais les blancs poussent ça pousse saute
gentiment chez Magnus Carlson incroyable
vu cette position il avait rien du tout
faut qu'il fasse gaffe Maxime attention
15 secondes tour à 5 oulala oui surtout
prends des cartes on reprend à 3 sur on
va prendre des 4 il y a trois quatre
échecs c'est très très bien vu ça de la
part du champion français belle défense
vraiment H5 comment on va faire
maintenant on va prendre il y a toujours
cette même arnaque arnaque entre
guillemets c'est c'est légitime de faire
des des combinaisons pour défendre
est-ce qu'on fait tourger cinq ou pas
oui ton G5 tourgé 3 va être joué
certainement
ton G3 va être joué ou pas ton G3 il
faut qu'il joue une tournée mais empêche
des choses est-ce que j'ai cinq
échouables non tout F3 ton G5 va être
rejoué c'est quasiment certain il va
jouer ton F4 maintenant elle est dans le
dur Maxime là Tour Eiffel 4 tours 5
certainement 3 5 pour faire du
harcèlement sur ce pion
voilà ça joue très fort toi et si tu
veux faire tourrage fuite sacré Magnus
tourrage 8 comment il se défend sur toi
je suis Détroit peut-être
des trois une fois des trois deux fois
cette seconde ouh là là que c'est chaud
mais que c'est chaud tour G3 ok tu
reprends H6 3 7 et surtout G6 il veut
faire quoi il veut faire des trois oh
c'est très précis ça bravo Maxime
bravo au roi F4 Détroit tempo il avait
pris vous Détroit et comment il fait
pour rattraper le purge j'en sais rien
j'en perds mon latin là tu reprends à 7
va être jouée pour revenir in extremis
sauver le pion ou pas 4 secondes 3
secondes ouh là là je suis pour faire
tourner 8
comment on fait maintenant ouais 7 alors
que c'est bien joué sur roi projet 3 il
y a toujours des deux
tour à 8D de tout reprendre moi aussi et
surtout il fait comment maintenant
Maxime tourner trois tours D1 et alors
comment on fait maintenant échec
certainement roi F6 d'abord j'en sais
rien
que c'est chaud mais quelle défense de
Maxime il s'est mis un peu en danger
mais ça va maintenant maintenant c'est
nul la tour est trop passive ici et si
on roi E4 on va faire simplement tour
des 8 et où il a tout peut pas bouger
et sur ça on fait les échecs autour des
5 quelle défense de Maxime sacrée Maxime
oh là c'est bien défendu
ah ça joue fort ouais ça devait être
jouée ici
ouais une fois qu'on a le truc que c'est
bien joué que c'est bien joué de la part
de Maxime c'est énorme bravo bravo belle
partie parce qu'il était un peu dans le
dur honnêtement
un peu dans l'endu dans cette première
partie mais alors que ça a été bien
défendu de la part de mvl
vraiment grosse grosse défense n'hésitez
pas vraiment il faut rester pour ce
match parce que là c'est ça joue ça joue
i level c'est du très très haut niveau
honnêtement c'est très très
impressionnant ce qui nous ont offert
les deux joueurs Magnus qui a réussi à
retourner un petit peu et à poser des
petits soucis à manus Carlsen et Magnus
qui s'en est quand même
très très bien et Maxime qui a fait une
défense au niveau 1 parce que final de
Tours je peux vous dire nepo il a peur
en deux secondes ça je connais je
connais mes clients les pots il la perd
tout de suite
et le roi blanc va chercher la tour
ouais mais non non non parce que quand
le roi blanc
le roi blanc va pas du tout chercher la
tour parce qu'en fait on fait ça et en
fait on peut jamais aller chercher la
tour bref 4 wash 7 et en fait
roi G4 mais on peut faire ça
je peux faire ça même ça c'est nul
et hop je reviens toujours et sur G6 3G7
et ça ne passe jamais la tourne peut pas
se joindre à l'attaque super partie il y
a une petite pause ouais et une petite
pause Maxime machin va voir les blancs
dans cette deuxième partie alors comment
ça se passe ce match on va vous le dire
tout de suite c'est au meilleur des
quatre parties donc premier arrivé à
deux et demi ça va être gros gros match
s'il y a deux partout c'est le fameux
Armageddon on y reviendra évidemment si
on y a droit mais alors c'est grosse
partie là grosse spectacle 15 + 3
magnifique les deux joueurs en très
grande forme il faut absolument rester
pour voir la fin de ce magnifique duel
je vous dis
à tout de suite je fais une petite pause
aussi il faut souffler comme les joueurs
parce que là franchement
c'est quelque chose
à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je suis de retour pour cette deuxième
partie du match qui va arriver
mais quelle première partie intense
quand même stratégiquement très
compliqué avec des escarmouches
tactiques et une finale de tour rudement
bien joué des deux côtés
ça nous promet du spectacle
à fond les ballons donc ça va être très
sympa à suivre bon après c'est à leur
rythme ils sont pas pressés pour jouer
leur partie bon qu'est-ce que vous
voulez c'est comme ça
la partie la deuxième partie pas encore
en route est-ce que les joueurs sont là
ou pas on va voir Magnus à part remis
sakam alors on sait pas est-ce qu'il y a
je vais regarder un petit message quand
même
première partie la prochaine a dans une
minute ok donc ça ça va pas tarder à
commencer et Maxime va chez Lagrave aura
les blancs nulle dans cette première
partie
Maxime avec les Blancs on va voir
mais ça va être très très beau une fois
de plus
ça va être très sympa à regarder il va
jouer son traditionnel E4 est-ce que
Magnus va le défier dans cette nage
d'offre comme il l'a fait hier
face à Yann les pomyachi qui est aussi
historiquement un joueur de nashdorf qui
est un peu arrêté pour jouer la pétrole
la Défense russe mais clairement c'est
une option
on va voir on va voir ce qui va se
passer
j'essaie de remonter le il y a beaucoup
d'enthousiasme évidemment
dans le chat je vois sur YouTube sur
twitch j'arrive plutôt à j'arrive pas à
suivre tout voilà bon on va voir en tout
cas
ça va enchaîner normalement si Magnus
veut bien remettre sa caméra allez mon
petit Magnus
mon petit Magnus non il remet pas sa
caméra pas pour l'instant en tout cas
bon ça va se terminer tard cette
histoire ça c'est c'est à peu près
certain une heure par partie ça va être
long quand même
mais bon peut-être qu'on va aller au
bout au bout du suspense
ça serait beau hein toute façon nous ce
qu'on veut moi ce que je veux pour team
neutre aujourd'hui
team neutre et donc team je veux un beau
match
et donc dans la première le rappel pour
ceux qui nous rejoindraient en cours de
en cours de route
il y a une nul dans la première partie
vous le voyez là les points pourquoi
pourquoi je me décarcasse a marqué les
points regardez les points à côté des
joueurs là 0,5 05 vous les avez en petit
mais bon ils sont là quand même
ils sont là alors est-ce que Magnus
vient ou pas ça devait commencer il y a
une minute normalement
selon le timing qu'est-ce qui se passe
là
qu'est-ce qu'ils m'ont fait qu'est-ce
qu'ils m'ont fait
ah ça y est Manu s'est remis
ça va jouer Magnus pas pressé
c'est Jean-Michel pas du tout angoissé
et on repart pour la nage d'orf on va
voir ce que ça donne
ils ont pris mon les deux on va voir ce
que ça donne waouh des filles Maxime va
chez Lagrave sur son terrain et bien ça
c'est en train de manger du scarsen
c'est à peu près certain
pour avancer la totale
demain ça sera à quelle heure car ce
n'est pas on sait pas on verra en tout
cas ce qu'on a demain on va regarder
faux 3,5 on regardera après c'est dans
le bracket c'est vrai qu'il y a Zam
malheureusement a perdu on a du mal à
même à imaginer quand c'est possible
parce que c'est vrai qu'il dominait
tellement ce match la première il avait
gagné la deuxième il était en contrôle
intégrale
et tout d'un coup il s'est mis mal au
temps il a gavé il a perdu et il a perdu
l'armée
donc
décevant évidemment de la part de
d'aller à ETF 3 qui est l'attaque
anglaise donc très très la voir la plus
complexe de cette une des vins les plus
complexe avec fougères 5 aussi
évidemment fouger 5 et food 3 sont les
deux coups les plus agressifs
et F3 Magnus réfléchi mais je crois
surtout qu'il est en train de manger en
fait parce que là dans cette position il
a forcément une prépa même plusieurs
fois 7 et jouable kbd7 et jouable tech
fraise dans sa jeunesse wiki
pour garder de la flexibilité jouer B5
peut-être pour C8 des choses comme ça
faut 7 j'ai déjà joué aussi quand je
voulais acheter longtemps c'était un
temps que les moins de 20 ans ne peuvent
pas connaître
et 7 jouer par Magnus
même des deux arrive ici où j'ai 4 on
peut commencer par G4 c'est toujours
l'option Dame des deux où j'ai 4 ça joue
garantie
qui des 5 parfois et jouable
mais ouais j'ai 4 a quand même le coup
qui a le plus de peps
frère j'ai 5 tout simplement et forcer
le cavalier noir aller en 5
je faisais B5 moi une vente qui est
quasiment affûté je crois
je me dégonflais pas
je jouais B5 mais B5 à mauvaise
réputation à moins que bon effectivement
et les nouveaux ordis
ça peut
on peut réhabiliter des variantes qui
étaient censées douteuses il y a 20 ans
ça c'est sûr
j'avouerais que c'est pas ma
préoccupation principale de ces jours-ci
la nights
donc parfois je c'est à peu près ce qui
se passe mais
ouais je suis plus au point sur la sur
les berlinoises par exemple
alors j'ai 5 jouer
sur kb6 qui normalement donne de la
flexibilité alors normalement l'idée
c'est de mettre le cadre des 7 mais on
peut aussi quand même changer d'avis de
mettre un H5 et d'un coup on a empêché
quand même qu'il y a des 5 parce qu'on
va reprendre de ce cavalier alors les
deux écoles ont du pour et du contre
Magnus qui réfléchit
longtemps
quelle année mais mais
dans les années 2000 des années 2000
un parti comme polar G4 c'est ouais
c'est la partie comme polluger contre
bulles dans cette ligne
on va aller
il m'ont fait des sacrés partis
donc
quand ça se passe mal ça se passe
vraiment mal
alors qu'est-ce qu'il va faire qu'est-ce
qu'il fait
il mange
il mange notre ami
il y a des cours on bluff hein
alors Magnus il est out of book
maintenant il doit plus se souvenir et
forcément pas au top book il y a
forcément fait une petite prépa parce
qu'il a l'air de vouloir jouer à un âge
d'or dans toutes les dans toutes ces
parties dans ce tournoi donc il a
forcément travaillé avant
mais effectivement c'est peut-être une
une petite sous variante
Dame des deux ok c'est tout à fait
logique on va faire grand rock on va
faire un H4 certainement faire foutage 3
peut-être
certainement c'était je m'avancais un
petit peu enfin je trouvais toujours
kfca donc c'est pas terrible on va faire
F4 après c'est ça les prochains coups en
général
7 a l'air vraiment très normal
bon ça y est apparemment
Magnus ça a fini de manger et il mange
tous les Norvégiens alors ça doit
l'embêter ces matchs un peu tard là et
norvégien à 18h30 ils ont fini de manger
mais il fait nuit déjà
il fait nuit en septembre 18h il fait
nuit et encore 18h c'est sympa
alors
qu'est-ce qui nous fait maintenant il
fait H6 ok alors ça c'est ça a coût
thématique sur pion on veut pas du tout
reprendre on veut jouer G6
on veut faire dommage 4 peut-être là sur
ce cas très précis fou F2 pour empêcher
et dame prend H6 ça fait en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'on veut pas
reprendre on veut pas reprendre la 6
donc plusieurs plusieurs écoles ici soit
on prend Alcis mais ça a pas l'air
terrible ça on fait grand rock et on dit
au noir très bien on prend j'ai 5 ok je
vais reprendre du fou je vais gagner du
temps quand même
soit on peut donner un pion comme ça
mais bon ça a pas l'air terrible
franchement prise voilà donc a priori
sur H6 on fait grand rock mais après
Maxime il connaît normalement très bien
c'est naydorf donc il peut y avoir une
autre chose qui échappe à mon attention
que je vois pas forcément
ouais je suis presque pour Maxime
tout ce que fait Magnus là il arrive en
retard il bouffe il se lève
[Musique]
et en fait trop là
est-ce que tu es le seul entendre de
l'écho je le souhaite
j'adore
pas des cons merci tu m'as fait peur
alors pas ça
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire mvl
et se couche à quelle heure les
Norvégiens elles se couchent tout il
mange tout et se couche tout
les weekends par contre
et weekend ça y va ça rigole pas
il y a des trucs ouais il y a des trucs
comme ça
il y a des sortes de traditions il
picole chez eux d'abord le week-end et
après ils vont dans les bars
sinon c'est trop cher
très très cher la Norvège les barres
sont très chers donc qui picole d'abord
et en général ils arrivent
assez amochés dans les bars c'est ça le
concept
ce qui peut tout le concept français
alors
bref
on va pas parler des mœurs Norvégiens
toute la soirée fous ranger 5 vous êtes
surtout ce genre de mœurs faut 7 et je
pensais que c'était pas possible ça
donnait un pion mais après tout c'est
vrai que dans la finale la petite finale
finalement il y a quand même un peu de
contre jeu où 7 on va faire tour H4 on
va mettre notre tour à H8 c'est vrai
qu'il y a un peu de jeu mais bon ça
reste un pion
un pion c'est un pion
alors
je crois qu'il va être obligé de prendre
quand même parce que quoi d'autre
puis Maxime on le connaît
on le connaît
notre ami Maxime quand il y a un pion en
prise
finalement c'est pris
après quel est le prochain coup des
noirs on peut pas vraiment sauver ce
pion donc il est à nous avec les Blancs
donc on peut améliorer notre situation
pour essayer de prendre plus tard est-ce
que je vois des coûts d'amélioration la
réponse est non est-ce que Maxime va
voir un coup d'amélioration la réponse
est peut-être
réseau qui me demande c'est ce que j'ai
déjà vu les parents de heureusement j'ai
vu les parents de Magnus 10 ans 5 mâle
champion du monde quand même
cavalier à 5 attaques le pion
B il est très proche de ses parents
ouais alors après il y a dans les règles
on
a on a le droit de faire une fois tant
en temps pour une envie pressante ou ce
genre de choses mais si c'est trop
répétitif ça pourrait être sanctionné sa
discrétion des arbitres c'est toujours
pareil cavalière donc il veut vraiment
il fait c'est voilà c'est le coup
d'amélioration dont je parlais que
j'avais pas vu qu'il a vu Magnus sur
grand rock
donc il va pas se passer un truc là
je regardais ça des choses comme ça
attention
pas de choix
c'est
tout C4
les grands rock je sais pas je sens pas
grand rock quand
le problème maintenant qui protège de
manière intelligente ce pion le problème
c'est que maintenant on voit les blancs
et du temps parce que le cavalier B6 est
en l'air comme on dit
joli coup car il est à 5 en M
normalement il veut jouer avec les Noirs
dans la Grenelle pour les connaisseurs
cavaliers à 5 comment on fait pas
évident tomber 8 et un coup qu'on a pas
envie de jouer parce que la tour est
passive ensuite
bon ça marche
ça mange
il est en retard c'est pas sans question
je te dise moi l'horreur est pas fixe en
début de c'est ça le problème en début
de journée il est pas fixe l'horreur
donc c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué c'est avant tout un show
mais oui effectivement Magnus aurait dû
commencer la première partie avec 5
minutes de retard ou 10
je sais pas quelle est la règle
honnêtement et vous tombez vite quand
même
ok ça peut être aussi l'erreur de
quelqu'un de l'organisation on sait pas
arrive à 20h quoi qu'il arrive possible
aussi j'en sais rien
j'ai pas du tout les infos
maxime est tout rouge tandis que notre
ami manus Carlsen avec un
il peut voir il peut voir comment est la
qualité de son air s'il faut ouvrir la
fenêtre ou pas
merci à eux de soutenir et de
sponsoriser ce champion de chaise tours
ok recette va être très probablement
jouer c'est vrai qu'il y a du il y a des
compensations mais est-ce que c'est
assez
je n'en sais rien
je n'en sais absolument rien je crois
pas au feeling je crois pas
normalement il est assez il est très
correct sur un échiquier Magnus ça il y
a pas de problème
mais là bon ça arrive un peu oublier
aussi
oui c'est vrai que manus tente plus de
choses au niveau capillaire
effectivement ça on peut pas lui enlever
pourquoi il y a pas Foucan à 6 oui mais
faut croire ici c'est peut-être une main
pourquoi il est pas fou point à 6h sur
ça
c'est quoi la ligne puis on prend
ah peut-être toi à 8
non pas toi à 8 puis on prend
sur un coup de dames en fait
on a deux pièces
non où est-ce que devait aller la dame
j'en sais rien je vais tricher
et donc c'est gagnant pour les noirs
6 alors maintenant est-ce que
est-ce que vous prend un si c'est un
coup ou pas
qui calme tout le monde
parce que puis on prend évidemment
faut faire tour à 8
pas très dur à calculer pour ce genre de
joueur
il y a pas la place désolé non le
layoutées
[Musique]
pas tout à fait la place c'est pas prévu
pour voir les pièces capturer
depuis que j'ai Racing chez moi j'ai
gagné 300 points à l'eau et ouais ça
m'étonne pas
ok cavalier F6 donc mais normalement pas
assez de contre le tour géant oh ton
géant qui contre-attaque sur le purger
qui gagne un temps et qu'est-ce qu'il
veut faire tourger 5 quelque chose de
dynamique peut-être
ne pas laisser manus Carlson s'organiser
tourger 5 jouets
fd7 probablement
c'est encore une fois bien joué de la
part de Maxime
c'est assez intéressant ce qui nous fait
il nous fait encore une grosse partie
pour l'instant
comment on fait avec les Noirs c'est pas
évident du tout
il va falloir protéger comme ça j'ai
l'impression ou alors faire tourrage 5
mais c'est embêtant mais non toi 5 ouais
quand même très passive
on n'aime pas ça
je vais ça ou pas
OK
c'est vrai qu'on a ce cahier en B6 c'est
pas grand chose
cela dit est-ce que vous ces quatre est
une vraie menace
beaucoup de subtilité
je trouve ça clarifie à fond
peut-être cavalier prend simplement
va faire WAF 6 peut-être c'est pas si
bon que ça
quels sont les autres options pour les
blancs c'est une autre question
sur le long terme on a le plus en H qui
est faible clairement
et puis on B7 aussi est faible parce que
très très embêtant ce cavalier quand on
y réfléchit on peut jamais faire baisser
si échec et on peut pas bouger la tour
donc pour l'instant il immobilise une
tour entière
ouais dans Maxime
ouais c'est vrai que c'est pas une
agence d'attaque avec les Noirs
clairement
là c'est aussi il joue
il joue avec le feu hein
Maxime sur son territoire
c'est quand même
c'est quand même osé
donc tous ces quatre et change les fous
est-ce que je peux faire toi
semble être un coup très raisonnable
pour contre-attaquer tout de suite et
menacer éventuellement devenir un chute
même si on menace pas vraiment à cause
de toujours ce pur en baissé de c'est
qu'est-ce que c'est embêtant ce pur on
baise cette
fois c'est quatre tours par Magnus je
suis pour le beau jeu je le répète
je le répète
pour le beau jeu avant tout pour un beau
match et on a un très beau match pour
l'instant
c'est ça
c'est de voir des beaux spectacles c'est
ce qu'on a envie de voir ton G3 pas mal
et du Grand Maxime on a envie de voir du
Grand Maxime
qui pose le maximum de problèmes à
Magnus et pourquoi pas pourquoi pas une
victoire de prestige face à manuscrite
vu comment se passe ce match et vu
comment maxime a joué depuis le début du
tournoi c'est tout le mal qu'on lui
souhaite
et tourage 4 coups du retour évidemment
échanger en G3 était pas un bon deal
c'était proposition malhonnête de la
part de Maxime de rétablir la structure
de pions et donc Magnus
qui n'est pas à perdre de l'année
à refuser
cette offre mais ça résout pas
son problème alors peut-être envisager
des choses comme ça
d'abord qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les
Blancs c'est ça la grande question
comment on améliore
je sais pas comment on améliore
nettement c'est très dur et très dur
cette position je serais hyper tenté
jouer cahier des 5 mais apparemment
je j'aime pas qu'est-ce que je vous dise
moi j'aime pas du tout
prend et en bloc c'est ça
je peux quasiment bloquer le roi
quasiment
peut-être simplement un coup de A4 ou un
coup comme ça pour essayer d'améliorer
notre situation à la dame et puis
finalement après tout on a une majorité
3 contre 2 donc pourquoi pas essayer de
valoriser cette majorité en poussant nos
pions
ça se tient parce que
je pense que j'en arriverai à cette
conclusion
que bon finalement je sais pas trop quoi
faire
et
voilà
et joue B3 ouais B3 roi B2 dans le même
esprit sur protège ici on va faire un 4
gentiment on va améliorer nos pièces
parce que on sait pas trop quoi faire
mais on sait pas non plus que vont faire
les noirs
c'est un peu bizarre comme position mais
je pense que c'est un bon coup de jouer
à la dame ça m'en concept alors comment
exactement
je sais pas
ouais aussi il faut prendre et ces
quatre clés 3 mais il y a pas d'urgence
pour ça parce que le problème de jouer
qui est C4 c'est quand l'hiver la tour
et ça on n'aime pas on est content de
voir cette tour en V8 pourquoi pas roi
B2 à 4 on améliore notre situation il y
a pas grand chose à faire en vrai je
crois qu'il en est
il est venu à même conclusion que moi
et donc
pas grand chose à faire donc améliorant
nos pièces gentiment
et il avait primo qui est prend ses
quatre donc maintenant le cavalier en C4
est-ce que il va profiter pour bouger sa
tour attention on peut y avoir le coudre
du retour à 5 qui peut être pénible
ça donne
B5 mes tours c'est 8-3 B2 ou 4 même
quand j'aime bien B3
5 minutes pour les deux joueurs et plein
de alors même si c'est pas un feu
d'artifice il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
contenu dans cette partie c'est très
intéressant en tout cas moi je trouve ça
passionnant
tourage 8 menace tour reprend H2
j'espère que vous aussi si vous restez à
cette heure là
c'est que c'est passionnant pour vous
aussi
prochaine compet en novembre de
69 100
je serai présent aussi au Cap d'Agde
mais je ferai quelques Blitz simplement
donc vraiment en semi vacances
alors tourgé de protège le pion h et oui
et surtout H3 on va faire tout rêve de
gentiment
et on se garde les options soit devenir
indécis soit de venir à 5 j'aime
beaucoup ce qui fait Maxime il joue très
très bien Maxime il peut organiser ça
qui arrive aussi avec ton cavalier prend
et tu reprends et on va laisser tourner
deux ensuite
moi j'aime beaucoup ce qu'il fait là
honnêtement
je trouve ça très harmonieux là et
Magnus en grande difficulté 4 30 contre
5 15
comment on fait avec les Noirs pas
évident pas évident du tout
de moi simplement alors c'est pas le
plus c'est pas le plus beau pion du
monde parce qu'on a cette structures
affaiblies mais
c'est un pion
c'est indéniable
je sais pas du tout ce qu'il doit faire
maintenant
je joue pas le grand Suisse ouais non je
me suis dégonflé dégonfle là
pour faire 11 nuls je me suis dit pour
faire dans une sous la pluie et sous le
vent
voilà c'est ça ok intéressant
ok au moins on a résolu ce problème mais
on donne cavalier à 5 peut-être pour
faire cacher 6 peut-être que c'est 8
concret en donne cavaliers 3 aussi hein
on ramène le cavalier qui est quand même
très très belle case ici on donne 6 mais
qui aide ici ça peut atterri parce que
où on va la case ici est prise on s'est
un peu autant enfermé on n'aime pas
qu'il est ici donc à mon avis ça je joue
entre Caval et A5 et cavaliero 3 c'est
ça la réflexion de Maxime c'est une
évidence ici
et pas l'angle la réflexion qui avait le
3 jouer qui est B6 joué par Magnus
Carlsen qui sur contrôle ici en des 5 et
il dit que les final de Tours seront
tenables ou peut-être qu'il est pas
vraiment le choix
il a probablement raison les finales de
tour sont toujours nuls et c'est vrai
qu'on a vraiment du jeu parce que la
structure est quand même il y a deux
faiblesses ici donc ça ça compense plus
ou moins le pur en moins
intéressant ce qui fait
ouais ça mettrait si il gagne cette
partie effectivement ça met Magnus dans
le dur
mais il y a pas trop de risques dans
cette partie c'est ça qui est bien déjà
c'est que c'est dur d'imaginer des
scénarios il la perd
les scénarios des scénarios où il repère
le pion on peut imaginer des scénarios
il perd la partie ça va être dur
comment on fait 350 contre 3,40 et
Maxime qui joue à une dame je vous en
parlais et oui parce qu'on a pas
tellement le choix on n'a pas tellement
de coups utile son liquide tout soit on
essaie de valoriser cette majorité ça va
être pris ici je pense
ouais c'est pris comme ça on crée encore
une fois des faiblesses et vous voyez la
structure de des blancs qui est quand
même en lambeau il y a quand même
beaucoup beaucoup de faiblesses donc on
va jouer sur ça on est toujours d'accord
pour la finale de Tours qui serait assez
facilement nul
comment on fait maintenant roi B2 1
quoi d'autre parce que si on bouge le
cavalier quelque part le pion à tombe et
si on fait ça et bien on fait tout
échanger et ça va pas aller très fort on
va pas on va pas avoir des chances sur
puis on prend attention la tour qui
surveille ça et surtout reprend je sais
pas même
peut-être trois aussi quelque chose
comme ça tourner deux tours c'est 6
ça va être dur de progresser honnêtement
mais est-ce qu'il a mieux que ça c'est
ça est-ce que roi B2 c'est mieux que ça
roi B2
en tout cas il y a ça
peut-être tomber vite là petit chantage
roi B2 jouer par Maxime va chez Lagrave
qui monte de l'ambition parce que cahier
des 5 était quasi une proposition de nul
ton B8 je vois pas le truc je vois pas
le délire
alors on peut on peut foncer allez
ça peut être oh on s'est mis dans un
truc là non
est-ce qu'on s'est mis dans un truc ou
pas
peut-être à 5 on va prendre à 5 tours on
attaque l'autre cavalier donc on est
obligé de reculer et maintenant ah non
viens pas ceci revient qu'il est B5
intéressant mais si roi V3 on peut faire
toujours que fd7 il a joué tombé 8
Magnus cars 7 et oui c'est évident
tourbé 8 3 à 2 et tour C8 jouer par
Magnus et sur roi B3 je crois qu'il va
même pas faire tomber 8 il va faire
cavalier
je retire ce que je dis fd7 il y a échec
ça va pas je rappelle que je regarde la
jauge enfin on a à jauge d'évaluation
mais j'ai pas les coups
et salut à toi Yoha cher futur voisine
incroyable mon des petits
on attaque le pion
et comment on fait
chez Maxime tour F2 mais c'est moche ton
F2 on n'a pas envie de jouer ça j'ai
envie d'être actif
mais trois c'est la seule façon de pas
répéter mais attention 2 minutes pour
Maxime tu mets dans la zone rouge là
niveau temps
il va peut-être falloir mettre un petit
coup de frein quoi que tout reprend F3
et pas une menace il y a il y a cavalier
F5 ou cahier des 5 pour l'instant qui
gagne la qualité donc ça irait
à 5 est-ce que à 5 est jouable à 5 est
tout à fait jouable cavalier c'est 4 je
suppose
et cavalier prend fais pas trop de sens
cahier des cinq et prank et prend et roi
et je suppose
parce qu'on est peureux on est lâche ton
âge 3 jouer à 5 jouets on trouve tous
les coups là je suis aidé par le chat
et
on trouve tous les coups
à 5 et ces quatre va venir je pense que
BD7 aussi solide les deux les deux se
discutent
au feeling c'est que
c'est ça marche
à 5 c'est jouer par Magnus Carlsen qui
est quand même un joueur intuitif s'il
en est qui prend allez vas-y
[Musique]
et il va jouer normalement
l'acheter m'empêcher de proposer aussi
mais effectivement c'est un meilleur
coup si on se fait pas mater j'avais
peur de je vois toujours le scénario du
pire
et donc le truc où on se fait mater avec
une tour qui apparaît ici mais c'est
vrai qu'elle a du mal à apparaître ici
le roi centralisé dans les finales bien
sûr
si ce comment on fait tourber 3 et il
veut essayer de faire ce plan alors il
donne le pion
non
c'est 5 et comment il fait tour c'est 5
directs joués par Magnus ah il veut
prendre sur échec il est là il est là
quand même l'ancien champion du monde de
partie classique
il est pas devenu aveugle moi je vous le
dis
il est quand même costaud
il se défend toujours avec autant de
précision il a pris l'avance autant
alors qu'il a mangé la moitié de la
partie
quand même il est assez énorme il se
défend bien et sa poubelle après
l'ouverture
comment on fait maintenant où est-ce que
tu reprends F3 marche
c'est quoi la réfute
ouais j'avais vu tomber 5 et je m'étais
dit ah malin mais roi A4 qui est
épreuves trois pas assez malin qui a
essayé cette caille prend mes cinq
pour ces trois qu'est-ce qu'il a joué il
a joué ça c'est une surprise donc il
veut revenir par là et pouvoir encaisser
comme ça oh c'est pas mal joué ça
F4 et si tu as un mauvais coup d'après
la jauge et c'est la première fois de la
partie que les noirs sont mieux et c'est
pas bon pour Maxime ça je disais qu'il y
avait pas de risque oh là j'ai les
points c'est quelque chose de bien il y
a pas tombé vite là et tomber vite jouer
monastère
tout d'un coup ça a tourné cette partie
les mouches ont changé d'âne tomber 3
oui seul coup on reprend Robert il y a
pas de cahier des deux la case et
contrôlée
on reprend les cahiers prend un 4 et oui
les noirs sont mieux maintenant voilà
Maxime qui doit se mettre en mode
défense maintenant il fait non de la
tête il a bien raison de faire le nom de
la tête parce que ça va pas là
comment on va faire comment on va faire
j'en sais rien il est fort ma muscarsen
quand même B4 ou BK cette casse qui
était valable pour B5 et 7
mais tour à 3 il est toujours ce
problème sur E4 qui prend 4 va arriver
c'est quasi certain mieux que on va
prendre 5 et apparemment d'après la
jauge c'est un avantage quasi gagnant
ou rabais de jolies pas de tour des
trois il y a cavalier F4 donc tout F3 ou
toi seul coup
tu vas avoir un problème sur le thème
des fourchettes c'est tout à 4 tour à 4
et jouable aussi vraiment
non il a joué ton F3 et plein de coups
F3
6 il prend le pion roi des 4 non oh là
là le roi est actif
alors évidemment on peut pousser la tour
je pense veut revenir sur B5 par exemple
comment prendre le pion là je sais pas
tout F5 peut-être que c'est 7
peut-être comme ça
pas si facile pas si facile
je vais mettre la je triche alerte
triche
c'est égal c'est égal d'après la jauge
après
c'est cette tour C5
et sur B6 sur C6 ah ouais bien vu allez
force c'est le jauge moi je vous le dis
et il a joué quoi il a joué tourgé 4
tout F2 échec trois B3 ou ton prince de
ces deux pions passer lié ça mais
apparemment qui a ici 5 a été raté
peut-être par Magnus
F5 ou 3 échec F5 est-ce que ça va gagner
cette finale de Tours un jour je mets
égal mais les noirs sont mieux ça c'est
sûr à quel point j'en sais rien
roasser vraiment F5 va être joué pour
prendre G6 qui est français 5b prend ses
5 rois français 5 est-ce que ça gagne
cette finale ou pas d'après la jauge non
on la croit
oh là là 20 secondes contre 40 il va
être obligé manuscrit est-ce que tu
retrouves une alternative je crois pas à
Tours quand même
tour 3 et un coup 30 secondes contre 20
tout peut se passer
F5 jouets cavalier aussi ah il fait pas
Erwan C4
ça joue fort moi je vous le dis il
manque ici et s'il y a pas de maths il
sait il s'est gouré Magnus Carlsen
qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire
il va faire tout à suite là non il va
faire attention et menace encaisser le
pion il va falloir fuir et peut-être
qu'on va avoir un tour câble et qu'on
tourne je sais pas
il va prendre sur échec évidemment qu'il
va prendre sur échec c'est certain et il
va revenir on a cette finale à défendre
qui est nul c'est sûr parce qu'au pire
du pire le pire des scénarios pour
[Musique]
pour Maxime c'est de voir sacrifier ce
cavalier qu'on ne pions et cette
filature qui avait qu'on tourne vous
allez voir une défense de fer de Maxime
machinagram une ne perd jamais ce genre
de position vous inquiétez pas il va pas
la perdre du tout
c'est supporter peuvent être rassurés
bon là attention il reste 10 secondes
quand même donc faut faire attention
c'est pas facile à défendre c'est sûr
mais
on lui fait confiance à Maxime ah c'est
bien joué ça
attaque le cavalier menace tomber 5
échecs il y a tombé 5 là ah c'est 6
menace
partout tomber cette OK
waouh ça joue fort mais là la défense
est difficile hein il a pris et il joue
F4 j'espère gagner ça c'est nul d'après
la jauge c'est bien juger de la part de
Maxime c'est pas évident à juger
c'est ça qui va revenir il va courir
avec le roi vite fait
c'est que c'est une tête de nul ok ça
comment on fait passer le roi la roi B5
simplement roi c'est satisfait ok F3 il
y a toujours quelqu'un F3 on peut pas
faire passer le roi ah waouh c'est bien
joué ça
on peut pas prendre a priori
il prend
oh ok j'ai quatre carrés
bravo Maxime belle défense quelle partie
encore regardez moi ça cavalier
est-ce que c'est le seul coup ou pas
est-ce que
doit perdre aussi
pas sûr
non
mais c'est très très joli et calculer
une vitesse il avait 10 ans
super
super partie une fois de plus les deux
joueurs qui nous régalent c'est du haut
et puis
il se défend il se défend le frérot
waouh ça se défend fort Magnus Carson
qui a décidé de de pas faire de cadeaux
non plus ça joue très fort ouais ouais
ça joue ça joue bien
ça joue ça joue très très bien
c'est quand même assez incroyable ouais
bien vu bien vu GG là il faut dire voilà
j'étais pour le beau jeu je crois qu'on
a des belles parties très
combative avec un contenu vraiment
passionnant
et les deux joueurs
jouent alors meilleur jeu c'est un peu
un fait derrière Nadal en finale de
Roland-Garros
c'est-à-dire qu'on a envie en fait quand
il y a deux parties on a envie d'avoir
10 quoi c'est ça le truc bon sur ce
je vais vous dire à quelle heure
commence la prochaine quand même soyons
fous
personne ne sait
bon à peu près une petite dizaine de
minutes a priori
mais
[Musique]
voilà petite dizaine de minutes je vous
montre le bracket
je vais je fais mes petites annonces
pour demain demain 18h qui est-ce qu'on
a on a guéri n'est pas miyashi alors là
alors là venez je sais pas j'ai envie
que les deux perles voilà là c'est sûr
je vous garantis que je rêve qui est un
double je sais pas c'est pas possible
que les deux perles je crois pas tant
pis et ensuite le vainqueur de Guérin et
pomyachi jouera le perdant de mvl contre
Magnus donc de toute façon un très beau
match
et
vendredi on a la grande finale donc le
vainqueur de tous ces matchs du loser
bracket rejoint le vainqueur
d'aujourd'hui de cette finale j'espère
que vous avez suivi je pense que c'est
pas hyper compliqué en vrai
et franchement ça donne envie d'en voir
plus mais demain guirin et pomyachi je
sais pas là là je suis là ça va être dur
ça va être ça va être très très
compliqué à commenter
j'ai vraiment envie que les deux perles
je sais pas comment on va faire
21h45 la prochaine
et je sais pas on l'a pas dit bon à peu
près voilà 5 6 minutes de pause et je
reviens
reste avec moi parce que là il y a quand
même du spectacle en perspective les
deux dernières parties est-ce que est-ce
que
mvl va continuer sur sa lancée sur cette
très belle lancée il y a pas de raison
qui continue pas sur sa lancée de tenir
la dragée haute au numéro 1 mondial
l'ogre norvégien Magnus Carlsen
à tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis de retour avant que ça ne râle
trop dans le chat twitch les poses
qu'est-ce que vous voulez il faut qu'il
se repose les joueurs clairement il
donne tout là grosse partie j'ai vu sur
Twitter là que c'était ils étaient sur
la première partie à plus de 99% de
de précision bon ben c'est juste assez
hallucinant
comment ça joue ce soir c'est incroyable
et c'est un très beau match qui nous
offre les deux joueurs vraiment
voilà ils ont refait le coup là
je vais permuter et
hop là et on a les deux joueurs qui sont
en place
la troisième partie va pas tarder à
débuter
très clairement
on va voir ça évidemment en direct
Maxime quel est noir dans la suivante
donc on va tourner chez qui
et ça va être
ça va être passionnant évidemment
comme ça les depuis le début
de ce tournoi avec Maxime qui a battu
Ali resa on le rappelle quand même
premier tour il a battu à lire Elsa et
ensuite il a battu chakra ma média Rohff
hier pour avoir le droit
de disputer un match de gala face à
Magnus Carl scène 4 partie 2
au vol
ah ça pue l'armée dans cette histoire
moi je vous le dis
et ça rejoue et cette fois c'est Maxime
qui a les noirs on va le mettre du côté
noir et il rejoue une nage d'or
oh là là décidément petit débat
théorique entre les deux joueurs mais
c'est plutôt le terrain de
Maxime il joue aussi OK
je vais aussi tourner les trucs là voilà
j'en fais plus les mêmes boulettes au
début
donc faut 3 et donc là on voit la
différence avec l'autre partie c'est à
faux 3 il a joué ok j'ai 4 Maxime
c'est connu
on peut l'autre option évidemment c'est
de jouer fouger 5 mais après on joue à 6
G5 c'est la ligne favorite de Gary
Kasparov mais il décide de jouer fou
c'est un kf6 F3 du coup pour éviter pour
éviter faut trois pour éviter que les G4
pardon et 6 x 3 B5 dames des deux
et la différence c'est que manuscrit son
pion en E5 et il a décidé Maxime
de le laisser en
et de jouer qui est BD7 la ligne
l'ancienne ligne de l'attaque anglaise
le 5 est plus populaire
ces dernières années mais bon
si ça reste complètement jouable on va
faire B7 il y a énormément de
théories comme d'habitude pour les
blancs on se pose la question de savoir
si on fait grand que d'abord où j'ai 4
les deux sont parfaitement jouables A4
parfois et jouable aussi mais alors
c'est en change complètement de plan
bon Magnus qui réfléchit visiblement
attrapé
dans l'ouverture j'ai 4 enfin attrapé
entre guillemets qui s'attendait pas
aussi c'est un Maxime mais normalement
un joueur de il jouait que 5 c'est
nashdorf alors B4 encore de coup cavaler
A4 ou cavalier 2 deux écoles énormément
d'options à chaque coup
H6 faut empêcher G5 parce que maintenant
en fait de jouer H6 menace de jouer des
cinq parce que des 5 n'allaient pas du
tout ici il y avait G5 on attaqué le
cavalier qui a été obligé de partir et
on prenait ici c'était la cata on nous
voit le centre et le roi et pas du tout
en sécurité donc il joue à 6
tous ces coups jouent à tempo ont du
sens la grand rock doit être le coup
parfois on peut faire C4 aussi
ça existe mais non mais c'est 4 règles
pions en G2 parce que pour faire faux de
petits rocks mais là c'est clairement
grand après on peut prendre le pion
aussi attention prise du pion je suis
plus ce qu'on fait là on doit faire des
dessins comme à mon avis
et ensuite puis on prend le 4 et c'est
qu'on a du contre jeu sur le centre
des cinq attaques la dame
alors
elles peut gagner et bien sûr qu'elle
peut gagner là c'est c'est une nageur
c'est son terrain
c'est son terrain de jeu favori
clairement heureusement oui alors là
c'est vraiment c'est des parties à trois
résultats ce genre de truc
c'était quoi la ligne est-ce que c'est
pas ça la ligne grand rock Damas 5
B3 qui est 5 à 3
qui est un 4 à prendre mes 4 il y avait
une vieille ligne comme ça puis on prend
un 4 alors je
vous dis 5 je crois
pour essayer de contre-jour on fait au 5
d'un pro 5 et jamais possible il faut F4
qui est 17 et ce genre de choses archi
complexe archi étudié
mais si on n'est pas prêt les blancs on
se dégonflent un peu normalement
c'est vraiment ouais c'est 55 ans
c'est vraiment là à ce niveau là
et Magnus a décidé de se faire un
challenge de ce match donc plus de 4 5
on joue des nages d'orf attention la
dernière fois qu'il avait fait ça je me
rappelle d'un match à Londres
le match
donc faut qu'il fasse attention parce
que Maxime sur son terrain de jeu
favoris
il est il est très très dangereux
il y a pas 50 coups c'est soit grand
rock Sodome
7 qui est prend B4 on va faire que 5 on
va attaquer tous les pions
c'est pas que le coup
des sacs certainement surpuis on prend
la Foux
il fait grand rock Magnus Carlsen et pas
du tout pas de massacre il a fait
cavaluer au 5e peau
Maxime va chier la grave
ok une autre ligne que je ouais j'ai pas
trop la réfe là il menace fous des 7 en
tout cas
en tout cas j'ai certainement étudié ce
genre de position mais ça fait longtemps
je me souviens plus
voyez-vous
mais Maxime qui sort ses prépas en plus
donc il prend ça très très au sérieux il
a envie de gagner ce tournoi
et peut-être une qualife pour Toronto
ça serait pas impossible
B3 jouer par Magnus Carlsen et oui comme
ça sur food D7 il a cavalier B2 qui est
possible
profilaxie B3
qui fait réfléchir maximum un petit peu
donc ça va peut-être dire non c'est fou
des sept et jouer assez rapidement quand
même donc ça veut dire que c'est
peut-être toujours la première ligne de
relique et B2 bon ça peut pauvre un jeu
qui est B2 mais peut-être à 5 à 4 à 5
fausses méfier de cab5 quand même
quoique
quoi
que c'est complexe cette histoire ça par
exemple ça a l'air bien pour les blancs
donc on peut pas faire n'importe quoi
non plus
qu'est-ce qu'on peut jouer d'autre on
n'est pas très tenté de jouer faux cette
petit rock parce qu'on va se faire on va
se prendre une avalanche de l'autre côté
donc on est plutôt tenté de faire un
coup
à l'aile dame lequel ou au centre des
cinq des cinq et un coup
de prendre le 4 Scipion prend on reprend
du cavalier attention
les trous
donc des 5 vraiment et un cookie qui
vient qui vient assez rapidement à
l'esprit
alors
comment il va faire je sais pas dessin
que je jouerai des 5
après
je joue pas là-bas et je joue pas là non
plus mais si ça marche ça a beaucoup
parce qu'on prend le centre c'est le
fameux coup libérateur alors c'est pas
toujours le cas
mais effectivement quand des 5 marches
ah oui c'est sûr que c'était vrai
artichaut au speck mais la vérité c'est
que les deux joueurs se souviennent plus
là donc il joue par eux-mêmes
ils auraient plus vite
ouais c'est peut-être 30 000 dollars
pour le premier quelque chose comme ça
oui il y a des beaux prix ça c'est sûr
des cinq jouets par mvl
mais c'est encore plus le prestige que
les prix là
alors Magnus qui réfléchit parfois il se
souvient maintenant attention il connaît
ses vieilles lignes il rigole pas
FF4
on sait pas trop comment ils se souvient
mais il se souvient au final il a pris
son temps mais en fait c'était juste
pour vérifier que ça allait bien
retomber
faut se méfier avec ma muscarsen il a
une culture échecienne très très vaste
FF4 c'est logique
comment on fait maintenant avec ce
cavalier c'est ça l'embrouille
on fait ça
sa tête de mauvais coup ça c'est
terrible c'est une tête de mauvais coup
mais bon peut-être qu'on doit faire ça à
la jauge j'ai pas choqué
et sur 5 c'est quoi le délire
oh la jauge qui me refuse pas tout de
suite incroyable
ouh là là faut faire
3 et qui prend un cadre de MD4 à tempo
ah
encore une fois waouh
pourquoi pour empêcher fousser 5 parce
que
c'était jouer très vite
maintenant on a que deux pions pour la
pièce avec les Noirs donc il faut faire
quelque chose de très rapide et ces
trois a l'air vraiment t'entend
parce que quoi d'autre franchement
on a un problème sur G7 là on peut pas
sortir les pièces normalement donc c'est
trois mois à ta claque la tour attaque
le pion créer du jeu damassin aussi
peut-être faire des bras à deux et
menacer mat
mais je sais pas au feeling ça va pas
marcher
j'ai dit mon feeling est pas mauvais
jour j'ai pas content je triche un peu
pour voir le pour effacer trois
change d'avis
alors
pour les noirs
c'est beau c'est beau
mais on n'est pas là à mon avis c'est
toi qui est C3 soit Damas 5
tour G8
alors évidemment l'idée c'est de
protéger le pion de menacer fousser 5
éventuellement j'ai 5 fou G7
on y croit un peu moins mais fous ces
cinq est une énorme menace
ah ouais son polo galère ouais
en référence Adam FGH contre deux fois
FGH ou de la gagner après certainement
avoir ajourné
c'est incroyable ce qui se passe
je vois plus fort que la joie et la
jauge elle montre davantage blanc mais
bon
pas décisif tout ça
comment on fait maintenant
est-ce que ça c'est jouable moi je ferai
ça je suis un peu pour empêcher c'est ça
j'aime pas
et
on peut faire des camions on va faire ça
non
OK
on va pas se voiler la face
alors après c'est un truc comme ça et
jouable
après tout c'est pas mes pieds
ça donne quoi ce truc
quand même plus ou moins forcé sinon
4 c'est pas très dangereux
et c'est jouer cavalier 5
alors je vous garantis que cavalier 5 il
veut il veut il veut claquer
surtout C5 il veut prendre ça c'est 100%
qu'est le 5 foot C5 23 24 puis on prend
on va refaire sa ralenti et prendre des
7 d'un prendre pour prendre alors c'est
quoi le matériel
déjà reprenons les choses à leur base 5
7 donc deux pions on a deux pions
et une tour
contre fu cavalier mais j'ai
l'impression
il faut voir on arrive à bloquer quand
même fort fou j'ai deux peut-être
faut que j'ai deux F5
peut-être
c'est embêtant de doubler
non
ça ensuite
c'est pas possible je mets je mets les
variantes là
c'est quoi le bon coup dans cette
position ça m'intrigue la jauge nous dit
cavalier à 4
c'est à qui qu'on peut pas aller sur une
case normale on est obligé de rester sur
cette diagonale
sur fout des quatre par exemple il y a
fougé 2 et tourner
c'est jouer c'est jouer c'est toute
cette ligne a été jouée par les deux
joueurs
s'il trouve cavalier A4
si tu trouves qu'elle est à 4 c'est un
jouable
parce que c'est pas logique
c'est tout simplement pas logique de
jouer cavalier à 4
c'est le cavalier on n'a pas envie de le
mettre sur la bande comme ça mais c'est
le meilleur coup
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça donne ça
un coup normal
un coup humain
ah si je joue cavalier
5 soit 7
soit j'ai 5 peut-être F5 pourquoi pas
5 il aime pas
échec
ouais un truc comme ça peut arriver
alors
ici
on s'enlève du méchant clouage éventuel
et ça serait après à peu près équilibré
d'après la jauge mais va-t-il trouver
cavalier à 4,5 ça serait incroyable qui
est C4 a été joué et oui Cavalia cast
était trop dur une fois qu'on le voit on
comprend mais franchement c'est dur
franchement c'est c'est
ce que je disais alors
il a joué le coup humain
s'appelle manus Carlsen mais bon il est
humain quand même
recette et le coup humain aussi on
s'enlève de toutes les embrouilles
mais pas le style de Maxime recette à
mon avis
il aime bien les choses plus concrètes
plus direct
on va voir ce qu'il fait
f6g quoi mais voilà je vous l'avais dit
je vous avais dit qu'il est plus concret
que que ça Maxime et apparemment le coup
est pas mauvais d'ailleurs
la jauge n'a pas bondi
et cette maintenant ok il veut faire F5
et avoir ces trois pions passés
un 5 contre 2 à jouer
effectivement
aux échecs comme au rugby
c'est sympa 5 contre 2
comment on fait
a priori peut-être H4 est-ce qu'on peut
faire H4 pour essayer d'activer cette
tour vouloir développer le foot casse
blanche
qu'est-ce qui nous fait
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui nous fait Magnus
mais la main devant les yeux H4 jouer
logique on va activer la tour
tout simplement
qui remet une pièce dans la machine
j'adore j'adore ton style très très bien
vu
un cavalier A4 tu joues Caval A4 comme
cramique t'es pas bien
c'est
direct
ok tour des 8
une tour sur une conne ouverte quoi de
plus naturelle mais c'est un mauvais
coup d'après la jauge
cause de ça
non pas du tout à cause de ça
peut être comme ça
pas bon ça
pas mal quand même
toi aussi peut-être très simple je vais
tant que c'est le pion ah j'ai compris
ou pas
ça ça peut être cher puis on prend
Maxime ok ok autant pour moi
il faut de maintenant protège et laisse
les Noirs dans la nasse avec ce pion
foie F4 ici mal débrouillé les rois
c'est dommage c'est dommage pour Maxime
il s'est mal débrouillé le roi ça s'est
mal passé
mais bien sûr quand on le sait Gargantua
29 ah tu tu viens pas c'est souvent
on en sait plus sur le coach secret de
ML en connaissant l'identité et
d'ailleurs dans le chat ils vont te le
dire dans le chat twitch pour ceux qui
suivent
qui est le coach secret de mvl c'est
connu
c'est très très connu
ah c'est connu du chat ça c'est
tout de suite
ton G6
et maintenant F4 on sera organisé
cavaliers 5 grosses et la tour donc là
faut faire attention il faut s'organiser
faut s'organiser sur ce cavalier 5
comment on fait
F6 mais c'est moche F6 pas du tout envie
de jouer comme ça
ah c'est désolé the French corser là
c'est parti en ligne pour devenir plus
importantes que le IRL je crois que
c'est en train ouais on prend vraiment
cette cette voie là il y a des lentilles
c'est très investi dans titre riche bon
alors Laurent bravo à droite 23 et il
suit il suit
aussi bravo bravo boljito bravo on voit
ah voilà on voit ceux qui suivent ça
fait plaisir
c'est plaisir voilà il faut pas le dire
il faut pas le dire c'est un secret
voilà
facile
non non non
[Musique]
ça a été dit ici plein de fois
c'est connu
mais il faut pas ça se crée entre nous
en dehors de l'eau en blanc ah ben oui
mais c'est lui
il a fait exprès de perdre d'enfoncer
les Lyonnais pauvre Maxime qui est
supporté à lyonnais
mais bon il gagne Laurent Blanc
le 13 comme on l'appelait
alors fous des 4 bien joué encore une
fois empêche que 5 on voit il s'est
passé tellement de choses il y a 5
minutes au 2 joueurs alors c'est une
éternité très peu à la fois
qui veut prendre la paire de fou il aime
les fous manuscrits
on reprend et c'est vrai que c'était
tentant de prendre ses fous parce que
maintenant sans le foot casoar ça va
être compliqué on va revenir ici on va
essayer d'encaisser spion
et F5 ouais quoi d'autre en même temps
il a raison Maxime
il est fatigué
ce soir mais en quoi
évidemment ils ont perdu ils sont en
division 18 de rugby là c'est terminé là
et il a pris je vous fais F4 OK et
réattaque ce pion et vous voyez c'est
fou qui font un très bon job se fout de
case noir ouais 5 pourquoi pas mais les
fous qui font un très bon job de blocus
et les blancs sont mieux là c'est une
évidence après à quel point j'en sais
rien est-ce que ça c'est un bon coup pas
ça me semble pas être un bon coup j'aime
pas ça parce que échanger
pour essayer de s'activer cette dur à
gagner donc
il faut bien sûr regardez tout le
clouage marche pas très bien c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire ou pas
donc faut prendre juste sur le coup et
c'est le coup jouer et on regarde la
tour pour qu'on regarde la tour parce
qu'on va revenir ici on va on va coller
une tour par là et ça va être quand même
très désagréable avec les deux fous on
peut voir des attaques de maths
j'ai 8 il y a 3
c'est un petit milieu qui rachète Mona
donc ça c'est un tout se sait
tout se sait
il y a des
confidence qui sont faites
qui en sont plus
mais ouais c'est compliqué de garder un
secret
alors
faut prendre 6 et Maxime réfléchit merci
beaucoup magnésium calcium
non ça fait partie du running gag
maintenant il le dira jusqu'au bout
c'est la dernière épisode
il s'arrêtera jamais de le dire le il y
aura un moment ou le dernier épisode
arrivera ça c'est sûr
qu'est-ce qu'on fait FF on doit garder
c'est la colonne g parce qu'il faut
juste cinq échecs donc où va-t-on est-ce
qu'on revient est-ce qu'on vient là pas
très clair
c'est nul de fou contre tour oui de fou
nu contre tout nuage
ouais c'est mieux
c'est de fou contre cavalier qui est
gagnant
mais bien sûr
je one qui c'est le même Laurent Blanc
que le foot mais oui évidemment
c'est vrai quoi
le champion du monde le champion de golf
aussi
évidemment
alors ton G6
pas mal parce que ça garde ça garde un
œil partout j'aime bien ce genre de coup
ça va pas être facile pour pour Maxime
dans cette partie il va falloir sortir à
l'école française de la souffrance
à son meilleur niveau là parce que il
s'est fait avoir dans les dans les
complications
ça pouvait tourner dans n'importe quel
sens mais ça tourne du côté de Magnus
pour l'instant c'est pas fini 3 18
contre 3,50 et on sait que ça défend
bien vous C4 pourquoi on peut pas faire
s'il peut le faire il va jouer c'est sûr
qu'est-ce qu'on fait sur 5 je comprends
rien
ou c'est très mauvais rose alors c'est
pas mauvais c'est très mauvais peut-être
tour H7 et tout recettes est-ce qu'on
empêche
comme moi
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
il a raté il a raté
c'est vraiment l'école française de la
souffrance donc échec va arriver mais si
sur échec
donc ça c'est le pire donc il va faire
ça je vous dis ce qu'il veut faire
et il dit tu passeras jamais
le roi est coupé heureusement
ça
quoi on s'est invente une vie avec le
roi mais bon on a vite rappelé à la dure
réalité peut-être fou B6 aussi pour
commencer à chatouiller les pions
ah c'est dommage pour Maxime pas fait
beaucoup d'erreurs dans cette partie
mais bon qu'est-ce que ça joue quoi ça
joue bien en face ça joue la c'est la
grande forme du Tour H5 ah j'avais pas
vu du tout ça ouais
c'était ça la pointe c'était sur géant
roi B2 tours
à l'autre il a cru que c'était une
forteresse
donc il a cru Maxime il a dit ok tu la
défense celle-là
d'après un jour non
mais alors c'est risqué de laisser ses
pions en vie
alors attention on va pas aller
n'importe où c'est ça aussi le truc pour
des 7 ouais
et là il va vraiment faire ça là
faut avoir le cœur vert raccroché quand
même avec ses pions qui font alors après
c'est contrôlé par les poussettes et on
orchestre donc on peut sacrifier un fou
parce qu'on a une dame et FF3 OK
mais quand même
il faut être en confiance là
il est
il va faire pousser trois sur F2 je
suppose fou ces trois on va où avec le
roi
moi
pousser trois rois j'ai 6
étoiles
OK et donc sur dame ça permet donc Tower
bien bon coup pour protéger le pion
pourquoi ça perdrait
parce que on est cuit dur là dans cette
finale hop c'est qui a été de plus mais
trois pions moins
quelle partie quelle partie encore une
vainque entre deux 50
le roi qui fonce évidemment faut pas il
se fait pas prier mvl il monte son roi
de 55 entre une 10 et c'est une partie à
trois résultats moi je vous le dis elle
est incroyable cette partie une fois de
plus les deux joueurs qui nous offrent
un spectacle absolument fabuleux il
menace ton C7 tours C4 elle est
fabuleuse cette partie il va tenir à
peut-être même la gagner je sais pas on
sait pas ce qui va se passer on ne sait
pas
oh là là qu'est-ce qui va se passer la
48 secondes pour manuscrite et ben c'est
dur à jouer
faut qu'il se dépêche parce qu'avec
simplement toi F6 joué qu'est-ce qui se
passe sur E3 et regarder à jauge qui a
changé d'avis ben oui trois là et puis
ils sont trop dangereux là
oh là là qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce qui se passe
on peut avoir une Polo Galien ski galère
là avec de fou trois pions contre dames
c'est ton jamais j'en sais rien au
scénario
scénario rocambolesque qui pourrait
donner ça ça serait drôle il reste ce
serait une belle ironie de l'histoire
où
Magnus fait des cours d'histoire mais
qui se retourne contre lui
c'est loin d'être fini cette partie ça
peut gagner ça peut gagner pour Maxime
surtout vu le temps 45 secondes
simplement pour eux Manu c'est ces deux
pions tours c'est le master prends ces
quatre attention ça c'est méchant fous
des trois certainement ou c'est une
gaffe d'après la jauge
pourquoi personne ne sait
vraiment
regardez en fait je crois qu'il y avait
roi G4 et sur pions prendre dame est nul
mais il y a un F2
ouah tac les deux tours que c'est bien
joué et donc il fait pion français 4
maintenant à fout des quatre il a il a
vu le coup personne ne savait pourquoi
c'était mauvais sauf manuscrite on prend
et maintenant tour de obligatoire
et là il y a roi C3 ah la gaffe de
Maxime est roi des trois
et fini le droit est trop loin ça perd
oh là là là là
cette partie comme toutes les
précédentes d'ailleurs
incroyable ce qui s'est passé mais ouais
voilà vraiment gaffe ici ça joue ici
ton C7 est une énorme gave qu'est-ce
qu'il fallait jouer
il fait jouer tour DD1 en même temps
pour me laver
tours
même peut-être la perdre
au 8 bref 4 à 5 est une pagaille en
descriptive qui se termine par la
nulsion l'oracle
stock fish
A6 3 1 il faut arrêter le fuyard des 4
tours à 6 il faut prendre 3 mais bon en
pratique les blancs sont mieux mais
c'est nul et dommage dommage d'avoir
perdu comme ça mais il est impitoyable
manuscrit
et bien sûr qu'il en reste une il en
reste une il en reste une évidemment
qu'il en reste une et ça va être
ça va être dans
9 petites minutes
donc comme d'hab mais
je sais pas quand les joueurs quand les
gens me demandent dans le chat si les
joueurs voient la jauge je sais pas
s'ils sont sérieux ou pas
peut-être ouais non non il voit pas la
jauge évidemment c'est de la triche de
voir la jauge ça va pas
donc belle
partie magnifique de Magnus Carlsen une
nouvelle fois que ça est sorti avec très
peu de temps mais
Maxime aura les blondes à la dernière et
il s'est créé des belles chances de gain
à la deuxième
donc c'est pas fini c'est pas fini
on reste de toute façon et on voit si
Maxime peut accrocher un Armageddon en
gagnant cette dernière partie en tout
cas il va il va tenter c'est une
certitude
et moi je vous laisse avec votre vos
pubs préférés et je reviens
dans quelques petites minutes reprises
dans
la alors je vous parle dans 8 minutes
donc je reviens dans 4 5 minutes tout de
suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiquier
surplus a du monde au tournoi des
candidats en passant par le speechesse
ou les title twist
day.com/avent tous les plus grands
tournois d'échecs qui se déroulent en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez comprenez
en direct les parties des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases
retrouvez toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les
comptes rendus quotidien les bio des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chaise.com/avent
aussi bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle part
ailleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je suis de retour pour cette dernière
partie entre Maxime Vacher Lagrave et
Magnus Carson dans ce duel a le temps
tout simplement
magnifique les deux joueurs qui sont qui
nous offrent un très très beau spectacle
il y en a hâte de voir la suite on
regarde le bracket rapidement 2-1 si
Maxime va chez Lagrave ne gagne pas il
jouera demain
ah vers 20h face au gagnant de guéri
n'est pas myashi
pour une chance de redéfier manuscrit
qu'il revienne
et ça c'est bien possible ça serait pas
une première qu'il revienne avec les
Blancs il doit l'emporter
et
éventuellement avoir un Armageddon
et voilà s'offrir un magazine
va-t-il répéter
la nightcore qu'il a joué dans cette
partie 2 je sais pas c'est possible
c'est possible ça ce sont un état
d'esprit de vouloir
de vouloir
défier défier Maxime sur son territoire
on va voir tout ça
dans
peu de temps c'est l'avant-dernière
voilà c'est ça on a envie que ça
continue franchement je crois que tout
le monde a envie que ça continue
mais ça va je crois tout va bien
j'ai eu peur
ah et j'ai perdu oui comme d'hab ok
c'est génial et ça joue ça joue alors je
vais
on va permuter hop là et comme ça on va
voir les deux joueurs et on va les
récupérer à la partie tout de suite je
sais pas pourquoi à chaque fois parce
qu'à chaque fois il se remet ouais c'est
ça j'ai compris
il me fait une blague Magnus et donc
on a cette partie qui commence avec
Maxime va chez lagraphe qui a les blancs
et on a une sicienne qui n'a pas de nom
enfin pas que je sache pas à ma
connaissance
et on provoque et prend ses 6 et
challenge accepted par mvl 4 fous B7
petite ligne
inventée à l'époque pas Peter Leko face
à Gary castor au fou B7 ça paraît pas
très très bon de mettre son son fou sur
sa diagonale mais on va jouer C5
et on va ouvrir le four donc Magnus qui
décide de la jouer un peu plus un peu
plus soft cette quatrième partie cette
dernière partie peut-être avec les Noirs
donc clairement
il choisit quelque chose de beaucoup
plus solide que la nage d'orf
alors
on va voir ce que fait Maxime je crois
que faut deux le coup principal ici mais
pas sûr
on va voir ce que décide de faire mvl je
suis pas à jour là sur fou B7 je me
rappelle de cette partie entre Kasparov
et Peter et
directement
tout simplement tout bêtement
qui est ici sont aspire en dessin les
Noirs vont jouer c'est 5 a priori c'est
quand même l'idée clairement clairement
c'est le concept ici de jouer c'est 5
quoi d'autre me direz-vous
peut-être pas tout de suite c'est aussi
ça la question c'est pour ça que manus
réfléchit c'est qu'il se dit peut-être
je peux faire un autre truc d'abord
je vois pas le truc et c'est 5 a été
joué
on ouvre la belle diagonale de ce fou
alors évidemment on a donné la paire de
fou mais on a
légère avantages de développement ce
pion est fort et faible à la fois parce
qu'il peut être attaqué donc pas si
clair selon la théorie en tout cas les
noirs sont ok
Magnus s'enfonce de plus en plus dans
son fauteuil il devrait pas bientôt
fermer les yeux si tout va bien possible
ouais on va faire ces quatre règles en
général parfois avec les Noirs les Noirs
font C4 oui pour restreindre ce fou de
casse blanche
alors C4 plutôt
cavalier F6 au feeling Kebe 4 bon je
sais pas on n'aime pas trop
B4 plus agressif peut-être pour venir en
C6 et en décape intéressant aussi certes
donc deux coups possibles kb6 en général
il y a aucun avenir ce cavalier en B6 je
vais le montrer il a joué Québec 4
Magnus il m'a pas du tout écouter qui
est B6 on fait B3 et ce cavalier est
complètement dominé donc ib4 jouer par
Magnus
et comment va-t-on faire maintenant
avec les Blancs
on peut plus faire foudre
[Musique]
ça a l'air méchant
donc c'est beaucoup moins simple pour
les blancs maintenant de se développer à
savoir si on va tout de suite attaquer
ce pion ou pas faut trois j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a des machins quand
même m'embête un petit peu menace et
chèque double
donc peut-être à trois directement à 3
de jouer et c'est 6 et maintenant X3
les finales sont peuvent être très
mauvaises pour les Noirs
[Musique]
6 juin tempo
8 joue à tempo
et bien ça c'est de la prépa
tourbé 8 pour faire pression sur ce pur
en B2 sur foot français 5 il se passe
quoi doit se passer un truc
je le vois pas je m'aide
x 6
grand rock c'est quoi ça pue le mauvais
coup cavalier à sac on peut pas prendre
à 5 parce qu'il y a dame prend mes deux
maths et on met un kb3
c'est perdant c'est moi - 4 parce que si
alors
la partie c'est ça
donc vous pensez 5 éventuellement x
comment on fait maintenant
mais j'en sais rien moi
j'en sais rien
je suis preneur de toutes les idées
on reprend on attaque on est bien mais
effectivement on n'est pas très bien
développé on sent qu'il va se passer une
histoire d'un mec par exemple
sur feu 2 on a fout penser 4
coucou il y a dame deux certainement
et c'est vrai que vous prend deux qui
est en V4 apprend avec 4 c'est un des
astres une fois de plus à cause du Fou
attaqué il a pris en C5 Maxime va cher
ne bluffez jamais Maxime voilà
ce soit aux échecs ou pas aux échecs à
n'importe dans la vie ne bluffez pas
Maxime
le bluff sera immédiatement
[Musique]
immédiatement je cherche
le mot je vais trouver avoir moins d'une
minute
mais honnêtement
démasqué voilà
alors
comment il fait
il faut le voir fois 6 quand même il
faut le savoir
qui m'a aidé
de toute façon mais
un truc c'est tellement risqué c'est
vraiment les trucs que je déteste avec
les noirs ou c'est très très risqué
stratégiquement c'est accordé à un coup
de
bah faut deux prochain coup on signe
genre petit rock faut deux
on fait ici ton adversaire ou pas
d'ailleurs pour la belle partie
mais enfin en gros encore un coup bon
c'est deux coups
on a deux coups de l'abandon voilà c'est
un truc qui me plaît pas
ouais grand rock pire coup mais bon
fallait voir grand rock grand rock c'est
air de tout pour de tout protéger s'il y
a pas cavalier A5 c'est pas si évident
que ça
mvl calling station
je vois qu'il y en a qui ont les rêves
dans la dans le chat ça fait plaisir
c'est comme ça qu'on peut le désigner x
8 qui est moins bon que X
d'attaquer ces quatre
ouais
donc on est bien tout à fait
tout à fait alors tomber un perd tout de
suite tomber un top tactique d'un F5
attaque de pièces
on prend la feuille de partie on la
signe et on abandonne ça ne va pas alors
grand rock toujours pas bon après
le foudroyant cavalier A5 on est pas
bien donc comment on fait pour protéger
espion
B4 à une option toujours B4 apparemment
le bon coup parce que sur cavalier prend
on va faire puis on prend donc c'était
mieux d'avoir le fond à 6 certainement
pour des fous prends ces quatre sur des
dames sac échec ou ce genre de ce genre
d'amusement
de fou c'est vrai mais oui c'est ça sans
plus paire de fou pour les blancs
effectivement
très bien résumé cash flow
sans plus faire de fou donc
potentiellement
ce serait pas hyper surprenant d'être
complètement raide avec les Noirs mais
il se trouve que les échecs sont un jeu
dynamique
parfois en tout cas et donc
voilà on peut avoir du jeu fubé 4 jouer
par Maxime bien jouer Maxime
et certainement poussé trois prochain
coup et ensuite F3 un truc comme ça et
en F2 et fou E2 et B4 voilà si on laisse
faire les coups je suis bien mais après
évidemment qui va pas il est pas fou
hein
il est pas fou le Norvégien il est tout
sauf
alors comment on fait ici avec les noirs
pour avoir du jeu
qui se penche qui fait pas du tout
attention à la caméra
heureusement qu'il joue bien parce que
il fait pas trop d'effort c'est assez
marrant bon on voit son front et ça
coupe
elle est pas si mal moi j'aime bien ça
coupe d'ailleurs
sa critiqué dans le chat tout à l'heure
plutôt joli
faut deux petits rocs aussi peut-être F3
parce que faut deux c'est vrai qu'il y
aurait peut-être des dames G6 qui
attaque G2 on peut pas faire vraiment
petit rock par exemple admettons petit
rock pour illustrer ce que je veux dire
j'ai si c'est un peu embêtant là on peut
pas faire petit rock parce que
le petit coup de F3 un petit coup de ici
par exemple un petit coup de fouet 3
même G6 F3 on va faire des trois
gentiment petit aussi on peut roi F2 au
pire bon ben voilà et en tout cas à
notre adversaire si c'est s'il a pris la
compter à l'école primaire
et si il répond oui et bien il se rend
compte qu'il a un peu de moi
c'est ça le truc là il faut faire
quelque chose c'est très très important
à 5 à mon avis est assez mauvais mon
cher gg303 parce que ça met justement je
voulais y aller
mais n'hésitez pas à proposer des coups
même si parfois
la nul n'est pas une option
et des quatre et des quatre un coup un
coup dynamique
et sur dame 5 il y avait faux de
prendre et prendre
et il faut ranger deux tourgers on avait
on garde espion de plus donc ça n'allait
pas mais c'était un bon 5 jouer
est-ce que dame 5 était le bon coup a
priori vu la jauge ouais
c'est sûr faut deux il y ait des quatre
maintenant ah non faut dire c'est 3
c'est une transposition pure peut-être x
2 et le coup qui est propre
j'ai deux
est-ce qu'on fait tour à 5 où on fait
tourner
tour j'ai un F3
c'est quoi le coup la tour prend à 7
dame prendre
pour reprendre mes quatre il se passe
quoi il est tombé 5 là
fait très mal
et voyez ce genre de scénario c'est
archi raide pour les noirs
pas du tout
et c'est un peu bizarre
alors je sais que c'est pas un argument
mais effectivement vous voyez on peut
pas ok quoi derrière
après c'est pas complètement c'est pas
assez loin d'être chrétien
peut-être dame
prend des 6 séances on a vite G3 mais
regardez
j'ai trois c'est chaud parce qu'on
recule la dame admettons ici et cahier
des quatre arrivent
ça ça peut faire mal apparemment c'était
pas la bonne case je sais pas pourquoi
peut-être qu'il est 4 en fait
non pas non plus la bonne case qu'est-ce
qu'il fallait faire ah la meuf 6
c'est 3 qui a des 4 OK
bon qu'est-ce qu'il va nous faire Maxime
sur dame 5 x 2 on le sait nous on sait
que c'est le bon coup il doit il a joué
il a joué bravo bravo Maxime qui ne se
désunit pas après cette défaite dans la
troisième
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure qui est pas
bonne du tout pour les Noirs alors
peut-être alors peut-être l'Armageddon
il faut qu'il voit tout géant
ok évidemment
et sur fouf 3 il faut qu'il voit tourger
5 et que sur dame prend de dame prend de
c'est ce qu'il a dû rater Magnus et qui
a tout reprend les cassettes et ça ça
fait très mal et ça c'est complètement
rentable et là c'est complètement
terminé avec ce roi en menace B6 avec le
mat derrière on est obligé de faire
petit rock et là on se prend à 7 on a ce
b6b7 qui est inarrêtable d'ailleurs
tombé utile à B6 on reprend il y a le
mal du couloir et B7 et tour à 8 et riz
zainito
c'est complètement terminé s'il fait ça
il faut prendre les deux
Maxime complètement gagnant en fait
complètement dernière fois tourgé un
est-ce qu'il veut faire un coin
intermédiaire comme tout à 5 peut-être
et tu auras cinq perles le droit de
roquet et donc est beaucoup moins fort
c'est ça son option qu'il est en train
de calculer il faut qu'il voit tourger
et qui comprennent que cette finale de
tour c'est pas évident et d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce qui se passe sur ça ça et ça
pourquoi c'est si bon que ça
peut-être tu auras 5 maintenant
en fait j'ai l'impression que c'est fini
elles sont quand même
elles sont bien caramel
ton projet c'est à toi on va plus
pouvoir ok pour prendre à 7 qui arrive
c'est complètement terminé qu'est-ce
qu'il a joué il a joué tout à 5
malheureusement
dame 4 tours j'ai un fou F3
c'était pas si facile à comprendre la
preuve la preuve
c'est qu'il est deux joueurs ont raté
évidemment nous c'est vachement plus
facile
et il prend en G7 ouais mais ça va je
pense qu'il fait en vrai
tu auras cinq dame
3 tu reprends G7 ça a énormément de sens
ça on peut pas lui enlever et c'est
toujours très très dangereux alors la
jauge n'est pas impressionné mais alors
c'est hyper dangereux les finales de
Tours sont complètement foutus si on
prend mais on prend pas les pièces
clouées
ça c'est c'est rideau c'est rideau mais
complet
donc ça il va pas le faire évidemment et
comment il fait
est-ce qu'il y a un perpète qui existe
par là peut-être
comment on fait sur ça ça ça ça
et ça
ok donc pas de perpète
donc c'est un 0-0 c'est une ligne au
milieu et qui veut dire la position est
égale
donc
il y a de l'espoir est-ce que tu
reprends mes 4 et un coup
visiblement pas
l'idée évidente
qu'est-ce que c'est le coup là
que c'est complexe peut-être on reprend
à ça tout simplement non
et je triche
tour G3
pour forcer l'échange
vous prend deux j'ai dû me prendre
temps
et on glisse
énorme
c'est un jeu très difficile tout à fait
ah oui c'est sûr mais il réfléchit
Magnus Carlson et oui sans le moment
critique il a raison tout AG5 et une
menace aussi oui tout à fait
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai que toi
j'espère
c'est peut-être pas si grave
il réfléchit et c'est quoi le bon coup
d'ailleurs le bon coup c'est ça
il y a fou prendre à me prendre et à me
prendre B2 ah c'est le pion B2 le pion
il a joué quoi et non il a joué l'autre
ok
l'espoir est permis de me prendre ah non
il a quand même ah oui c'est la même
il est là dame
prend B4 il prend tous les pions
il vaut mieux mater là
est-ce qu'il va en prendre un de plus et
jouer roi F8
c'est ça
pas l'air
on s'est perdant
waouh c'est joué c'est un coup perdant
aussi incroyable que ça puisse paraître
ah non
pas du tout
la jauge qui craque qui est fatigué
comme nous et fit d'un meuf 3e
il y a beaucoup de pions malheureusement
pour les
projets
8 et on protège bien ce pion
tout reprend F7 joué par Maxime waouh
alors sur ton
surtout prends c'est fini ces maths ça
c'est sûr
waouh ça peut être raté quand même c'est
incroyable ce qui nous fait sur One
prend ça va être mat aussi comme ça
et donc sur ton prof c'est le bon coup
c'est de pas prendre alors quel est le
bon coup
quel est le bon coup incroyable sacré
Maxime et quelle forme il nous trouve de
cette tactique mais alors c'est délirant
délirant
oh là là tout reprend F7 super coup
pas vu par l'ordi pas vu par Magnus
c'est pas la moitié d'un coup ça
il menace ça d'un F3 le doigt le roi
doit reculer et tourgé 8 mains dans le
cadre coup de centralisation
coup de sang-froid
mais coup de bol je crois aussi pour
Magnus honnêtement parce qu'il avait pas
vu ce tour près cette émission
c'est incroyable ce qui se passe
c'est terminé en fait
je vois même pas comment on fait pour
pas perdre la
échec peut-être au début
et ça
et ça ça gagne pas
comment ça gagne
échec
je mets je triche
évidemment on pouvait pas si on allait
de l'autre côté c'était pas comme ça
waouh donc ça ça
et là je dois faire
tomber 7
chafou joue un coup tout seul vous voyez
la jauge elle l'aime pas
et bien
tombé 7 c'est quoi le meilleur coup
bonjour
effectivement
mais quelle partie
quelle partie
quelle spectacle c'est incroyable ce qui
se passe là
c'est du délire tout recette et Tours G7
certainement le coup
pouf
c'est assez improbable
tout recettes c'est le coup Maxime qui a
fait chier énormément
il voit peut-être pas il cherche quelque
chose qui n'existe pas peut-être
les deux joueurs archi concentrés
qui se regardent peut-être c'est la
magie aussi de ces colles on peut se
regarder
ouais ouais tours 7 tours G7 c'est
vraiment c'est le coup normal mais
évidemment Maxime il calcule tout ça et
probablement il a vu que ça suffisait
pas
mais quoi d'autre en même temps c'est ça
qui me tire le pin
c'est je vois rien d'autre
mais non
il fait tourger G7 waouh mais quel
artiste mais quel artiste
dame J6 seul coup légal enfin
ça fait peur
Tour Eiffel et après on vient de la tour
et H4
c'est magique ce qu'il fait
peut-être 38 là pour faire tourger 7 ça
doit tenir après la
sacro-sainte-georges ça tient et
qu'est-ce qui se passe sur ton bien
c'est quoi la différence
il y a une différence apparemment
non pas de différence
c'est quoi la ligne to recette non mais
là il dit vraiment que c'est pas bon ah
oui d'accord j'ai craqué
quand même
laisse les tours comme ça
je veux bien
mais pas évident il va jouer le temps
il va jouer tout reprend
il va jouer tout reprendre quasi sûr
même six
ouais
bien sûr
j'ai moi-même ne voyant pas
donc on sait pas là
on sait pas en tout cas il menace claire
c'est la moulinette elle a dit que je
t'en prie tout sur la 7e pas très
agréable donc
donc
tu reprends
quel coup
ouais mais en même temps elle est en
ligne droite cette ligne
je remonte parce qu'elle peut être jouée
d'un instant à l'autre est-ce qu'au roi
des 8 est perdant ou pas on débute et
perdant
pourquoi c'est perdant
ça
ça a été joué
c'est comme ça ton projet si c'est la
position de la partie
puis on prend le 6 évidemment qu'il faut
faire
oh là là qu'est-ce qu'il est là
il nous donne le tournis
après la
peut-être ça aussi
gênant
F7 va être joué rapidement à mon avis oh
et un jour en D8 c'est perdant Tour
Eiffel il a cru qu'il était cool B7 et
c'est gagnant maintenant oh il y avait
mieux que ça encore
il y avait mieux ça gagne pas ça ce roi
des 8 qu'est-ce qu'il fallait faire je
vais regarder tout de suite sur roi D8
le coup c'était dame G7 tours 8
et HK tout simplement et enfoncé Adam
mais ce qui est pas des forteresses
comme ça
peut-être qu'il y avait une forteresse
comme ça pas sûr bon on va voir priorité
au direct évidemment dmg5 croissez
wydames c'est 5 3 V7 dame B5
alors là il a envie d'inciter roisser
vite pourquoi j'ai pas la refais
répéter
gagner du temps
à 8 il veut les donner des choix à
Magnus d'après la jauge il est gagnant
Maxime Vacher La Grave incroyable cette
partie en lui a mis le feu et il fait
dame c'est calme maintenant
est-ce qu'on fait roise si s'il veut pas
donner l'option droit à 6 et dame prend
des 7 maintenant il avait pris Mouv' à
me prendre et 7 aussi
il est là sur la prime ça fait bizarre
mais oui effectivement c'est des bons
primov c'est des primo safe c'est primov
de Take fresh bon je fais les mêmes prix
mouvement parfois j'y pense pas dame
prend aussi on a envie de prendre les
pions ou pas
d'après d'après la Jauche je vais
regarder les valves de la jauge voilà
que c'est bien joué des deux côtés
de Magnus Carlsen
c'est pas fini c'est pas fini
c'est loin d'être fini
maintenant si on arrive à faire ça
waouh
alors ça
c'est bien joué hein ça libère le pion
menace 3 c'est 5 en fait le roi est une
pièce la même en finale de dame
incroyable
quelle partie quelle partie encore ils
ont fait un match
et ça montre qu'est-ce qu'il faut pas
faire pour Batman new scarsen
rendez-vous compte a priori il va pas la
perdre celle-là et
Maxime a fait un match mais alors
époustouflant
après il aura une deuxième chance
vendredi si jamais il gagnait pas
celle-là mais c'est pas fini c'est pas
fini 3 13 quand même
ça peut gagner
comment je vois pas moi je pousserai
mais bon ça fait un moment j'aurais
perdu n'importe quelle couleur là
alors à 5 peut-être
ouais
alors à 5 à 5 jouets oui oui c'est
logique on va baisser à ça clairement il
veut créer du contre jeu en gros le
concept c'est je t'échange ce pion
contre ce pion et ça va faire mieux
alors dame c'est 7
et maintenant on va foncer ça va pas
être évident non non je trouve pas le
problème c'est que les pions sont
paliers c'est quand même un gros défaut
il pousse il pousse il pousse il va
venir il va pousser
ou alors s'il peut pousser sans perdre
de pions il va pousser
alors roi des trois
ça c'est pas mal pour créer des des cas
où il fait chèque échec et il ramasse le
pion
après je le vois pas le cas
ce qui va faire à deux peut-être à deux
hein
pourquoi ça perd
à cause de roi des quatre à deux d'un B7
ça c'est bien joué tout à 8 de jouer
et ouais en même temps elle dure cette
position tour à 8 à la place de j'avais
dit quoi moi à deux
moi
il veut ce concept là
mvl
la d'après la jauge vous devinerez
jamais le bon coup
vous enfin si vous pouvez deviner le bon
coup mais là c'est c'est
très dur
à deux c'est mauvais
mais pas assez mauvais pour perdre
et c'est fini il a gavé roi c'est 5 il a
raté
il a raté roissé 5
incroyable c'est pour C8 le coup
effectivement il fallait jouer tour C8
ici ça allait encore la dame B2 il
fallait jouer
il fallait jouer dame ah ouais mais
c'était dur dame prend et roi non mais
c'est peut-être perdant déjà
c'était peut-être perdant en fait il
fallait jouer tour assez vite comme quoi
c'était vraiment archi compliqué
ah ouais là c'est du c'est du + 10
incroyable cette fun partie trop fort
trop fort mdr
quel match il nous a fait
quel match nous fait quel match nous a
fait je parle au passé mais il a lieu
encore ce match il y a de partout là
enfin quasi il y a vraiment pas de coup
là
il y a vraiment pas de coup
il y a vraiment pas de coup bon on fait
quoi là sur Youtube là vous me direz un
petit peu ou pas
merci
incroyable cette partie
incroyable et on va voir droit à l'armée
il est incroyable ce match et Magnus qui
réfléchit à une on menace pas
à deux il a raté ça peut-être
même ça ça marche
derrière
3D 5 et quoi là
ah oui et sur on va prendre ici sur B8
évidemment mais le problème c'est
d'apprendre à deux et chaque EMAT bravo
Maxime et quelle partie quelle partie
c'est largement mérité pour
Maxime lâcher la grave qui revient dans
ce match fou il est fou ce match mais il
a fait des trucs mais alors il a fait
des trucs c'était assez incroyable avec
ça a commencé comme ça et
là il a fait une série de coups tourgé 5
c'est très joli il donne tous les pions
ton propre F7 alors là c'est magique on
peut pas prendre la meca tour gg7 on
peut tout on peut prendre mais enfin
quasi obligé d'AMS cesser si c'était
bien aussi même si c'était bien et là
je sais pas ce qu'il a raté Tour Eiffel
c'était beaucoup mieux
je suis droit F8 ça je sais pas je sais
pas pourquoi il a pas joué ça ça j'ai
pas la ref
parce que sur H4
ça a l'air quand même vachement plus
simple
il a joué roi des 8
et c'est là où apparemment il a
peut-être raté un gars de Mesdames G5 D5
est tellement naturel d'aller prendre le
pion et c'est peut-être gagnant là le
jour se trompe peut-être c'est tellement
complexe que c'est possible la jauge
montré ça et c'est là où j'avais des
doutes
sur si vous voulez ce genre de scénario
ou
en pH7 et en fait ce qui va se passer
c'est que je fais ça
et en fait je me demande si ça gagne ça
ou pas c'est pas si clair que ça gagne
parce que la tour peut faire comme ça
comme ça et le roi va pas trop passer
peut-être ça gagne peut-être pas on ne
sait pas
mais oui à la fin non mais à la fin
c'était chaud tour C8 ouais tour C8
était l'erreur décisive de Magnus
Carlsen c'était celle là à trois rois
des trois ça c'était très bien joué d'un
point de vue pratique fallait jouer pour
DC8
ou tout bc8 un des deux tour des C8
était encore mieux en fait
allez voir avec si peu de temps la
pendule il pouvait encore se tromper roi
B4 et une gaffe par exemple mais il a
fait il a cru en toi 8 roi des 4 la tour
C8 était encore nul
ou pas d'ailleurs il change d'avis
ok donc je sais pas
là il montre que A1 et nul donc il a
joué tout reprendre ici trois C5 et
c'est terminé en menace maths de deux
façons
et
il disait au début que A1 en fait il
change d'avulation très bizarre
maintenant il dit que c'est gagnant
j'en sais rien ah oui ce genre de truc
est-ce que c'est gagnant est-ce que
c'est nul
allez savoir en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'on va avoir un Armageddon de
toute beauté qu'est-ce qu'ils ont dit
oh là là là là là là alors
l'Armageddon est dans 7 minutes
écoutez-moi bien
mvl
il a mis une enchère pour avoir les
Noirs dans cette partie alors on
rappelle 15 minutes pour les blancs on a
les blancs on a normalement plus de
temps mais on doit absolument apporter
si on a perdu donc Magnus Carlson a
proposé Maxime Vacher la grave a proposé
10 minutes et 16 secondes peut-être un
peu fatigué normalement il doit proposer
il peut proposer moi
Magnus Carlson a proposé asseyez-vous
tout le monde est bien assis
8 minutes et 28 secondes
minuscule
donc les noirs
dans 6 petites minutes
magnifiques on va avoir une partie ou
maximale et blanc
6 minutes 32 secondes d'avance à la
pendule mais l'obligation de l'emporter
et les pièces blanches
ça va être magnifique on va voir on va
voir ce que ça donne je reviens dans
quelques minutes
et le temps de passer une pub mais là je
fais très vite cette fois
rester
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
personne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et je suis de retour pour ce match
extraordinaire tout simplement il n'y a
pas d'autres mots entre Magnus Carlsen
et Maxime machine à graves
de nulle dans les deux premières mais
hyper accrochée hyper compatible
vraiment il y avait tout dans ces
parties très très bien joué tout
simplement objectivement je crois une
partie là j'ai vu 99,6% pour les blancs
de précision 99,8 pour les noirs
que demande le peuple et ensuite
victoire de manuscarsen à la troisième
et égalisation de Maxime Vacher Lagrave
au talent dans la dernière et on a cette
Armageddon avec la victoire impérative
des blancs
c'est les Noirs ont le droit de faire
nul
mais ils ont moins de temps et l'enchère
de Magnus Carlsen a été de 8 minutes et
28 secondes assez incroyable
mais voilà c'est son choix
et on a les deux joueurs qui sont
revenus déjà et on va voir cette partie
qui va bientôt débuter
alors où là attendez là ça va pas
commencer il m'a dit 11 alors là il
commence pas en avance et ça a commencé
ça a commencé je vais mettre tout de
suite
l'autre échiquier en direct ou plus
vous pouvez suivre en LIVE j'arrive plus
à parler tellement l'excitation est
grande
alors le Maxime qui a les blancs et donc
voyez 14 45 entre 8,14 une karaoké avec
H4 et bien il avait raison E5 une vente
d'avance ouais cash 4 et très très
agressif de la part des blancs
mais ça promet d'être
explosif cette grande finale on va voir
ce que ça donne
Maxime qui prend un peu de temps mais il
y en a en plus ça peut flaguer à la fin
tout peut se passer tout peut se passer
les enchères en charge de Maxime qui
était à 10 minutes 10 minutes et
quelques mais voilà Magnus qui a décidé
d'avoir les Noirs dans cette partie
est-ce qu'il va s'en mordre les droits
les doigts ou pas on va voir on va voir
ça va être chaud ça c'est certain d'imbé
6 attaque mais la pression surtout sur
B2 d'ailleurs
mais quel match
alors minus qui joue un peu plus vite
dans cet Armageddon moi j'ai vu ouais
moi je préfère avoir les blancs
parce que ça se termine par une gaffe
ces trucs là donc enfin à mon niveau
vous voyez c'est ça aussi c'est eux ils
jouent mieux ils gâtent moi dans mes
matchs je peux vous dire l'Armageddon et
se termine par une gaffe c'est 100% du
temps et à fatigue tout ça la tension ça
termine par une gaffe dame B3 qui
apparemment pas un bon coup
ok la jauge n'aime pas les blancs Magnus
qui a l'air mieux préparé dans cette
carrocane il a décidé de changer un pas
de sicilienne cette fois
et quelque chose de plus solide où il va
il aime bien la structure des noirs très
solides
alors comment on peut faire ici cavalier
F3 on sort les pièces pourquoi pas et
fougères direct ou ça joue très vite
chez Magnus c'est l'air de connaître sa
menace de prendre un F3 est
éventuellement d'affaiblir déjà la
structure mais peut-être prendre des
quatre quoi que pas sûr il y a plus on
baisser de derrière mais si je pense que
vous pour F3 est une vraie menace
alors comment on va faire est-ce qu'on
fait ces cinq
non il prend des cinq quoi c'est logique
de prendre les 5 bien sûr en général on
prend plutôt du cavalier ici parce que
ce cavalier on sait pas trop comment le
sortir d'ailleurs on prend du pion il me
fait mentir
et il veut un avenir plus radieux
radieux pour son cavalier j'arrive plus
à parler là il est trop tard il est trop
tard
cavalier 5 menace
qu'est-ce que ça donne ce truc vous
prend puis on prend dame prend puis on
prend toujours regarder les les échanges
mais ça donne la case H3 pour le four si
on prend un F3 c'est ça le problème
c'est grand puis on prend on a donné du
jeu faut acheter vraiment gênant
donc il a pris d'abord en B3 et il joue
cavalier F5 ok c'est vrai que il y a pas
d'urgence à prendre ce cavalier qui est
cloué
il veut probablement faire 7 voir
foubec 4 et ça a l'air complètement ok
pour les Noirs au minimum
et Magnus qui a joué en une minute tout
s'écoute tandis que Maxime a dépensé de
30 mais bon il avait 6 minutes d'avance
il a plus que il y a plus que 5 ça reste
quand même très confortable
ouais alors en gros il y a une anomalie
sur ce truc d'Armageddon c'était celui
qui a me donner en chair à plus basse
décide si la noire ou les blancs
ce qui est bizarre avec l'enchère de
l'autre
si vous comprenez par exemple Magnus
aurait pu prendre les blancs
avec 10 minutes pour pour
ce qui est une règle très bizarre pour
moi donc j'explique pas comme ça 17 il
aurait pu jouer avec les Blancs et mvl
avec les Noirs parce qu'on choisit
derrière
ça me semble assez étrange une fois que
les enchères sont faites
mais c'est comme ça c'est une règle à
changer à mon avis fossette et ouais
c'est très solide pour les Noirs assez
facile à jouer
et on peut éventuellement envisager
c'est pour ça qu'il a pris depuis en e
hein c'était bien vu un cavalier à fuite
cavalier aussi pour mettre la pression
sur ce pion des ça serait une manœuvre
thématique parce que ce Cavalaire des 7
il a pas beaucoup d'avenir
ok j'ai trop en protège H4 et on va
faire cavalier à fuite là
c'est un coup à la Carsat
c'est un coup je m'y connais pas je m'y
connais pas il joue F6
ok qui est vachement concret M6
qu'est-ce qui se passe donc puis on
prend a priori à l'air vraiment d'être
le coup puis on prend F6 j'ai pris un F6
jouer
et c'est vrai que ça a l'air
complètement ok pour les noirs
cavalier fuite ah je le connais quand
même il le fait plus tard qu'avec les
flics pour faire cavalier aussi c'est
tapé sur ce fou on a les mêmes idées
mais
il les fait il est fait en mieux
c'est tout lui
cavalier aussi est embêtant Maxime dans
le dur là
Maxime dans le dur mais attention il
revient de loin déjà
donc pourquoi pas une deuxième fois
peut-être que j'ai parce qu'on a envie
quand même de protéger ce pion en D4
j'aime bien que j'ai je vois pas aimer
ça je la connais je la connais cette
jauge ça ça par exemple ça développe
alors effectivement les noirs sont pas
mal hein bref 7 ou roi des 7 les noirs
sont bien mais bon au moins ça perd pas
de pion parce que là il y a un vrai il y
a un vrai sujet cavalier aussi il faut
prendre F3 qui prend des quatre bon ben
ça arrive vite c'est au prochain coup
ça a été joué
parce qu'il veut remettre ce Cavalaire
F3 considère c'est une meilleure casque
que la case C3 c'est vrai le Cavaillon
C3 faisait pas grand chose c'est
qu'elles étaient quand même bien
contrôlées et donc c'est très logique
évidemment on va pas prendre ce fou même
ça serait ça pourrait être un bon deal
dans d'autres circonstances mais là ce
cavalier et quand même assez pacif ici
il est obligé de rester par là donc on
prend pas le fou tout de suite on
s'interdit pas de le faire plus tard on
va jouer des coups comme tout 8
peut-être fou B4 on peut plus le faire
peut-être à 5 et oui à 5 pour empêcher
B4 on menaça 4 peut-être de temps en
temps il fait à 4 est-ce qu'on fait B4
ici c'est une grosse décision plutôt oui
plutôt plutôt bécane parce que on n'a
pas envie de la tour s'active aussi
facilement
il fait tout droit aussi qui était une
option pour pas donner la colonne c'est
la même idée
est-ce qu'on va faire un truc comme puis
on prend et cahier des 6 cavaliers 4
c'est peut-être l'heure de remettre de
cavalier en route où il fait il joue
très concret Magnus C5 puis on prend
est-ce qu'on va reprendre du cavalier
pour aller en E4 certainement car il
prend ses 5 ans
C8 c'est quand même pas mal pour Magnus
là
Maxime mais qui donne quand même qui
donne tout là
incroyable cette partie encore une fois
comment on fait est-ce qu'on
contre-attaque avec un lif4 j'ai
l'impression que oui non quoi que on
perd on perd en
perd la funky familière on perd F2 on
perget3 ça va pas et comment on fait
pour protéger spion
j'ai envie de vous dire c'est pas mon
problème mais bon j'aimerais bien vous
donner une solution
je la vois pas la solution il prend il
va pas jouer fou hein quand même il va
jouer Tour Eiffel
c'est l'idée de tout reprendre à 8
tours mais fou c'est 5 et on va remettre
un coup
un coup de marteau là sur ce pion F2 et
si on en est rendu à jouer des choses
comme fouet ça va pas du tout
mais c'est pas facile plus que deux 40
d'avance pour Maxime va chez Lagrave
dans cet Armageddon ça tourne mal pour
le français mais attention mais
attention c'est pas fini ce n'est jamais
fini avec des joueurs comme ça
ouais ça je t'aime pour Magnus il est en
confiance il est très fort ambulette
aussi on se rappelle il s'est fait
battre par Nakamura certes mais il a
battu tout le reste
il était en finale donc c'est des
joueurs ça leur fait pas peur de jouer
des coups avec une minute
ils font des Blitz il faut énormément de
Blitz mais bon avec cet état de fatigue
c'est quand même courageux de proposer
un tel handicap de temps parce que le
moindre problème de 3 minutes on est
déjà mal
Maxime qui sait pas quoi jouer là
c'est moche mais bon c'est pas j'avais
pas de meilleure solution à lui proposer
il faut 3
quand même attaque de pion
c'est moche c'est moche mais bon ça joue
comment on fait pour Magnus je sais pas
peut-être fou des 6 je serais tenté de
faire ça c'est une surprise ouais il
avait pris mon pion prend le 3 et fous
des 6 va être joué je pense pour
empêcher les cavalier F4 ou ce genre de
choses et attaquer G3
ça a l'air pas mal quand même
voilà on peut faire tourner vite aussi
pour attaquer G3
en tout cas faut jouer un coup actif à
mon avis
parce qu'on peut pas laisser les blancs
s'organiser par des coups comme tour des
un cavaliers F4 donc faut faire des
menaces
faut faire des menaces avec les Blancs
ça c'est très clair
vous décide on attaque G3
et
comment on fait
avec il fait tourner un pour attaquer
des cinq contre-attaquer sur des 5
qui est qui est rangé trois ou pas
prends j'ai trois j'en sais rien pour
ces cinq peut-être pour protéger
c'est pas mal aussi de protéger
et de garder la menace pour ces cinq
jouets
ton C5 me plaisait beaucoup une fois vu
et maintenant on a un gros problème sur
ce pion G3 comment on fait on va pas
pouvoir le protéger à mon avis
ça sent mauvais pour Maxime là mais bon
4-39 contre 7 26
il va encore poser des questions
peut-être
ou pas je vois pas quelle question on
pose 4 ah ça doit être à regret mais
c'est jouer quand même il a pris il a
repris du pion G
et maintenant est-ce qu'on a réussi à
cahier des quatre donc on fait pas ça
comment on fait ici avec les noirs
G4 une option pour taper sur ce pion 3
intéressant 4 16 ça peut flaguer ça peut
flaguer ça la fin
qui est décisif pour faire kale F5 ah
c'est bien joué ça encore ah ouais à
chaque fois que je vois les coups
j'adore un tour C8 quelle classe tour 8
pour attaquer le pion ou alors tour G8
qui peut arriver pour jouer pour tour G4
il les voit par série les coups c'est
très très beau ce qu'il fait Magnus ils
sont les deux hommes qui sont au sommet
de leur art c'est assez incroyable
mais attention la pendule Maxime
n'hésitera pas à flaguer ça sera tout à
fait normal
c'est complètement normal de flaguer en
Armageddon il y a aucun souci là-dessus
il y a vraiment même pas de question à
se poser
on flag n'importe quoi
je crois que ton jeu vite va arriver
quand même tour j'ai vite pour faire
tourger 4 à moins qu'il y a un coup de
cavalier dévastateur
dont j'ai 8 a été joué
et maintenant
et maintenant comment on fait
comment on fait cavalier 2 peut-être
dès qu'on bouge de cavalier le roi vers
le 6 les noirs peuvent faire nul le tour
ces trois pour faire tourner cette
qu'est-ce que c'est bien joué ça encore
ça pose de nouveau de nouveaux soucis
et ben quelle partie tour G4 ah il
décide de
d'aller sur son jeu ah ça a du sens ton
C7 on fait roi G6 tour des 7 cavalier 5
ça va être dur parce que ce pion h il
est rapide
ok comment il va faire
Maxime peut-être cavalier F3 pour pas
filer le pion mais bon il y a cavalier
F5
évidemment
352 contre 5 52 minutes d'avance pour
champion français
mais Magnus pour l'instant qui tient le
bon bout qui défend parfaitement
Maxime qui a réussi à poser des
questions et des questions et encore des
questions qui est assez incroyable dans
ce match et c'est pas fini à mon avis
c'est loin d'être fini
on va voir on va voir ce qu'il va faire
mais ouais je vois pas je vois pas
comment on continue à poser des
questions mais ça c'est normal que je
vois pas il va le voir pour moi
certainement un truc comme ça peut-être
est-ce qu'on peut faire ça est-ce que ça
ça marche pour me la SEMAT
oula peut-être ça ouais et sur cavalier
fuit ton fuit on va pas là ici on va par
là il joue ton C5 Maxime machin jouer tu
reprends des cinq va être jouée pour
prendre les cinq jouets
on peut faire recette ah parce que tu
reprends des 6 ne marche pas si on
reprend kf5 mais tu auras chaud
intermédiaire attention coin
intermédiaire il jouait 4 manuscrite
est-ce que c'est un bon coup oui c'est
un bon coup d'après la jauge l'oracle
qui confirme qu'est-ce qui se passe sur
tour des 7
tours des 7 ça a manqué de matériel tout
ça si on va dans là-dedans on va prendre
F4 ensuite ça me manque de matos
et oui les pions qui disparaissent les
uns après les autres
ça paraît quasiment sauvé pour
manuscarsen mais attention il nous a
fait des miracles il peut nous en faire
un autre peut-être Maxime cavalier F5
tout rage 2 certainement
attaque B2 intéressant
tout ça
pour des 7
x 8
ça échange trop de pions ça va pas
ça va pas
cavalier aussi ok le cavalier ml le
cavalier magique
sinon je vais à 32 ouais c'est plus
précis que tu auraschin comme toujours
minuscarsen l'as de la précision sur B4
il va faire ça je connais par cœur il va
faire ça sur B5 qui va faire ça sur
on va là sinon c'est le match des Arabes
si on va et on va faire ça et on va
faire ce mécanisme de nul très connu
c'est ça l'idée
je vous livre rapidement ce que je vois
3 2 c'est pour ça qu'il fait roi de H4
maintenant évidemment qui pousse
il est pas fou ma muscarsen il pousse
ses pions plus que 20 secondes d'avance
pour Maxime ça va être très très
compliqué parce qu'il a pas la position
pour gagner là tu es C4 va être jouée
évidemment qu'elle s'est qu'elle va être
joué
ah il veut faire roi B3 il est là
il est là mvl et il va envoyer le roi et
ses quatre cavalier un peu dominé mais
bon pas tellement
non il va le faire il a joué tu rachète
la même idée et sur roi B3 à mon avis il
fait tout reprendre les deux rois c4k
et il a un pion de plus Magnus Carlsen
ça va être compliqué
de faire en sorte qu'il se passe quoi
que ce soit dans cette partie
elle a échec et sur roi des 5 à tour des
deux
ouais non il y a tour des deux là c'est
c'est caramel c'est caramel pour Maxime
khalie F ça quoi ça c'est hyper safe
menaces attention
menace tour des six mais fin à la partie
qui essaie 3 F8 va être jouée il va
répéter à mon avis Maxime
et non il répète pas il a bien raison de
pas répéter H3 H3 et comme ça sur tout
reprend il y a cavalier 7 attention
quand épreuve si peut-être ah non il y a
tout 6 donc H3 va être joué à mon avis
pour simplifier
mais alors 40 secondes d'avance
peut-être un flingue
avec aussi peu de temps
et oui Maxime qui grimace
il va faire H35 barbelé
mais bon je sais pas quoi y réfléchit
pardon cahier des 5 plus que 2 minutes
pour Magnus Carlsen attention
attention H3 jouer ça aurait été envoyé
beaucoup plus rapidement que 7
maintenant et prendra prend
et 2 minutes baisser le trop c'est trop
c'est trop ton rêve de va arriver
c'est trop de temps
non il fait des échecs et proposition de
nulle de mvl qui sait qu'il a aucune
chance de l'emporter
dans cette partie victoire à l'arraché
de Magnus Carlson on va regarder le
tableau
victoire complètement à l'arraché de
Magnus Carlson qui se qualifie pour la
grande finale là c'était simplement la
finale vendredi ça sera la grande finale
et Maxime va chez Lagrave qui est dans
le loser bracket donc qui a perdu un
seul match qui peut s'offrir une
revanche dès après-demain contre Magnus
Carlson mais d'abord demain il y a
guérir une éponyashi à 18h et le
vainqueur de ce match
joue contre Maxime Vacher la grave pour
défier Magnus dans la grande finale
et s'offrir un nouveau match de 4
parties c'est tout ce qu'on souhaite
évidemment
à nous d'abord à nous parce qu'on s'est
amusé quand même on a on a on a vibré
et c'était c'était vraiment un match
magnifique bravo vraiment
ça ça félicitations à Maxime qui a
vraiment fait un gros match vraiment
très très gros match contre manuscaren
qui est très en forme aussi
donc vraiment là il montre il montre de
grandes grandes qualités et il sera
favori dès demain contre Guéret on est
paumé à Chypre peu importe il sera grand
favori dans un match en deux parties
donc des 19h30 20h un peu comme
aujourd'hui match à deux parties
aller-retour blanc noir et ensuite s'il
y a un magasin et s'il gagne il y a la
revanche vendredi oui il peut s'il gagne
le premier match en quatre parties et
bien il a rejoint un deuxième parce que
Magnus n'a pas encore perdu et donc
Magnus aura le droit à l'erreur vendredi
voilà c'est tout ce qu'on sait mais en
tout cas
gros match de Maxime qui a su revenir
vraiment très très impressionnant Magnus
en grande forme en ce moment c'est pas
une surprise donc ça on a vu un homme
sur de lui sur de sa force
qui a dominé cette Armageddon mais match
qui aurait pu aller des deux côtés merci
infiniment de m'avoir suivi je vous
donne rendez-vous demain
même heure
18h avant
même endroit twitch YouTube abonnez-vous
comme ça vous êtes tous des notifs les
réseaux sociaux n'oubliez pas les
réseaux sociaux c'est toujours bien
comme ça on se tient au courant
et voilà comme ça demain vous n'oubliez
pas et on se rejoint dès demain
pour encore plus de spectacle et le
retour de Maxime Vacher Lagrave dans le
loser bracket mais enfin bon nous avons
raquette ça sera une finale pour rejouer
pour avoir la chance de redéfinier
Magnus Carlsen
bonne nuit à tous bonne soirée on sait
pas Ciao
match
[Musique]